COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATION -- AND WATER PARKS
AND WILDLIFE JOINT INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ON FLOOD MANAGEMENT AND
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS.
FIRST LET ME THANK MY COLLEAGUE
CHAIRMAN BROADER GARCIA FIRST
PARTNERSHIP IN ORGANIZING THIS
HEARING.
I APPRECIATE ALL OF HIS
LEADERSHIP IN THE WORK OF THE
STAFF.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS HAS BEEN A
REBOUND HERE FOR CALIFORNIA'S
WATER SUPPLY BUT THE ABUNDANCE
OF WATER ALSO CARRIES A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF RISK.
A FEW WEEKS AGO I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH THE
FLOOD MANAGEMENT OFFICIALS AND
NATIONAL WEATHER SERVICE.
METEOROLOGIST AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF WATER RESOURCES FLIGHT
OPERATIONS CENTER HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
IT WAS NOT FOR TO TO SEE
FIRSTHAND THE COORDINATION
BETWEEN OUR STATE AND FEDERAL
FLOOD MANAGEMENT TEAM AND TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE NOT CAUGHT
FLAT FOOTED BY A FLOOD EMERGENCY.
WHILE THE SIERRAS WERE INUNDATED
WITH THE RECORD NUMBER OF
ATMOSPHERIC RIVER.
EVENTS THIS YEAR WE NEED TO
PREPARE FOR WARMER TEMPERATURES
IN THE SHORT TERM AND SEVERE
DROUGHTS IN THE LONG TERM. FOR
FAR TOO LONG CALIFORNIA HAS NOT
HAD A REAL WATER PLAN REAL PLANS
REQUIRE REAL DECISIONS IN
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATIONS.
HAVE REFUSED TO TAKE ON THIS
TOUGH ISSUE.
CALIFORNIA'S AGING WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE IS PAID THE PRICE.
THAT'S WHY I INTRODUCED ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX THIRTY EIGHT EARLY THIS
YEAR TO FORCE THE STATE TO
ACTUALLY ADDRESS THE VERY REAL
IMPACTS THE CLIMATE CHANGE WILL
HAVE ON OUR DAMS CANALS.
AQUEDUCTS AND LEVEES.
AS YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA'S FLOOD
CONTROL SYSTEM IS COMPLEX AND
LOCAL FEDERAL STATE AGENCIES
HAVE DEVELOPED A VARIETY OF
PHYSICAL STRUCTURES TO REGULATE
FLOOD FLOWS.
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY TWO EVERY
COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
DECLARED A FEDERAL DISASTER AREA
AT LEAST ONCE FOR A FLOODING
ABOUT.
MORE THAN SEVEN POINT THREE
MILLION PEOPLE ON STRUCTURES
VALUED AT NEARLY SIX HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS STATEWIDE ARE
LOCATED IN AN AREA WITH A ONE IN
FIVE HUNDRED PROBABILITY OF
FLOODING.
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY ALONE
NEARLY ONE THREE RESIDENTS IN
CROPS WORTH NEARLY SIX BILLION
ARE LOCATED IN FLOOD PRONE AREAS.
GIVEN THE COMPLEXITY OF OUR
FLOOD MANAGEMENT SYSTEM THE REST
TO LIVES AND PROPERTY IT IS
IMPORTANT WE INSURE ARMORED SHE
PLANS A ROBUST AND UP TO DATE.
I IS THE TO BE CONSISTENT WITH
THE MOST CURRENT RESTS AND
INCORPORATE THE BEST FOR CASTING
TECHNOLOGIES.
WHEN IT COMES TO FLOOD
MANAGEMENT WE ALSO NEED TO FULLY
CONSIDER THE CONSEQUENCES
FLOODING HAS OUR LIFELINE
SYSTEMS SUCH AS FUEL POWER
COMMUNICATIONS DRINKING WATER?
AND CRITICAL TRANSPORTATION.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO HEARING
THE TESTIMONY TODAY I THINK.
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE WHO'S HERE --
PRINT AND THE PRESENTERS FOR
TAKING TIME TO PARTICIPATE -- IN
TODAY'S HEARING.
THIS TIME ALL TURN OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE -- EDUARDO GARCIA FOR
ANY OPENING COMMENTS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND EVERYONE WHO IS
JOINING US THIS MORNING I WANT --
TO JUST TO ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR
EFFORT IN REACHING OUT TO OUR
COMMITTEE TO PUTTING THIS.
A HEARING TOGETHER IT'S ALL
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE TO THE FOREFRONT --
I ALSO WANT TO JUST ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT -- THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
TIMING.
OF FOR THIS CONVERSATION AS WE
KNOW -- WE HAVE BEEN FACED WITH
TREMENDOUS -- CIRCUMSTANCES THAT --
RAISE THE CONCERNS OF WHAT WE
ARE DOING AS A STATE -- NOT ONLY
TO REACT BUT ALSO TO TRY TO BE
PROACTIVE.
ON THIS MATTER -- I'M HOPING
THAT WE GET A GOOD.
CONVERSATION GOING WITH OUR
PANELISTS.
AND I THINK THE FIRST ONE SETS
THE TONE. FOR US TO SEE WHERE
OUR RESOURCES ARE BEING INVESTED --
TO ADDRESSES ISSUES SO AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE
LEADERSHIP ON THIS AND I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO THIS
CONVERSATION.
OKAY WITH THAT WE WILL -- INVITE
OUR FIRST PANEL. TO THE TO UP
FRONT.
WE HAVE WITH US MEMBERS --
PRINCIPLE FISCAL POLICY AND
SMELLY RO AS WELL AS CHIEF OF
HYDROLOGY FIGHTER IF OPERATIONS
OFFICE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING YOUR
TESTIMONY.
GOOD MORNING I'M RACHEL EHLERS
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
THIS MORNING -- THE SERGEANTS
JUST PASS OUT THE HANDOUT FROM
WHICH I'LL SPEAK IT'S ALSO
POSTED ON OUR WEBSITE LA -- DOT
CA DOT GOV AND WILL BE ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE -- AS WELL
SO I'VE BEEN ASKED TO GIVE A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE STATE'S
FIGHT MANAGEMENT SYSTEM -- ALSO
TOUCH ON FUNDING AND HAVE SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES AROUND THE
SYSTEM AND THEN -- DEFERRED TO
SUBSEQUENT PANELS TO GET INTO
THE DETAILS AND ALSO HAD TO TALK
ABOUT.
EMERGENCY RESPONSE AND
PREPAREDNESS I WON'T TALK ABOUT
THAT TOO MUCH MOST OF MY
PRESENTATION COMES FROM A REPORT
THAT OUR OFFICE PUT OUT.
IN MARCH OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN IT'S KIND OF A PRIMER
ON FLOOD MANAGEMENT IN
CALIFORNIA AND I'VE LEFT A STACK
OF THEM WITH STAFF -- IF ANY
MEMBERS ARE INTERESTED IN THOSE
AND THAT'S ALSO AVAILABLE ON OUR
WEBSITE AS WELL.
SO TURNING TO PAGE ONE THIS IS
JUST A VISUAL OF OF WHAT
CHAIRMAN GREAT ALREADY DISCUSSED
IN TERMS OF OUR FLOOD RISK
ACROSS THE STATE -- BOTH IN
TERMS OF RESIDENTS SEVEN POINT
FIVE MILLION PEOPLE LIVE IN --
THE FIVE HUNDRED YEAR FLOOD RISK
AREA THAT MEANS THERE'S A ONE IN
FIVE HUNDRED CHANCE OF A FLOOD
HAPPENING IN A GIVEN YEAR -- US --
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
STRUCTURES BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN CROP VALUE.
AND I THINK EVEN THESE DATA
WHICH COME FROM A REPORT THAT
WAS PUBLISHED IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN AREPROBABLY
UNDERSTATING THE RISK BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK THAT IT.
TOTALLY TOOK INTO ACCOUNT SOME
OF THE EFFECTS OF A CHANGING
CLIMATE WETTER WIND.
STORMS SNOW MELT POTENTIALLY
MEANT MELTING EARLIER SOME OF
THE PREDICTIONS OF OF SOME OF
THE CHANGES WILL SEE -- BUT WE
CAN SEE THAT THERE'S CLEARLY
HAVE QUITE A BIT OF RISK ACROSS
THE STATE.
TURNING TO PAGE TWO OF THE HAND
OUT THIS JUST HIGHLIGHTS THAT
THEIR RESPONSIBILITY SHARED
ACROSS ALL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT
FOR ADDRESSING FLOOD MANAGEMENT --
THE FRONT LINES ARE THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND THOSE ARE
ORGANIZED IN DIFFERENT WAYS IN
DIFFERENT JURISDICTIONS AROUND
THE STATE SOME ORGANIZATIONS --
TASK TASK THOSE RESPONSIBLE IS
TO CITIES TO COUNTIES AND SOME
TO SPECIAL DISTRICTS -- THOSE
FRONTLINE AGENCIES ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR CONSTRUCTING
MAINTAINING AND IMPROVING THEIR
LEVEES AND FLOOD MANAGEMENT
STRUCTURES DEVELOPING LAND USE
POLICIES.
PLANNING AND LEADING EMERGENCY
RESPONSE AND THEN GENERATING A
LOT OF THE FUNDING THAT'S USED
FOR FLOOD MANAGEMENT.
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL THERE ARE
TWO MAIN AGENCIES INVOLVED THE
US ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS AND
FEMA THE FEDERAL EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT AGENCY.
I HAVE THE THE US ARMY CORPS
GENERALLY IS CONSTRUCTING SOME
LARGE PROJECTS AND THEN TURNING
OVER THE DAILY OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE TO THEIR NON FEDERAL
SPONSORS TO PART PARTNERS EITHER
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL OUR STATE
AGENCY LEVEL -- BUT THEY DO
TYPICALLY MAINTAIN REGULATORY
AUTHORITY OVER THOSE STRUCTURES
CAM INCLUDING SETTING STANDARDS.
AND THEY WILL COME IN AND REPAIR
FLOOD DAMAGE LEVEES BUT ONLY FOR
THOSE LEVEES HAVE MET CERTAIN
STANDARDS AND I THINK YOU'LL
PROBABLY HEAR ABOUT THAT AND
SUBSEQUENT.
PANELS -- FEMA COMES IN IF THERE
ARE EMERGENCIES AND ALSO
OPERATES THE NATIONAL FLOOD
INSURANCE PROGRAM AND THEN AT
THE STATE LEVEL AS YOU'LL HEAR
FROM ALL OF THESE AGENCIES TODAY.
I DID HAVE YOU ARE IS OUR LEAD
AGENCY IN FLOOD RELATED
PREPARATIONS FOR CASTING AND
RESPONSE AND ALSO HAS
RESPONSIBILITIES OVER -- THAT
CENTRAL VALLEY.
FLOOD SYSTEM OVER WHICH THE
STATE HAS SPECIAL
RESPONSIBILITIES KNOWN AS THE
STATE PLAN OF FLOOD CONTROL OF
TALK ABOUT THAT A LITTLE BIT OF
DETAIL IN A MOMENT -- THE
CENTRAL VALLEY FLOOD PROTECTION
BOARD OVERSEAS AND REGULATES
THAT SYSTEM AND THEN -- THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
HELPS IN RESPONDING TO AND
PREPARING FOR FLOOD DISASTERS.
SO TURNING TO PAGE.
THREE MOST OF THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE IS LOCALLY OWNED
AND MANAGED -- ALTHOUGH THE
STATE DOES HAVE SPECIAL
RESPONSIBILITY OVER AT THIS
STATE PLAN A FLOOD CONTROL
SYSTEM.
AND I'VE GOT HIGHLIGHTED ON PAGE
FOUR YOU CAN SEE A MAP THAT
OUTLINES WHERE WHAT THAT STATE
PLAN A FLOOD CONTROL SYSTEM
LOOKS LIKE IN WHICH WHERE THOSE
LEVEES ARE.
AS YOU CAN SEE THEY'RE MOSTLY
ALONG THE MAIN STEM OF THE
SACRAMENTO RIVER AND SAN JOAQUIN
RIVER IF YOU LOOK AT THE DELTA
THERE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE MAP
YOU CAN SEE THERE AREN'T A LOT
[inaudible]
MANY.
STATE RESPONSIBILITY LEVEES
WITHIN THAT SYSTEM SO IT'S
MOSTLY ON THE MAIN STEM BUT BUT
THERE ARE SOME PATCHWORK
SURROUND OTHER PARTS OF IT -- I
CAN DEFERRED A SUBSEQUENT PANELS
TO TALK ABOUT HOW THE SYSTEM
CAME ABOUT BUT THE IN THE
OVERVIEW IS THAT.
WHILE MOST OF THESE LEVEES WERE
ACTUALLY ORIGINALLY DEVELOPED BY
PRIVATE CITIZENS PUSHING SAND
AND SOILS TOGETHER DURING THE
GOLD RUSH.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THEN CAME
IN IN THE EARLY PART OF THE
NINETEEN HUNDREDS AND AND HELPED --
DEVELOP THEM IN THIS PROJECT AND
THEN THE STATE TOOK OVER
RESPONSIBILITY IN THE MID
FIFTIES AND GIVE ASSURANCES TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT WE
AS THE STATE WOULD.
BE RESPONSIBLE FOR OVERSEEING
THIS SYSTEM AND THERE WAS AN
IMPORTANT LAWSUIT IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE THE TURNOVER SCAB
VERSUS CALIFORNIA COURT DECISION.
THAT REALLY ESTABLISHED -- THAT
THE STATE HAS SPECIALIZED THAT
LADY OVER THESE SYSTEMS.
YOU DRIVE A LITTLE DEEPER TO
EXPLAIN WHY -- WHAT THE PROMISE
LAWSUIT ONCE?
WELL AND I MAY DEFER TO MY
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE MORE
EXPERTISE ON THIS BUT I'LL I'LL
I'LL GIVE THEM A SHOT AND THEN
AND THEN PERHAPS TURNED OVER IF
THAT'S ALRIGHT -- BUT THERE WAS
A LEVEE FAILURE THERE AND THERE
WAS A COURT DECISION THAT FOUND
THAT IT WAS THE STATE'S
RESPONSIBILITY EVEN THOUGH.
THE LEVEES HAD NEVER BEEN UP TO
IN MODERN ENGINEERING STANDARDS
THE COURT STILL FOUND THAT THE
STATE KNEW THAT AND THEN
THEREFORE HAD SOME
RESPONSIBILITY -- TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY WERE IN OPERATIONAL.
FOR ANYTHING THAT I GOT THE
THUMBS UP THAT COVERAGE -- SO.
THAT DID ESTABLISH THIS STATE
LIABILITY FOR MAINTAINING THIS
THIS SYSTEM.
ALTHOUGH THE STATE HAS THIS
RESPONSIBILITY AND LIABILITY WE
HAVE IS TO ESTABLISH MAINTAINING
RELATIONSHIPS AND AGREEMENTS
WITH AGENCIES ACROSS THE STATE
TO DO THE OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE OVER THOSE SYSTEMS --
AND I THINK YOU'LL HEAR FROM
SOME OF FROM ONE OF THOSE
AGENCIES LATER AND YOUR PANEL AS
WELL.
SO EVEN THOUGH WE TALK A LOT
ABOUT THESE STRUCTURES -- TO
CONTROL FLOOD WATERS THERE ARE
ALSO OTHER -- APPROACHES THAT
THE STATE CAN TAKE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES TAKE TO MANAGE FLOOD
WATERS -- WHICH INCLUDE.
ACTUALLY LETTING THE WATER FLOW
AND CREATING WIDER AND AND
BROADER AREAS FOR THE FLOOD
WATERS TO SLOW TO SPREAD TO SYNC.
AND WE FOUND THAT THAT HAS A LOT
OF OTHER BENEFITS IT CAN BENEFIT
FISH AND WILDLIFE HABITAT AND
ALSO -- EVEN WATER SUPPLY WHEN
IT REPLENISHES GROUNDWATER -- UP
THE FIRST SO THAT'S BEEN A
REALLY MAJOR PUSH OF THE STATE
IN RECENT YEARS AND I THINK
YOU'LL HEAR ABOUT THAT SOME FROM
SUBSEQUENT PANELISTS AS WELL. TO
LOOK AT OTHER OPTIONS FOR TRYING
TO MANAGE OUR FLOOD WATERS.
SO SKIPPING OVER PASSED THE MAP
TO PAGE FIVE TALKING ABOUT
FUNDING FOR A MOMENT THERE ARE
WIDE RANGES OF ESTIMATES ON HOW
MUCH IS SPENT ANNUALLY ON FLOOD
MANAGEMENT -- ACROSS THE STATE
ESTIMATES RANGE BETWEEN TWO IN
THREE BILLION DOLLARS AS IS TRUE
WITH MOST WATER RELATED
ACTIVITIES IN THE STATE MOST OF
THIS IS FROM THE LOCAL LEVEL --
AND MOST OF THAT THAT LARGEST
SOURCES PROPERTY TAXES AND
POPERTY ASSESSMENTS BUT THEIR
LOCAL LOCALS GENERATE FUNDS IN
VARIOUS FORMS.
THERE IS SOME FUNDING FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AS WELL
ESTIMATES ARE IN THE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ANNUALLY THE
LARGEST PIECE OF THAT COMES IN
THOSE LARGE PROJECTS THAT THE US
ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS
CONSTRUCTS -- THERE'S ALSO
SPENDING FOR DISASTER RESPONSE
AND THEN FROM THE STATE THE
LARGEST SOURCES BOND FUNDS YOU
CAN SEE HERE IN THE CHART AT THE
BOTTOM OF PAGE -- FIVE SOME OF
THEIR RECENT ACROSS THE LAST TWO
DECADES BONDS THAT HAVE PROVIDED.
FOR FIVE POINT SIX BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS BILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING FOR FLOOD MANAGEMENT
TYPE OF ACTIVITIES THESE FUNDS
ARE STILL BEING SPENT RIGHT NOW
ESPECIALLY SOME OF THE MORE
RECENT ONES.
IN ADDITION TO BONDS ARE ALSO
SOMETIMES IS GENERAL FUND
PROVIDED FOR FLOOD MANAGEMENT --
AN EXAMPLE OF THAT IS THE MOST
RECENT BUDGET.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BUT
PROVIDED A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
MILLION IN GENERAL FUND FOR
MATCHING FUNDS FOR TO SOME LARGE
FEDERAL PROJECTS A HUNDRED
MILLION IN ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE ON LEVEES
IN THAT STATE PLAN A FLOOD
CONTROL SYSTEM.
AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION ONGOING
GENERAL FUND FOR INCREASED
MAINTENANCE FOR A DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES ON THAT SYSTEM.
AND THEN FINALLY TURNING TO PAGE
SIX JUST HIGHLIGHTING SOME OF
THE FLOOD MANAGEMENT CHALLENGES
IN CALIFORNIA I'M SURE YOU'LL
HEAR MORE ABOUT THIS IN YOUR
SUBSEQUENT PANELS AS WELL.
FIRST BEING THAT OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE IS OLD -- ARE
LEVEES MANY OF OUR LEVEES ARE
OVER A HUNDRED AND TWO YEARS OLD
AND WERE NOT DESIGNED ACCORDING
TO MODERN DESIGN STANDARDS EVEN
IN THE FIRST PLACE WE SAW.
THE EFFECTS OF WHAT HAPPENED OR
A BILL DAM A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO
THAT SHOW BOTH -- THE RISK OF
SOME OF OUR EXISTING AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT ALSO ARE
CRITICAL DEPENDENCE ON IT.
AND NOT ONLY THIS INFRASTRUCTURE
ALL BUT WHEN IT WAS DESIGNED IT
DIDN'T WASN'T NECESSARILY
DESIGNED FOR THE TYPES OF GOALS
AND CONDITIONS THAT WE FACE
TODAY.
A LOT OF THE ORIGINAL GOALS OF
THE FLOOD MANAGEMENT STRUCTURE
WAS GETTING THE WATER OUT TO THE
SEA AS FAST AS POSSIBLE AND NOW
WE KNOW THAT.
THAT HAS NEGATIVE EFFECTS ON
FISH AND WILDLIFE AND ALSO EVEN
ON ON WATER SUPPLY IN SOME CASES
SO TRYING TO RE ENVISION HOW WE
HANDLE FLOOD WATERS TO ACHIEVE
OTHER BENEFITS -- WE'VE OUTSIDE
A LOT OF POPULATION GROWTH FOR
FACING CHANGING CLIMATE SO A LOT
OF A LOT OF CHANGING FACTORS
THAT HAVE COME INTO PLAY SINCE
THAT FLOOD INFRASTRUCTURE WAS
DEVELOPED -- THIRD OUR NEEDS ARE
GREAT BUT FUNDING IS LIMITED AND
WE HAVE A FEW EXAMPLES HERE OF
SOME OF THE CONSTRAINTS ON ON
GENERATING FUNDING FOR FLOOD
MANAGEMENT.
LAND USE COMES INTO PLAY
ESPECIALLY THE GROWING
POPULATION AND WHERE THAT
DEVELOPMENT HAPPENS.
AND THEN FINALLY I THINK ONE OF
THE OTHER ISSUES YOU'LL HEAR
ABOUT TODAY IS THERE ARE SO MANY
AGENCIES INVOLVED IN FLOOD
MANAGEMENT DECISIONS THAT A LOT
OF TIMES COORDINATING ACROSS
THOSE AGENCIES FOR PERMITTING
FOR FUNDING FOR TIMING.
CAN CREATE CHALLENGES AS WELL SO
HOPEFULLY THAT PROVIDE SOME
CONTEXT FOR THE DISCUSSION YOU
HAVE AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU WERE GOING TO GO ON TO
THE NEXT PRESENTER WILL HOLD
QUESTION AFTER THE THE FINAL
PRESENTER FOR THE SPANISH.
YEAH THANK YOU CHAIRMAN GRAY
CHAIRMAN GARCIA MEMBERS OF THESE
COMMITTEES ARE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE MY
NAME IS JOHN PASH.
AND THE PRINCIPAL CIVIL
ENGINEERING CHIEF OF THE
HYDROLOGY IN FLIGHT OPERATIONS
OFFICE FOR THE DEPARTMENT.
THE WATER RESOURCES -- I OVERSEE
THE FOOT OPERATIONS SNOW PACK
AND RIVER FORECASTING REGIONAL
EMERGENCY FLOOD EMERGENCY
PLANNING.
AND THE STATE FEDERAL FOR
OPERATIONS CENTER AND THE
CALIFORNIA DATA EXCHANGE CENTER
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AT THE BSN ABOUT RESOURCE
AMERICANS NEARING FROM CAL POLY
SAN LUIS IN A MASTERS OF SCIENCE
IN CIVIL ENGINEERING FROM TEXAS
A AND M. UNIVERSITY.
AND I'LL JUMP IN HERE.
GET A CHAIRMAN'S GARCIA AND GRAY
MY NAME IS MIKE MYERS WHY I'M
ALSO CIVIL ENGINEER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES I CURRENTLY WORK WITH
THE TO BE OURS EXECUTIVE VISION.
I REPORT TO ERIKO BECAUSE OUR
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR FLOOD
MANAGEMENT DAM SAFETY WHO HAS
JOINED US HERE TODAY.
SO WANTED.
TO CALL ATTENTION TO THAT.
I MY EXPERTISE AND REMEMBER ALL
THE DEPARTMENTS BY TECHNICAL AND
POLICY ADVICE TO A NUMBER OF THE
DEPARTMENT PROGRAMS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S INTEGRATION AND
COORDINATION OF VARIOUS WATER
MANAGEMENT ACTIVITIES.
I AM CURRENTLY LEADING THE DVR'S
CONTRACT NEGOTIATIONS IN SUPPORT
OF PROPOSITION ONE THE WATER
STORAGE INVESTMENT PROGRAM.
AND PREVIOUSLY I WAS THE LEAD
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN CENTER FIVE THE
PROTECTION PLAN.
WHICH I'M HOPING WILL BE THE
SUBJECT OF THE SECOND PANEL HERE
TODAY -- IN MY BACHELOR'S IN
CIVIL ENGINEERING FROM TEXAS A
AND M. UNIVERSITY WE HAVE TO AYE
HE'S HERE TODAY.
AND THEN I CAME TO CALIFORNIA TO
GET MY MASTERS OF CIVIL AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ENGINEERING AT UC
DAVIS.
WE HAVE HAND OUTS FOR YOU --
WILL BE ALSO WALKING THROUGH THE
POSTERS AND CALL ATTENTION TO
WHICH POSTER WILL BE WORKING
THROUGH -- THESE WILL BE MADE
AVAILABLE TO YOU AFTER AS WELL
SO YOU SHOULD HAVE THE NOW BUT
IF YOU NEED MORE COPIES -- THE
DEPARTMENT PROVIDE THAT FOR YOU.
SO WITH THAT I'M GONNA GO AHEAD
AND START WITH OUR FIRST HAND
OUT HERE WE ARE LOOKING AT WHAT
IS OFTEN CALLED THE STAIR STEP
OR MANAGING RESIDUAL RISK
GRAPHIC THIS IS ADAPTED FROM A
DOCUMENT THAT FEDERAL AGENCIES
HAVE BEEN USING FOR DECADES TO
DESCRIBE.
WHAT WE DO FOR PORTFOLIO
MANAGEMENT TO BUY DOWN RISK THE
KEY POINTS HERE IS THAT THERE IS
ALWAYS FLOOD RISK IT'S A
MISNOMER THAT YOU CAN ACTUALLY
ELIMINATE OR CONTROL FLOOD
WATERS?
THE THE THE GOAL OF ALL AGENCIES
IS TO MAKE INVESTMENTS AT THE
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL LEVELS
TO BUY DOWN THOSE RISKS THROUGH
PORTFOLIOS OF ACTIONS THAT
INCLUDE ACTUAL STRUCTURAL
ACTIONS.
AS WELL AS WHAT WE WOULD CALL
MANAGEMENT OR NONSTRUCTURAL
ACTIONS THERE ARE A HOST OF
THOSE THINGS INCLUDING BUILDING
DAMS RESERVOIRS -- BUILDING A
CONSTRUCTING AND MAINTAINING
LEVEES HAVING FORECASTING
PROGRAMS COORDINATING ENSURING
THE INFORMATION FROM THOSE
FORECASTING PROGRAMS.
HAVING FLOOD INSURANCE -- AS A
MEANS TO PROTECT PRIVATE
CITIZENS -- ZONING AND BUILDING
CODES WHERE WE CAN ACTUALLY MOVE
PEOPLE AWAY FROM HARM.
AND THEN -- ALSO IN THERE IS
TRAINING IN BUILDING EXERCISES
SO THAT WHEN A FLOOD EVENT
HAPPENS THE RESPOND AS WELL AS
LOCAL COMMUNITIES KNOW WHAT THEY
CAN GO THROUGH AND DO -- IT IN
THE CONTEXT OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- JUST SOME NUMBERS
OUT THERE THEY'RE OVER TWELVE
HUNDRED REGULATORY DAMS FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- MOST OF
THESE ARE ACTUALLY QUITE SMALL
THEY DO NOT ACTUALLY HAVE A
DEDICATED FLOOD CONTROL
OPERATION OR DESIGN WITHIN THEM
BUT THEY DO POSE SOME ADDITIONAL
RISK OUT THERE THERE'S
ADDITIONALLY FOR COORDINATION --
THERE OVER FOURTEEN THOUSAND
MILES OF LEVEES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ONLY SIXTEEN HUNDRED
OF WHICH THE STATE ACTUALLY
MAINTAINS AND OWNS THE MAJORITY
OF THESE ARE LOCALLY MAINTAINED
AND THERE OVER A THOUSAND
DIFFERENT AGENCIES WITH WATER
MANAGEMENT RESPONSIBILITIES.
THAT OVERLAP INTO FLOOD
MANAGEMENT RESPONSIBILITIES WITH
ALL OF THIS IN MIND THE LARGEST
ROLE THE STATE HAS ACTUALLY IS
IMPROVING THE LOCAL CAPACITY TO
REDUCE FLOOD RISK IN BY IT DOWN
OVER TIME.
AND THE PRIMARY MEANS OF DOING
THIS IS EFFECTIVELY COORDINATION
AND DISSEMINATING INFORMATION
AND THEN BUILDING THROUGH
EXERCISES AND TRAINING PROGRAMS.
THAT LOCAL CAPACITY TO RESPOND
QUICKLY TO FLOOD EVENTS
HISTORICALLY THE STATE HAS NOT
GOT INTO THIS BROADER GOAL OF
ACTUALLY GOING IN ACTIVELY
MANAGING THE FLOODS OUT THERE
BECAUSE OF THE EXPANSIVE THE
STATE ITSELF IS SO LARGER BE
COSTLY TO MOVE.
PEOPLE IN PERSONAL OUT THERE.
I THANK MIKE.
X. WE'RE GONNA GO THROUGH --
MORE IN DEPTH OVERVIEW OF THE
STATE PLAN A FLOOD CONTROL
SYSTEM -- THAT RITUAL AT A
ALLUDED TO EARLIER AND SO IF YOU
LOOK TO THE NEXT FIGURE -- HARMS
IS UPSIDE DOWN AFTER -- SO THE
FIGURE ON THE TOP OF THE
SACRAMENTO RIVER FLOOD CONTROL
PROJECT AND IN THE FIGURE ON THE
BOTTOM IS THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER
FLOOD CONTROL PROJECT.
AND WITHIN THESE TWO PROJECTS
OTHERS OVER ONE POINT THREE
MILLION PEOPLE LIVING WITHIN THE
FLOOD PLAINS EIGHTY BILLION
DOLLARS WITH THE PROPERTY AND
ASSETS THAT ARE AT RISK. FIVE
MAJOR URBAN CENTERS AND DOZENS
ABOUT FORTY PLUS SMALL COMMUNITY
CENTER.
AND END DOZENS OF ENDANGERED
SPECIES THAT ARE -- PROTECTED BY
THE STATE PLAN A FLOOD CONTROL
SYSTEM.
AND THE THIRD ARE THERE ARE SOME
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE
SACRAMENTO SYSTEM AND THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER SYSTEM OF A
SACRAMENTO SYSTEM IS RAIN DRIVEN.
WHERE THE SAME WORKING SYSTEM IS
MORE SNOW MELT DRIVEN AS WAS A
SHARED AT THE IF THE
INTRODUCTION OF THE OF THE
COMMITTEE?
HAPPENED THE NORTHERN SIERRA YOU
CAN EXPECT ABOUT FIFTY INTO THE
PRECIP ON AVERAGE PER YEAR
RESIDENTS SOUTHERN SIERRA AS
YOU'D EXPECT ABOUT THIRTY INCHES
A PRESET PER YEAR.
AND CALIFORNIA RECEIVED ABOUT
TWO THIRDS OF THE TOTAL
PRECIPITATION FROM THE SIERRA
NEVADA MOUNTAIN RANGE -- GOING
THROUGH UP THE BIG PIECE OF THE
THE CITY GETS A SYSTEM OF
SYSTEMS WE HAVE THE RESERVOIR
THE RESERVOIR SYSTEMS AND AND
YOU CAN SEE FROM THE SACRAMENTO
SYSTEM YOU GOT THE OROVILLE DAM
FOLSOM DAM.
SHASTA IS OUT OF THE RANGE OF
THIS GRAPHIC BUT THOSE ARE A
MAJOR PIECE OF THE FLOOD CONTROL
PROJECT.
WHEN MANAGING IT IS A SYSTEM IN
ON THE SAN JOAQUIN SIDE YOU HAVE
A NUMBER OF?
RESERVOIRS -- ON THE ON THE
MCCALL ONLY CALAVERAS STANISLAUS
WOLLEMI MERCED RIVER'S AS WELL
THE CHURCHILL AND FRESNO RIVER
AND THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER AND
THE KINGS RIVER.
THERE'S A LOT OF RESERVOIRS THAT
ARE MANAGING FLOOD WATERS -- IN
BOTH OF THOSE SYSTEMS.
ANOTHER DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THOSE
TWO SYSTEMS IS A SACRAMENTO
SYSTEM HAS MORE GREAT CHANGED
STEEPER SLOPES MOVE WATER FASTER.
THE SAME WORKING SYSTEM IS MUCH
FLATTER.
THAT CREATES A DIFFERENCE IN HOW
YOU HOW YOU APPROACH THE THE
CHALLENGE OF FLOOD CONTROL AND
IN THE SACRAMENTO.
SILICON VALLEY IS.
AND IN ADDITION -- IN ADDITION
OF THOSE PIECES WE HAVE OF
SIXTEEN HUNDRED MILES OF FEDERAL
STATE LEVEES.
IT WAS DEVELOPED IN THE NINETEEN
FIFTIES WHEN IT WAS ESTABLISHED
AS A STATE PLAN A FLOOD CONTROL
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
IT'S OWNED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND OPERATED TO
MAINTAIN MOSTLY BY LOCAL
AGENCIES.
AND THE STANDARD FOR MINUTES IS
REGULATED BY THE ARMY CORPS OF
ENGINEERS IN THE CENTRE LIKE
FLOOD PROTECTION BOARD.
ANOTHER PIECE OF THIS SYSTEM ARE
THE WEIRS AND BY PASSES.
WHICH ARE UP MOSTLY MAINTAINED
BY THE STATE.
AND AND THE SACRAMENTO SYSTEM
80% OF THE FLOOD FLOWS ARE
PASSED THROUGH THE SET THROUGH
THE THROUGH THE BY PASS SYSTEM
SHOWN IN GREEN.
ON ON YOUR ON YOUR HAND OUT.
IT'S NOT AS PREVALENT OF A BY
PASS SYSTEM ON THE SAN JOAQUIN
SYSTEM THERE'S A SMALL BY PASSES
OFF THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER THAT
CHURCHILL AND YOU SIDE BY PASS.
AND THEN FURTHER ON TOWARDS
TRACY YOU HAVE THE PESCADERO CUT
WHICH ASK ACTS AS A BY PASS.
SAID INFLOWS WEST THE WEST HILLS
AS OPPOSED UP.
INTO THE URBAN AREAS OF STOCKTON --
TOOLS OF THE PHYSICAL ELEMENTS
OF THE FLOOD CONTROL SYSTEM THAT
I WANT.
TO MAKE YOU AWARE OF BUT THERE'S
ALSO IS MICHAEL TO THE NON
STRUCTURAL PIECES TO THE SYSTEM
WHICH IS COMPRISED OF THE PEOPLE
IN THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT MANAGE
THE SYSTEM.
THE PUBLIC ENTITIES.
THEY OPERATE MAINTAIN THE
PHYSICAL SYSTEM AND YOU.
YOU'LL YOU'LL HEAR FROM PANELIST
REPRESENTING THOSE ENTITIES
TODAY OTHERS ALSO THE GAUGE
NETWORK AND YOU AND IN THE END
NOW ALSO STAYED BEHIND THE
MANAGEMENT THIS THE SYSTEM AND
IT'S IT'S ROBUST ENCOMPASSES THE
ENTIRE.
QUITE A BIT OF A WATERSHED --
AND THAT'S LARGELY HOW ARE
FORECAST AND ARE STILL NOT
FORECASTER.
ARE A ARE CREATED USING THE GAVE
SYSTEM.
SO WE'RE GONNA JUMP THROUGH HAND
OUT THREE AND THEN -- SHORTLY
AND A HAND OUT FOR HERE -- WHAT
YOU'RE LOOKING AT IN THIS
GRAPHIC ON HAND OUT THREE IT'S
JUST REVISED CONTACTS THAT AS
WERE MANAGING THE FLOOD ISKS
OUT HERE THERE HAVE BEEN A
HUNDRED YEARS OF OUR BUS
PLANNING EFFORTS -- THIS GRAPHIC
HERE TO PICKS WITH DOTS ALL OF
THE MAJOR FLOODS AT THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IS EXPERIENCED IN THE
PAST HUNDRED AND FIFTY YEARS.
AND THEN ALL OF THE DOCUMENTS
YOU'RE SEEING OFF THE SIDE OR
EITHER PROJECTS OR SOME SORT OF
FEASIBILITY STUDY OR A PLAN THAT
HAS BEEN CLEVERLY WORK BETWEEN
THE STATE -- FEDERAL AGENCIES
AND LOCAL AGENCIES -- A FEW
FLOOD EVENTS IN THOSE DOTS THAT
HE JUST WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
ARE VERY FOUNDATIONAL TO
UNDERSTANDING THE SYSTEM.
IS IN NINETEEN OH SEVEN NINETEEN
OH NINE FLOOD EVENTS -- THAT'S
WHAT MOST OF THE CURRENT
INFRASTRUCTURE TODAY WAS
ORIGINALLY SIZED FOR THE
NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE FLOOD EVENT
WAS VERY NOTABLE THAT WAS PART
OF THE JUSTIFICATION FOR
CREATION OF ORAL DAM.
WHICH MOST PEOPLE THINK OF AS
PART OF STATE WATER PROJECT BUT
IS A CRITICAL FACILITY IN THE
STATE PLAN A FLOOD CONTROL
FACILITY.
AND PROVIDES FLOOD PROTECTION
FOR THE FEATHER AND SEPARATE
LOWER SACRAMENTO VALLEY'S.
AND THEN -- THE LAST OF THE
MAJOR FLOOD EVENTS WAS THE
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX FLOOD EVENT
WHICH REYES REFERRED TO DURING
HER PRESENTATION AND THE CONTEXT
THAT THAT LED TO THE CREATION OF
THE LEGISLATION.
TO HAVE A SYSTEM MY PLAN THE
SENATE BY FOR PROTECTION PLAN.
AND JOHN'S GOING TO PULL UP THE
SECOND SLIDE NOW WHICH IS -- A
MAP JUST IN IS INDICATING AND
THE SPATIAL EXTENT OF WHERE THE
STATE IN THE PAST TEN YEARS HAS
BOUGHT DOWN RISK THROUGH BOTH --
STRUCTURAL IN NONSTRUCTURAL
MANAGEMENT ACTIONS AND YOU CAN
SEE THAT THERE'S BEEN A HIGH
CONCENTRATION OF INVESTMENTS
MADE WITHIN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
NOW PART OF THAT WAS DUE TO
PROPOSITION ONE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR WHEN THEY WERE ADOPTED IN
TWO THOUSAND SIX THERE WAS
NEARLY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
THEIR PORTIONS OF THAT MONEY WAS
SET ASIDE FOR THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
WITH THE REMAINING PORTIONS THAT
MONEY WAS TO BE DISTRIBUTED
STATEWIDE -- BUT THIS GIVES YOU
AN INDICATION THE TYPES OF
PROJECTS THAT THOSE DOTS
REPRESENT ALL REPRESENT SORT OF
A BLEND OF WHAT YOU'RE SEEING IN
THE STAIR STEP GRAPHIC OFF TO
THE RIGHT HERE -- WITH THAT THE
APPROACH BY WHICH WE WERE GOING
THROUGH AND I WANT TO GIVE YOU A
LITTLE MORE DETAIL OF ADDRESSING
CLIMATE CHANGE RISKS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WITH THOSE
PROJECTS ACTUALLY LOOK LIKE.
CAN BE SEEN NOW IN HAND OUT FIVE
IN IN THIS PARTICULAR GRAPHIC
OFF TO THE LEFT YOU'RE LOOKING
OUT THE LOWER THE A BY PASS OF
THE A BY PASS IS ONE OF THAT
SYSTEM A BY PASS IS FOR THE
SACRAMENTO RIVER.
AND WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT THERE
IN THE BLUE IS YOUR BY ASSETS
THIRTY FIVE MILES LONG THE
SACRAMENTO RIVER STARTS OFF TO
THE WEST OF THEIR CUTS ACROSS
THE TOP OF THE A BY PASS.
AND THEN PASSES ESSENTIALLY TO
THE EAST OF THE A BYPASS -- AND
TOGETHER THEY WORK AS A SYSTEM
DURING FLOOD EVENTS ABOUT 80% OF
THE FLOOD WATERS ACTUALLY MOVED
THROUGH THE YELLOW BYPASS THEIR
EFFECTIVELY PROTECTING.
THE GREATER SACRAMENTO WEST
SACRAMENTO METROPOLITAN AREA --
BUT THE INTERESTING THING ABOUT
THE BY PASSES WHEN IT'S NOT
BEING USED FOR FLOOD PROTECTION
IT IS AN IMPORTANT AREA OF
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTION FOR YOLO
SOLANO COUNTY.
AS WELL AS AN AREA WHERE WE
CURRENTLY HAVE A VERY ROBUST --
AB IN A WATERFALL AND AQUATIC
SPECIES AN IMPORTANT FOOD SOURCE
SO THIS IS BECOME A FLAGSHIP FOR
WILL BE CALL INTEGRATED WATER
MANAGEMENT OR MULTI BENEFIT
PROJECTS.
IN THE MAP ALL THE LITTLE WHITE
COLLAR BOXES YOU'RE LOOKING AT
OUR INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT WITH THE ARMY CORPS
OF ENGINEERS AND LOCAL AGENCIES
BUT THE GOVERNMENT AGENCIES AND
THE LOCAL MEANT LEVY MAINTAINING
AGENCIES AND LAND OWNERS.
HAVE COLLECTIVELY WORKED ON AN
ARTICULATED WITHIN THE CONTEXT
OF CENTER I FLOOD PROTECTION
PLAN.
NOW JUMPING DOWN INTO THE
SOUTHERN PART OF THE DELTA
THERE'S A CONCEPTUAL GRAPHIC
HERE FOR PARADISE CUT EXPANSION --
VERY SIMILAR TO THE A BY PASS
AGAIN THIS IS A STRUCTURE WHERE
WE'RE GOING TO IMPROVE THE
CONVEYANCE OF WATER THE WATER
WILL NOT GO DOWN AS SEMI CAN
RIVER AND CAN ENTER INTO THE OLD
AND MIDDLE RIVERS -- THE SIZING
OF WHAT YOU'RE SEEING HERE FOR
THE PARADISE CUT WAS ACTUALLY
CONDITIONED ON FUTURE CLIMATE
CHANGE CONDITIONS SO WE'RE
ACTUALLY GETTING WHAT IS
EQUIVALENT TO A VERY LARGE DROP
IN THE THE FLOODWATERS PASSING
THROUGH STOCKTON MANTECA.
AND A LINE THAT WATER TO MOVE
THROUGH THE DELTA WELL ACHIEVING
HABITAT OPPORTUNITIES AS WELL
.
THE MOST COLORFUL GRAPHICS.
ARE THE MOST COLORFUL GRAPHIC OF
THE OF THE DAY IS IT SHOWS HOW
WEGOT TO WHERE WE ARE THIS
WINTER.
THIS IS A APART PUT TOGETHER BY
CW THREE YOU PICK THE THE CENTER
FOR WESTERN WEATHER AND WATER
EXTREMES.
AND AND AND THE BEAT BUT WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THEM TO HELP
DEVELOP A BETTER UNDERSTANDING
OF THE ATMOSPHERIC RIVER
PROCESSES.
AND AND FORECASTING AND TO BUILD
AWARENESS BECAUSE THIS HELPS US
MANAGE FLOOD WATERS AS WELL AS
MANAGE -- MANAGE WATER SUPPLY.
AND SO.
THIS IS WHY WE HAVE SUCH A WET
WINTER FORTY SEVEN OCCURS
ATMOSPHERIC RIVERS MADE LANDFALL
ON THOUGH -- CONNELL US HALF OF
THOSE.
MADE LANDFALL IN THE STATE IT ON
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
WHY WE HAVE ABOUT A 126% OF OUR
STATEWIDE AVERAGE THIS YEAR.
AND JUST.
THE IN GAME THE IMPORTANCE OF OF
WORKING WITH THESE PARTNERS IS
THAT AN IMPROVED UNDERSTANDING
OF THE ATMOSPHERIC RIVER
PROCESSES REDUCES THE
UNCERTAINTY.
IMPROVES OUR ABILITY TO
COMMUNICATE REAL TIME FLOOD RISK
ENABLES LOCAL WATER AGENCIES TO
BETTER MEET THEIR MULTIPLE WATER
MANAGEMENT OBJECTIVES.
THE NEXT GRAPHIC WE HAVE UP AS
ANOTHER STEP SORT OF WHERE WE'RE
AT THE PRESENT SITUATION -- YOUR
MATE BEGINNING IN MAY HERE AND
SO THIS IS A THIS IS A FIGURE
WITH DATA THAT COMES FROM OUR A
CALIFORNIA DID EXCHANGE CENTER
AS WELL WHICH IS FED BY THE THE
RESERVOIR OPERATORS AS WELL AS
THAT STATEWIDE MONITORING
NETWORK OF GAUGES.
THAT I TOUCHED ON EARLIER AND AS
YOU CAN SEE YEAH THE BLUE BAR
SHOW THE STATUS OF THE
RESERVOIRS.
THAT'S A PRETTY FULL RESERVOIRS
AT THIS MOMENT.
NEARING THE TOP CONSERVATION
WHICH IS THAT RED LINE WHICH IS
ANYTHING ABOVE THAT IS SPACE OF
THE ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS
REGULATES AND WANTS TO KEEP OPEN.
IN CASE THERE'S A THERE'S AN
INFLUX OF INFLOWS IN THAT
RESERVOIR FOR THE PROTECTION OF
THE RESERVOIR AND FOR THE
PROTECTION OF THE THE DOWNSTREAM
COMMUNITIES.
HELLO BAR ON THE RIGHT.
WITH THE KIND OF SNOW OUTLINES
THAT'S THE FORECASTED -- SNOW
MELT IT REMAINS TO BE THE BEST
IS YET TO RUN OFF OUT OF THE OUT
OF THE WATER SHOULD ABOVE THOSE
RESERVOIRS.
AND THAT'S THAT'S DATA THAT'S
COMES FROM ARSENAL CENTER
NETWORK AS WELL AS OUR MANUAL
SNOW -- ARSENAL MEASUREMENTS.
AND SO THAT YOU CAN SEE THE THE
THE WET WEATHER WE GOTFULL
RESERVOIRS AND IT'S ALSO BEEN A
COLD WINTER WHICH MEANS WE'VE
GOT A WHICH IS WHY WE HAVE A
DEEP SNOW PACK.
AND WE PEAKED IN AT FORTY FIVE
INCHES OF STATEWIDE SNOW WATER
EQUIVALENT ON MARCH THIRTY FIRST
AND ALREADY WE'VE LOST ABOUT
TWENTY INCHES.
OF THAT OF THAT FORTY FIVE
INCHES JUST IN THE STOMACH THAT
OCCURRED IN APRIL.
QUESTION SO THE STATE.
DOESN'T OPERATE OWNER OPERATOR
[inaudible]
YEAH CERTAINLY. TO ASK A
QUESTION [inaudible]
THE NORMAL CHARGE EVER
PERCENTAGE FIGURE. 10% 50% 90%
IN A NUMBER ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
WHAT IS THAT NUMBER.
THAT'S THE UNCERTAINTY.
THAT WE HAVE IN THE IN THE
AMOUNT OF SNOW THAT'S GONNA RUN
OFF -- SO WHAT.
THAT CAPTURES KIND OF THE MIDDLE
80%.
HEY I WHAT FOR EXAMPLE I
ACTUALLY FOLLOWED MERCED RIVER I
KNOW WHAT ONE AM THIS MORNING.
IT.
IT WAS NINE FEET AS IT EXITS THE
VALLEY -- JUST LOOK AT THE
MERCED RIVER BASIN I SEE THE 10%
THAT'S A PROBABILITY WHAT'S THE
EIGHT FOURTEEN EZANI.
ARE YOU TRANSIT IN THE 10% TO
SOME CUBIC FEET PER SECOND OR
SOME OTHER NUMBER SO WHAT'S THE
YES CERTAINLY SO OUR OUR MEDIAN
FORECAST.
IS A THERE'S STILL SIX HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY FOUR THOUSAND ACRE
FEET OF WATER THAT NEEDS TO RUN
OFF.
OUT OF THAT KIND OF THE MERCED
RIVER BASIN.
THAT WE THINK THERE'S A 90%
CHANCE THAT THAT.
WILL AT LEAST GET FIVE HUNDRED
FORTY FOUR THOUSAND ACRE FEET.
AND WE'RE SAYING IT'S LESS
LIKELY WERE NEVER GOING TO GET
ANYTHING ABOVE EIGHT HUNDRED
FOURTEEN THOUSAND ACRE FEET.
OKAY SO THAT'S THOUSANDS OF ACRE
FEET I JUST DID YEAH SEE WHERE
THAT WAS EXPLAINED THANK YOU.
YEAH.
YOU FOR THE QUESTION.
ALLOW ME TO CLARIFY.
SO THE STATE DOESN'T OWN AND
OPERATE ALL OF THESE RESERVOIR
IS THE ONLY ONE THAT IT OUTLINES
AND OPERATES IS.
IS LIKE OR DISLIKE ORAL -- THE
REST ARE OPERATED BY THE BUREAU
OF RECLAMATION THE ARMY CORPS OF
ENGINEERS AND SEVERAL LOCAL
LOCAL WATER DISTRICTS TURLOCK
IRRIGATION DISTRICT -- ON THE TO
ONLY RIVER AND THEN WERE SITTER
ADDITION DISTRICT ON THE ON A ON
THE ON THE I NEVER SAID RIVER
BASIN.
THINKING IS RIVER WATER
AUTHORITY ON THE KINGS RIVER
BASIN.
AND SO WHILE MOVING TO THE NEXT
GRAPHIC WELL THIS WELL THIS
LOOKS DAUNTING -- NOW THERE'S
THERE'S A LOT OF SNOW NOT YET TO
COME AND THE SAN JOAQUIN READY
AS YOU SAW ON THE DESCRIPTION OF
THE STATE PLAN OF THE CONTROL
THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER SYSTEM AND
THE AND THE LEVY SYSTEM.
DOESN'T HAVE NEAR THE CAPACITY
OF THE SACRAMENTO RIVER SYSTEM
THESE FLOWS NEED TO BE MANAGED.
AND THIS MAN IS COOPER RELIEF TO
OUR FORECAST COURTED OPERATIONS
GROUP WITHIN WITHIN OUR OFFICE.
AND WHICH IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
AND AND IN THE KNOWING THAT
[inaudible]
THAT.
THE STATE CAN'T FORCE ANYONE
OPERATE.
A RESERVOIR THE MAYBE WE WOULD
LIKE TO REDUCE FLOOD RISKS SO WE
WERE COOPERATE FULLY WITH THEM.
TO HELP BY GIVING THEM -- GIVING
OUT FUNDS TO HAVE BETTER GAUGING
STICKING OUT BETTER DATA WITHIN
THE BASINS AND DEVELOPING TOOLS
LIKE THE ONE THAT YOU SEE ON OUR
ON OUR ON THE NEXT SLIDE HERE
THAT'S UP -- TO HELP THEM MANAGE
AND AND AND WORK THROUGH SOME OF
THE SCENARIOS THE WORST CASE AND
BEST CASE SCENARIOS -- ON HOW
THEY WANT TO MANAGE MANAGE THOSE
RESERVOIRS.
AND SO ON THAT ON THE TOP FIGURE
IT'S COULD YOU THE SNAPSHOT
THAT'S TO COME THAT'S THE
PICTURE OF THIS THE THE UPPER
SAN JOAQUIN SYSTEM -- FROM THE
KINGS RIVER ALL THE WAY ALL THE
WAY UP. TO TO GET STANISLAUS
RIVER BASIN.
AND AT THE MOMENT EVERYTHING IS
LOOKING PRETTY GREEN GREENS GOOD --
THAT YELLOW YOU SEE I DON PAGERS
ONLY A CALL BECAUSE THE DATA
THERE IS A DAY OLD.
AND SO AS WE WANNA MAKE SURE
WORKING WITH NEW DATA AND
THAT'LL TURN GREEN WHEN IT'S
WHEN WE GOT NEW DATE IN THERE.
AND ON THE BOTTOM SLIDE THE
BOTTOM OF THAT SLIDE THERE.
IS IS THE ACTUAL UP.
PROGRAM THAT WE'VE DEVELOPED AND
IT'S HOSTED BY OUR CALIFORNIA
DID EXCHANGE CENTER THAT THE
RESERVOIR OPERATORS HAVE ACCESS
TO AND THEY CAN USE. TO TO TEST
AND SEE HOW THEY'RE DIFFERENT
RESTAURANT RATIONS MIGHT
INFLUENCE -- THE FLOOD CONTROL
SYSTEM DOWNSTREAM AND SO THEY
CAN PLAY WITH DIFFERENT SOURCES
OF SNOW MELT DATA THE
DEPARTMENTS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
AND RIVER RIVER FORECAST CENTERS.
THEY CAN ALSO PLAY WITH
DIFFERENT -- SNOW MELT.
STILL NOT SHAPES AND EARLY MELT
MAYBE A LATE MELT SO THAT THEY
CAN KIND OF PLAY WITH THE TIME
OF HOW THAT MIGHT COME ALSO THEY
CAN REALLY TRY TO OPTIMIZE THEIR
RESERVOIR OPERATION TO MEET THE
BILL WHAT I BENEFIT NEEDS ONE IS.
TO CLEARLY THEY WANT TO FILL THE
RESERVOIR BY THE END OF MONTH
AND INTO THEY WANT THEY DON'T
WANT TO DO THAT IN SUCH A WAY
THAT PUTS THE DOWNSTREAM FLOOD
CAN.
FLOOD SYSTEM AT RISK -- AND THAT
THEY GET TO FALL TO EARLY AND
THEN.
WE GET A SURPRISE IN THE SNOW
MELT AND THEY HAVE TO YOU KNOW
MAYBE THEY STILL HAVE NO CONTROL
RELEASE.
SO THIS THIS FLOOD CONTROL
FORECAST COURTING OPERATIONS
EFFORT -- IS GOING ON ITS
ELEVENTH ALMOST TWELVE YEAR NOW --
WE GOT THE SUPPORT OF THE ARMY
CORPS OF ENGINEERS WHO WORK WITH
THE SYSTEM AS WELL THE
CALIFORNIA AND RIVER FORECAST
CENTER AND THE RESERVOIR
OPERATORS THEMSELVES YOU. TO
WORK PROPERLY TO TO MANAGE AND
AND SO EVERYONE CAN ALL TAKE
THEIR TURN IN RELEASING WATER
INTO THE SAN JOAQUIN SYSTEM
[inaudible]
AND THEN.
WHAT WE'RE ABLE TO DO IS?
AS WE WORK WITH THEM ON ON THE
RESERVOIR OPERATIONS WE CAN
COMMUNICATE THAT INFORMATION.
THE DASHING FLOOD MANAGERS THE
COUNTY EMERGENCY MANAGERS THE
LOCAL LEVY MAINTAINING AGENCIES
SO EVERYONE'S AWARE OF OF WHAT
RESERVOIR MIGHT BE AT RISK OF
SPELLING OR HAVING A HAVING A
RELEASE THAT COULD CHALLENGE THE
CAPACITY OF THE FLOOD CONTROL
SYSTEM.
AND AND WITH THAT AWARENESS
WEAKENED THE STATE CAN PRE
POSITIONED RESOURCES AND PEOPLE --
IN ANTICIPATION OF THOSE.
OF A POTENTIAL FLOOD RELEASES.
BUT AT THE MOMENT.
IT'S LOOKING PRETTY GOOD.
SO IN CONCLUSION -- NEAR TERM
WILL CONTINUE TO FORECAST WILL
CONTINUE TO VERIFY -- OUR DATA
AND AND RECALIBRATE THE MODELS
AND THIS IS UPDATED DAILY ON A
REAL TIME BASIS WITH THE
RESERVOIR OPERATORS.
A WILL CONTINUE.
TO WORK WITH THROUGH THE
FORECASTED COURTED OPERATIONS
PROGRAM AND COMMUNICATE
INFORMATION TO THE DOWNSTREAM
FLOOD MANAGERS.
AND WILL CONTINUE.
TO LOOK FOR NEEDS TO PRE
POSITION MATERIALS AND AND
PEOPLE AN ANTICIPATION OF A OF A
HIGH WATER EVENT ON THE SAN
JOAQUIN SYSTEM [inaudible]
WE'RE DONE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible] FOR THE
ACTUAL PRESENTATIONS AND
CERTAINLY BRIDGE TOPIC AT THIS
TIME WILL BRING ABOUT THE
NUMBERS I SEE THE MYSTICAL YES
QUESTION.
AND I WAS SORT OF MULTI TASKING
SO SHAME ON ME.
BUT DO YOU END UP HAVING A IS
THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER SYSTEM
REQUIRE GREATER COORDINATION
AMONG SORT OF PARTNER AGENCIES.
MY SENSE IS THE SACK ROSE MORE
STATE BROWN.
THAT THAT THE BIG RELEASES ARE
ARE.
MADE BY STATE AGENCIES IN
COORDINATION ORVILLE FALL SOME.
TO WEAR THOSE SORTS OF THINGS IT
LOOKS LIKE THERE'S A NEED FOR
MORE.
COORDINATION.
OF INDEPENDENT AGENCIES EACH
WITH A PIECE TO CONSENT WATER
INTO THE COMMON CHANNEL.
IS THAT MORE RECORD NATION.
ON THE SAN JOAQUIN.
AMONG PART RATES USE AS OPPOSED
TO WITHIN.
THE STATE D. W. R..
AND HOW TO AND IS THAT WORK
GENERALLY.
PRETTY WELL YEAH I THINK YOU YOU
MAKE A GREAT POINT THERE -- WE
DO HAVE A SIMILAR FORECAST
COURTED OPERATIONS GROUP ON THE
SACRAMENTO SYSTEM PASSED BETWEEN
THE HAVE TO ORVILLE AND AND THE
FED I DON'T KNOW WHEN THE WATER
FROM MORE OF BILL IS GOING TO
PASS THE CONFUSED AMERICAN
REVERSAL THAT FALL SOME WATER
CAN. SEVEN BEHIND IT AND VICE
VERSA. FOR EXAMPLE -- BUT HERE
YEAH YOU'RE RIGHT THERE'S
THERE'S MORE RESERVOIRS ON THE
SAN JOAQUIN -- THERE'S LESS.
THE STATE DOESN'T MAINTAIN.
ANY OF THE SYSTEM ON THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER THAT'S ALL
MAINTAINED BY LOCAL LIVING
MAINTAINING AGENCIES -- AND
RECOGNIZING THE NEED FOR THE FOR
ADDED COORDINATION AT THAT POOR
LEVEL LIKE YOU SAID AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL -- WE'VE THE THE STATE
THROUGH ITS PROP TWENTY AND ON
MY PROPERTY FOR FINDING US AS
PUT SOME LOCAL ASSISTANCE
DOLLARS OUT THERE -- TO THE TUNE
OF ABOUT THIRTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO ENCOURAGE LOCALS --
THE LOCAL NOT LETTING
MAINTAINING AGENCIES TO COME
WHEN YOU COULD BE BETTER ALIGNED
WITH THEIR COUNTY OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES.
AND THOSE COUNTY OFFICES OFFICES
OF THE BRITISH SERVICE TO BE
MORE AWARE OF WHAT EACH OTHER'S --
AND YOU KNOW IT'S WITH A LOT OF
A LOT OF PLANNING AT THE LOCAL
AND COUNTY LEVEL FOR EMERGENCIES
FLOOD EMERGENCY SPECIFICALLY --
TRAINING EXERCISES AT THE COUNTY
LOCAL LEVEL AND THEN -- BUILDING
STOCKPILES OF FLOOD BY MATERIALS
AT THE COUNTY AND LOCAL LEVEL --
DANIELLE.
IT HAS BEEN A SUCCESS AND I
THINK YOU'LL HEAR FROM ONE OF
THE PANELLISTS LATER ON YOU CAN
AND MAYBE SPEAK TO SOME OF THAT --
AND SO YEAH THAT THAT THAT IS A
NEED FOR FOR GREATER
COMMUNICATION AND COORDINATION
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
IT HAD A SURE OF THAT ALL TWENTY
CHANNELS ONLY SO LARGE.
AND YOU CANNOT HAVE ALL THE
AGENCIES SENDING WATER OFF THEIR
LITTLE PIECE.
IT WAS ALL GUNNA CONVERSION A
POINT IN THE CHANNEL WORD.
OVERFLOWS.
SO YOU SORT OF HAVE TO HAVE A
TIME IN A QUEUE IN SEQUENCE SEEN.
IN PEOPLE AND FOR THOSE PIECES
OUT.
AND I'M GENERALLY FIRMER WAS OUT
ON THE ON THE SACRAMENTAL -- AND
I I I KNOW THAT YOU GUYS KNOW
HOW LONG IT TAKES TO WATER FOR
MORE REAL TO PASS THE CONFLUENCE
OF THE AMERICAN RIVER OR THE
WHERE WHEN IT'S OPEN AND AND
CONSEQUENTLY.
WHEN WHEN RELEASE COULD BE MADE
FROM FULSOME AND TRAVEL -- DOWN
PAST MY CITY AND IT JUST.
THE THE TIMING OF ALL THESE
PIECES I JUST SORT OF ASSUMED AT
THE STATE LEVEL ON THE NORTH ON
THE SACRAMENTO RIVER.
IT WAS GOT THAT HANDLED.
AND YOU MANAGE MORE THAT IN
HOUSE.
AS OPPOSED TO NEEDED IT JUST
CORD AND EVERYONE WITH THEIR
PIECE.
I'D I'D SAY IT'S SETTLED -- I
WOULDN'T CALL IT IN HOUSE I
WOULDN'T WE'RE NOT WE'RE WE'RE
NOT TRAFFIC COPS OUT THERE THAT
ARE YOU KNOW.
IT'S MORE OF A ROUND ABOUT.
THAT IS THAT A FOUR WAY STOP.
IF THERE IS MAYBE THE WAY I'D.
WELL I DEFINITELY SEE THAT ON
THE SAN JOAQUIN AYE AYE ME MY
SENSE IS THERE'S MORE STATE.
CONTROL ON THE SACRAMENTAL THE
NORTHERN END MAYBE I'M.
YES TO SIMPLISTIC WHEN I WOULD
LIKE TO JUST ADD IT'S IN CONTEXT
AND LOT OF PEOPLE ARE FAMILIAR
WITH THIS THE THE SAN JOAQUIN I
THINK BIãU IS MEMBERS ARE
AWARE THIS THE MOUNTAINS THERE
ARE HIGHER HITS THE SNOW BASIN.
THE RESERVOIRS IN THE SACRAMENTO
BASE ARE ACTUALLY A BIT YOUNGER --
THEY WERE NEWER FACILITIES AND
WE HAVE LEARNED FROM SOME OF THE
LESSONS ON HOW TO COORDINATE
EARLY ON IN THE FIFTIES THE
CHALLENGES IN THE SAN JOAQUIN.
SO WHEN THE FLOOD CONTROL POLLS
WERE ESTABLISHED FOR WELL NEW
BULLARD SPARSE ON THE FEATHER
AND THE UNIVERSE THERE WAS A
JOINT OPERATIONAL CONSIDERATION
THAT WAS PUT INTO THAT FLOOD
OPERATION THERE.
SO THERE THE REASON THAT YOU
HAVE.
EARLIER COORDINATION ON THE
SACRAMENTO BASIN IT WAS ACTUALLY
PLACED INTO THE ACTUAL RULES OF
HOW THEY WOULD WORK TOGETHER.
I HAD A COUPLE.
A COUPLE QUESTIONS -- AND I
WOULD DRAW BOTH THE COMMITTEE'S
ATTENTION AND THE PANELS
ATTENTION.
TO THIS IS DOCTOR THE DOCUMENT
TAKING ACTION TO REDUCE
RESIDENTIAL FUND RISK IF WE GO
TO PAGE.
SEVEN WE HAVE RESERVOIR
CONDITIONS AND SNOW ABOUT
[inaudible]
TWENTY NINETY A AND IT WOULD
JUST A QUICK.
CLICK GLIMPSE OF THIS DOCUMENT --
WHAT'S CONCERNING.
IS CERTAIN RIVERS.
WELL DRAW YOUR ATTENTION TO THE
SAN JOAQUIN FOR EXAMPLE.
HAVE SNOW MELT.
AND I SERVICES AND THOUSAND ACRE
FEET RISE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT --
A 10% CHANCE OF THE WORK WORST
CASE SCENARIO WHAT WAS AT ONE
POINT SIX MILLION.
ACRE FEET OF WATER IN THE SNOW
MELT.
THAT'S A 10% CHANCE AND THE
RESERVOIR CAPACITY IS DOWN AT
WHAT SEE. 65% CAP ON IS THAT
LESS THAN A HALF A MILLION ACRE
FEET.
I THINK IT IS.
YEAH.
SO.
IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THAT AND
THEN YOU TAKE YOUR EYES AND HEAD
UP TO THE TOP LEFT CORNER HERE
WITH THE SACRAMENTO RIVER BASIN.
THEY'RE SITTING ON FOUR AND A
HALF MILLION ACRE FEET OF
STORAGE.
AND THEIR CAP IS AT 94% OF THAT --
WHATEVER THAT WORKS OUT TO A
LITTLE OVER FOUR MILLION ACRE
FEET.
OF STORAGE AND AND IF YOU LOOK
TO THIS THE SNOW PACK THERE IS
OBVIOUSLY SO MY POINT BEING.
IN SOME RIVERS WE'VE GOT LOTS OF
STORAGE.
AND SMALLER SNOW PACKS AND THEN
DOWN HERE WE'VE GOT BIG SNOW
PACKS AND NOT ENOUGH STORAGE IT
LOOKS LIKE -- WHICH TELLS ME
THAT WE'RE RELEASING A LOT OF
WATER IF WE HIT THAT 10%
SITUATION AND OR WERE FLOODING
RIGHT.
YEAH IT IS THAT AN ACCURATE
STATEMENT.
AND SO TO THE LAY PERSON OR THE
COMMONSENSE PERSON.
YOU WOULD THINK WE NEED TO BUILD
SOME MORE STORAGE ON THIS
PARTICULAR RIVERS.
IN ORDER.
TO ACHIEVE.
YOUR BETTER FLOOD CONTROL
SITUATION.
AT LEAST HAVE SOME.
HELLO FLOODPLAIN MANAGEMENT OR
SAYS SOMETHING THERE'S GOT TO BE
SOME ADDITION -- WHAT WOULD YOU
ALL SUGGEST -- I IT'S ACTUALLY
THE PORTFOLIO JUST LIKE
SUGGESTED OUT THERE IT'S A
COMBINATION OF ACTIONS -- KING
TO THE HAND OUT ONE WHERE YOU
CAN KIND OF A HIGH LEVEL SEE
SOME OF THOSE -- THERE'S THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO THROUGH --
OVER TIME AND TALK ABOUT WHAT
THAT YELLOW PORTION NOW.
CALL THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER BASIN
IS OUT THERE THAT FLOOD CONTROL
POOL IS.
A THREE OPERATION REDEFINED THE
YELLOW VERSES THE BLUE SO THAT
YOU HAVE MORE SPACE IN THE
YELLOW TO PUT.
THE SNOW INTO WHICH IS I THINK
WHAT WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THAT'S ONE OPTION -- RACHEL
TALKED EARLIER IN HER PORTFOLIO
DISCUSSING THAT AS THE STATE
ACTIONS OUT THERE THERE'S THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO SEEK EASEMENTS --
DOWNSTREAM AND IDENTIFY AREAS
WHERE THE THE THE ACTUAL
CONSEQUENCES OF FLOODING OUR
LAST AND THOSE ARE JUST TWO
EXAMPLES OF THINGS WE COULD GO
THREE NEW -- THE THIRD THING
THAT I POINT OUT IS IN SOME
SMALL INSTANCES THROUGH
PROPOSITION ONE THE STATE IS
INVESTING TO TWO POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN STORAGE
PROJECTS ONE ON EXACTLY THAT
POINT.
IT WAS AS A MEMBER WHO IS HERE
WHEN WE MOVE FORWARD WAS STORAGE
FUNDING.
WITH THE CONCEPT THAT THAT
STORAGE FRONT WOULD ACHIEVE IN
THIS EXACT REASONS THEY WERE
TALKING ABOUT -- INVESTMENT
INTERPRETS FIGHT RESERVOIR WHICH
I BELIEVE IS ON THE SAN JOAQUIN.
YOUR CORRECT YES IN THE END YOU
KNOW HOW MANY ACRE FEET -- THAT
POTENTIAL PROJECT WOULD HAVE --
STORED.
I DON'T KNOW THE EXACT NUMBER ON
THAT HOWEVER I CAN'T CONFIRM
THAT THAT PARTICULAR PROJECT --
DOES HAVE WHAT WE CALL
INCIDENTAL FLOOD RISK BENEFITS
IN THE STATUS COST SHARING TO
ADDRESS THAT VERY ISSUE -- IT
JUST STRIKES ME AGAIN THAT YOU
KNOW IN SOME AREAS WE'VE GOT WAY
WHAT WE HAVE ADEQUATE STORAGE
OTHERS WE DON'T AND I'M NOT SURE
THAT WE'RE MOVING FORWARD TO
WHERE I KNOW THE WATER
COMMISSION SCORED SOME OF THESE
PROJECTS THAT WE THAT WE FUNDED.
THROUGH THE WATER BOND -- AT
LEVELS THAT YOU MAY NOT SEE THEM --
BUILT AND THIS.
IS CONCERNING AND IT DOESN'T SEE
LIKE DOES HE LIKE REPORT WE'RE
MAKING AVAILABLE ALL THE TOOLS.
FOR FLOOD MANAGEMENT AND I'M
KIND OF CURIOUS.
WHY THAT IS SIR IF THE AND AND
WHY IS THAT NOT IN THE STATE
MANAGEMENT -- PORTFOLIO WE WILL
GET BACK TO THE PATERNAL FIRST
CALIFORNIA THE ESTABLISH OF THE
S. P. FC.
WHY DID THAT NOT MOVE UPSTREAM --
UP.
BUT A LITTLE BIT OF THAT AND I
THINK THE SECOND PANEL PROBABLY
WOULD WANNA PROBABLY ADDRESS
THAT AS WELL -- THE STATE PLAN A
FLOOD CONTROL THE ONLY RESERVOIR
THAT'S ACTUALLY PART OF THAT
SYSTEM IS OR BILL BECAUSE THE
STATE ACTUALLY OWNS OR BILL
WE'RE ALL OF THE RESERVOIRS WE
HAVE IN THE SAN JOAQUIN OR
EITHER FEDERAL OR LOCAL ENTITIES.
THIS BILL IS YOUR QUESTION.
YOU'RE YOU'RE ON TRACK TO KEEP
GOING.
THE JURORS SO FIRST -- ONE I
KNOW MR CORY ASKED LOOK ABOUT
THE DATA.
HOW DOES THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES -- MAKE THIS
PSYCHOLOGY DATA AVAILABLE FOR
LOCAL OF FOLKS IN A WAY THAT --
IT'S UNDERSTANDABLE -- RIGHT
ABOUT THAT SO BUT BASIC QUESTION
A WE'D LIKE TO GET A SENSE OF
WHAT THAT.
SYSTEM LOOKS LIKE IN PLACE.
YEAH WE WE WE THAT'S A THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT PART IS TO MAKING SURE
THAT THE DATA THAT WORD THAT
WORK WE'RE COLLECTING AND WE'RE
ANALYZING IS BEING DESCENDED IN
A WAY THAT'S UNDERSTOOD BY THOSE
THAT THOSE THAT NEED IT.
AND SO -- WHEN WE MAKE AVAILABLE
DATA REAL TIME THAT THE DATA YOU
FIND ON CALIFORNIA DATA EXCHANGE
CENTER WHICH WE USE PRETTY
EXCLUSIVELY IS NOT YOU SEE THIS
THIS THE RAW DATA COMING IN FROM
THE FROM THE GAUGES -- AND THAT
SO THAT'S AVAILABLE ON THE
INTERNET -- ANYONE CAN GO TO
THAT GO TO THAT WEBSITE -- WE
ALSO PARTNER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
NEVADA RIVER FORECAST CENTER.
THEY ISSUE YOU KNOW YOU MAY BE
AND THE YOU KNOW THEY THEY ISSUE
THERE FOR THE RIVER FORECAST ON
THEIR OWN.
ON THEIR OWN PAGE BUT WE WE
CONTRIBUTE TO THAT ANALYSIS.
AND AND AND THAT'S AVAILABLE
PUBLICLY ON THE INTERNET.
AND AND WE ALSO DO HIGH WATER
NOTIFICATION CALLS WILL ACTUALLY
CALL LADY LOOK LOCALLY BLOODY
MAINTAINERS UP OR INTERESTED
STAKEHOLDERS.
UP AND LET THEM KNOW WHEN OF
STAGE AT A PARTICULAR LOCATION
OF THEIR OF THEIR INTEREST IS
GONNA REACH MONITOR A FLUTTER
DANGER STAGE -- AND THERE'S ALSO
THE YOU KNOW THROUGH THE
NATIONAL WEATHER SERVICE THEIR
THEIR ALERT WARNING SYSTEM YOU
KNOW THE BUZZERS IF YOU GET ON
YOUR CELL PHONE ONCE IN AWHILE.
YOU'LL THAT THE ISSUE WARNINGS --
THAT WAY TOO AND SO THERE'S
THERE'S LOTS OF WAYS TO ONE THAT
THEY CAN PULL DATA.
OFF THE WEBSITES BUT WE'RE ALSO
GETTING INTO A DAY AND AGE WERE
MORE DATE IS CAN BE CAN BE
PUSHED IF PEOPLE WANT TO GO IN
AND REGISTER -- FOR
NOTIFICATIONS CAN BE PUSHED TO
THEM -- AND JUST TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE DATA IS UNDERSTOOD.
WE ROUTINELY THROUGHOUT THE YEAR
WILL MEET WITH PARTNERS ON YOU
KNOW.
HOW TO HOW TO UNDERSTAND AND
DIGEST WITH THE INFORMATION THAT
WE HAVE AND ONE OF THE REQUESTED
WE DO HAVE FROM COUNTY?
OFFICES OF THE MERGER SERVICES
WHEN WHEN THERE'S A HIGH WATER
THEN AS WITH THE LAST FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE SOMEONE
FROM THE FLIGHT CENTER TO COME
DOWN.
AND BE IN THEIR COUNTY EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS CENTER TO MAKE SURE
THEY'RE AWARE AND THEIR
DIGESTING UNDERSTANDING ALL THIS
INFORMATION -- YOU KNOW IN AN
ENTRY IN A MEANINGFUL WAY AND
ARE NOT MISINTERPRETING ARE
MISSING SOMETHING.
JUST ON A THE GENERAL -- I GUESS
A PERSPECTIVE.
WHO ARE THE PARTNERS JUST FOR
PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND?
AND TO AND HAVE A BETTER SENSE
OF WHO WHO THEY ARE WAR WE
TALKING ABOUT WHEN YOU SAY YOU.
PROVIDED THIS INFORMATION TO THE
PARTNERS.
YES SO THE THE PARTNER'S ONE IS
OUR OUR OUR COOPERATORS THAT
WORK WITH US ON ON SNOW
MEASUREMENTS IN A AND THEY HAVE
THEIR OWN GAUGING NETWORK SO
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
ON THE RESERVOIR OPERATORS
THEY'VE GOT THEIR OWN CITY
GAUGES THAT WE ALL SHARE
INFORMATION -- YET THE POWER
COMPANIES P. JEANNIE SO CALLOUS
AND THEY'VE GOT A LOT OF DATA
YOU KNOW THEY GOT A LOT OF
CENTERS UP IN THE WATERSHED --
THE RESERVOIR OPERATORS YOU KNOW
THE MAJOR ONES ON THE SACRAMENTO
SAN JOAQUIN SYSTEM WERE GETTING
DATA REAL TIME -- AND THEN PUT
THE BOOK WILL THE RESERVOIR
OPERATORS YOU GOT.
TO THAT THE COUNTY EMERGENCY
MANAGERS AND THE LOCAL LIVING
MAINTAINING AGENCIES -- THE
FOLKS THAT ARE ON THE GROUND THE
OF THE WONDER TO PEOPLE THAT ARE
OUT THERE PATROLLING LEVEES
DURING HIGH WATER DANCE --
MAKING THAT INITIAL ATTACK ON AN
INCIDENT IT'S A RELIGION SIDE OR
A BOILER SOME KIND OF SEEPAGE --
YEAH THOSE ARE THE FOLKS THAT
WERE TRYING TO AND TRYING TO
INFORM.
BUT MY NEXT QUESTION WOULD BE
AROUND THE THE SMALLER RIVERS.
AND THEY MAY NOT HAVE -- THE
FLOOD MANAGEMENT INFRASTRUCTURE
IN PLACE.
WHAT WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE
FROM YOUR?
PERSPECTIVE IN WHAT ARE WE DOING
TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S CONSTANT
RISK MANAGEMENT ASSESSMENT AND
KEEPING -- THOSE PARTNERS - IN
THE LOOP.
I'LL TAKE A CRACK AT THAT ONE
JUST FROM THE STANDPOINT OF OF
FLIGHT OPERATIONS AND SO THE BUT
THE DEPARTMENT IN THE CALIFORNIA
NEVADA RIVER FORECAST CENTERS
FUNDS WE DON'T.
DO RIVER FORECAST FOR EVERY
EVERY STREAMING THE STATE IT'S
YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S THE MAIN.
MAIN RIVERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- BUT THOSE SMALLER
SMALLER STREAMS WHICH CAN BE
JUST AS AND NO IMPACTFUL AND
ARMING TO TO SMALL COMMUNITIES --
WEEK THROUGH OUR GRANTS FOR THE
THINGS THAT WE'VE WE FIND IT IS
THE THE UPGRADE OF THEIR ALERT
WARNING SYSTEMS.
AND SO THERE HAVE BEEN SEVERAL
COUNTIES THAT HAVE TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF THAT. TO TO SO THAT
THEY HAVE BETTER QUALITY DATA ON
YOU KNOW HOW WHAT WHAT THE
STAGES IN THEIR RIVER OF CONCERN
OR THEIR TO THEIR CREEK OF
CONCERN.
AND AND HAVE THAT DATA TO
LIMITED RIGHT INTO THEIR COUNTY
FLOOD CONTROL DISTRICT OR COUNTY
AND THE BIRDS HE OFFICE OF THE
BURDEN COUNTY -- EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS CENTER.
AND I'LL JUST ADD A NOTE IS THE
NATIONAL WEATHER SERVICE THERE'S
WITHIN SACRAMENTO TO OFFICES
THEY GET INVOLVED IN EMERGENCY
NOTIFICATIONS IT'S THE RIVER
FORECASTS ARE THE CALIFORNIA
NEVADA RIVER FORECAST CENTER
WHICH JOHN MENTIONED WHICH
HANDLES THE LARGER RIVERS.
AND THEN THERE IS THE SACRAMENTO --
WEATHER SERVICE OFFICE -- THERE
OFFICES SPREAD OUT ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE PRODUCTS FROM THE NATIONAL --
RIVER FORECAST CENTER PUSH DOWN
TO THE WEATHER FORECAST OFFICE
WHO THEN IS THE ENTITY THAT IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR ON LIKE YOUR
TELEVISION OR THE RADIO SENDING
OUT THE ALERTS FOR THE SMALL
CREEKS AND WATERSHED SO
SOMETIMES YOU'LL SEE.
AT THIS TIME OF YEAR -- DICTATE
THE BOTTOM OF THE THE TELEVISION
A NOTIFICATION SOMETHING
HAPPENED IT'S A FORECAST THAT
COMES FROM THE LARGER GROUP TO
THE SMALLER THAN THE HYDROLOGIST
WHO ARE MY WITH THOSE WATERSHEDS
THE FEDERAL LEVEL WORK TO GET
THAT INFORMATION OUT.
THE OTHER THING I WANTED TO ADD
TO JOHN'S ANSWER IS THE WEATHER
SERVICE HAD WITH THE CALL
SERVICE COORDINATION
HYDROLOGISTS WHICH ARE
SPECIALISTS TO GO THROUGH.
AND ENGAGE THE LIST OF COMMUNITY
SAID HE WENT OUT THERE AND WHEN
WE'RE COMING UP WITH PROTOCOLS
ON WHAT IS THE LEVEL -- TO ALERT
PEOPLE AT ITS THE LOCALS WHO
THEN COME UP TO AN AGREEMENT
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OF
WHAT THAT THRESHOLD IS SO IT'S
NOT A TOP DOWN PROCESS BUT
RATHER A BOTTOM UP.
I'VE GOT TO ASK JUST A FEW
QUESTIONS ARE PUT INTO ONE FOR
LA -- REPRESENTATIVE -- TALKING
ABOUT PERHAPS -- THIS HAS BEEN
ALREADY LOOKED AT INVESTMENTS IN
TRADITION -- FLOOD PROTECTION
INFRASTRUCTURE VERSES.
FLOODPLAIN RESTORATION AND THEN
THE OTHER IS -- OUR INFORMATION
TELLS HOUSES WE'VE SPENT ABOUT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
LAST TWENTY YEARS.
ON THIS MATTER AND DO WE HAVE A
BALLPARK FIGURE OF REALLY WHAT
THE STATE WIPED A ASSESSMENT
MIGHT BE IN TERMS OF NEED.
THE TICKET FOR SHOT AT THAT AND
THEN KICK IT TO THE DEPARTMENT --
YES THERE HAS BEEN AND A VERY.
LARGE INCREASE AND FOCUS ON THE
MULTI BENEFIT APPROACH -- IN IN
FACT IN PROPOSITION ONE AND I
THINK IN PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT
AS WELL THOUGH HE BONDS WERE
WRITTEN WITH THE REQUIREMENT
THAT THOSE FUNDS GO FOR MULTI
BENEFIT -- FLOOD MANAGEMENT
PROJECTS -- THERE AND THERE IS A
WIDE VARIETY IN ESTIMATES ON
NEED.
ALWAYS IN THE MULTIPLE TENS OF
BILLIONS -- OF DOLLARS ACROSS
THE STATE I THINK IT WAS WAS IT
TWENTY BILLION IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY FLOOD PROTECTION PLAN --
JUST FOR THE CENTRAL VALLEY --
SOME OF THE OTHER ESTIMATES I'VE
SEEN I'VE BEEN KIND OF IN THE
FIFTY BILLION DOLLAR RANGE
ACROSS THE STATE -- FOR FOR
FLOOD MANAGEMENT THAT WOULD BE
ACROSS MULTIPLE DECADES AND I
WAS SO THAT'S NOT A SINGLE YEAR
ESTIMATE BUT IN TERMS OF NEEDS
SO SO CLEARLY AND NOT A LOT OF
NEED OUT THERE I WOULD JUST
AGAIN HIGHLIGHT -- THAT
TYPICALLY THE FUNDING COMES FROM
MULTIPLE SOURCES LOCAL FEDERAL
AND STATE AND THE STATE HAS NOT
BEEN THE LARGEST SOURCE IN IN
THOSE FUNDS BUT WIND THE STATE
HAS PUT MANY IT HAS FOCUSED
PRIMARILY ON THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AND AND STATE PLAN IF I'M
CONTROL BECAUSE OF THAT SPECIAL.
LIABILITY THAT WE HAVE BUT NOT
EXCLUSIVELY THESE BONDFUNDS
HAVE ALSO BEEN USED AND BEEN
MADE AVAILABLE FOR GRANTS AND
OTHER AREAS OF THE STATE.
AND BE A SOURCE OF THE THE
DOLLAR ESTIMATES THAT RACHEL HAD
INDICATED OUT THERE THE TWENTY
ONE BILLION HAT WE HAVE FOR THE
SOME BY THE PROTECTION PLAN.
IS LOOKING AT STATE INVESTMENTS
AS WELL AS PROJECTS THAT LOCAL
ENTITIES TO PROVIDE A MORE
INCLUDED WITHIN THE PORTFOLIO
THAT THE PLOT PLAN ADVOCATES.
FOR THE STATEWIDE ESTIMATE OF
FIFTY BILLION FIFTY BILLION IS
THAT ACTUAL DISCRETE LISTA
PROJECTS WHERE THE DEPARTMENT
WATER RESOURCES AND THE US ARMY
CORPS OF ENGINEERS.
INTERVIEWED ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
DIFFERENT FLOOD MANAGEMENT
ENTITIES WITHIN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THEN FROM THEN
HAVE AN ACTUAL LIST OF DEFINED
PROJECTS SO THE FIFTY IS.
PROJECTS THAT ARE CONCEPTUALIZED
THAT THEY WOULD LIKE TO MOVE
FORWARD ON AND WE'RE WE GET UP
TO THE HUNDRED BILLION THAT'S A
GAS THAT THESE WOULD BE THE NEXT
LEVEL OF PROJECTS THAT WOULD
COME.
TO CONTINUE TO REDUCE THE FLOOD
RISK.
HELLO TO DOUBLE DOWN ON THE
CHAIRMAN'S QUESTION -- IF WE
HAVE THE NUMBER PICKED AT FIFTY
AND WE'VE DONE.
SEVERAL WATER BONDS -- IN RECENT
MEMORY.
HOW MUCH OF HOW HOW MUCH OF WE
DONE AND WHAT IN WATER BONDS
HERE IN TOTAL AND HOW DOES THAT
COMPARE TO THE FIFTY BILLION AND
AND OF THE NUMBER THAT WE'VE
DONE AND WATER BONDS?
HOW MUCH OF IT ACTUALLY GOES TO
FIXING ANY OF THAT FIFTY BILLION
DOLLAR?
ISSUE SO ON PAGE FIVE OF THE
HAND OUT THERE'S A FIGURE THAT
SHOWS -- OVER THE PAST TWO
DECADES THE PROPORTION OF THE
BONDS THAT HAVE PASSED THAT IT
HAD FUNDING SPECIFICALLY FOR
FLOOD MANAGEMENT ACTIVITIES --
SO FIVE POINT SIX BILLION
[inaudible]
SO WITH.
SO WHAT'S THAT TOTAL.
SO FIVE POINT SIX BILLION HAS
BEEN DEDICATED FROM WATER BONDS
OVER THE PAST TWO DECADES FOR
FLOOD MANAGEMENT SPECIFICALLY.
OF A FIFTY BILLION DOLLAR
PROBLEM.
CORRECT BUT AGAIN I THINK AS
NOTED THAT FIFTY BILLION DOLLAR
ESTIMATE WAS PROJECTS TO
ANTICIPATED NOT THAT THE STATE
WOULD WOULD PLAY THAT.
BE THE SOLE FINDER IT IS STORE
KLAY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
WHAT ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF SOME OF%
THE BIG PROJECTS STATE FAIR
STATEMENT -- OF THE BIG PROJECTS
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS.
CHOSEN TO INVEST IN WHICH I
THINK IT IS.
LAW EMITTED.
A WOMAN'S LAST TIME THEY MADE
ONE OF THOSE INVESTMENTS READ
VERY RECENTLY YEAH IN THE PAST
FEW MONTHS -- CURRENTLY THERE'S
A TWO BILLION DOLLAR -- SPECIAL
INITIATIVE FOR THE ARMY CORPS OF
ENGINEERS TO INVEST IN THEIR
COST SHARING THE PROJECTS AND
INVESTED.
ARE IDENTIFIED WITHIN THE FLOOD
PLAN AND UP PART OF THE REASON
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WAS
ABLE TO GET THAT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS WHICH WE STILL HAVE TO
GET -- WAS THEY LOOKED AT THE
ACTUAL LIST OF PROJECTS ALONG
WITH ALL THE OTHER ACTIONS IN
THE CONFERENCE PORTFOLIO.
THAT -- THE LOCALS IN THE STATE
HAVE BEEN WORKING THROUGH OUR
PLANNING EFFORTS TO THE BUILDING
AND THEN A FIVE IT WE HAVE THE
NUMBER THE TOTAL WATER BOND
NUMBER FRIENDLY DREW MY
ATTENTION TO THE FIVE BILLION
THAT'S GONE TOWARDS FLOOD
MANAGEMENT BUT WHAT'S THE WHAT'S
THE TOTAL AMOUNT THAT WE'VE.
AUTHORIZED.
I THINK IT'S AROUND THIRTY
BILLION THIRTY ONE MAYBE SO OUT
OF THIRTY ONE BILLION DOLLARS OF
BONDS WE'VE WE'VE ALL THE
ALLOCATED -- FIVE TWO THIS
SUBJECT OF FUND MANAGEMENT SINCE
YOU DO HAVE WATER PARKS CRACKS
THAT THIRTY ONE BILLION IT WATER
AND RESOURCES SO THERE'S MANY
FOR PARKS AND OTHER NATURAL
RESOURCES IN IN THOSE BONDS BUT
OF THE NATURAL RESOURCES BOND
SINCE TWO THOUSAND I THINK IT'S
THIRTY ONE BILLION.
LET ME DRAW YOUR ATTENTION BACK.
TO MY FAVORITE CHART HERE -- OF
ALL THOSE RIVERS IF WE GOT TO
THE 10% PROBABILITY OF THE SNOW
MELT.
WHERE WHERE'S THE GREATEST FLOOD
RISK?
AB.
IN THE HERE AND NOW -- USUALLY
WERE WERE REALLY WORRIED ABOUT
THE URBAN POPULATIONS SO LOOKING
UP THERE WE WOULD BE USUALLY
WORRIED ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING
UP IN THE SACRAMENTO REGION.
BUT THE WHAT WE DON'T ALWAYS
FACTOR INTO THAT IS THE ACTUAL --
REAL TIME FIELD CONDITIONS OUT
THERE MEANING THE CONDITIONS OF
THE LEVEES THE ABILITY TO CONVEY
THE FLOWS THROUGH.
SO ANY GIVEN TIME YOU CRITICS.
YOU HAVE THEIR RULE NUMBER ONE
SHIP TO EXPECT THE UNEXPECTED
THE FLOOD WILL NOT HAPPEN FOR
YOU THINK IT WILL IT'S GONNA
HAPPEN SOMEWHERE ELSE.
I LET ME ASK THAT AGAIN -- WHERE
WITH THE MOST FLOODING OCCUR NOT
TAKE IN THE CONSIDERATION YOU
KNOW YOUR PRIORITY LIST OF ALL
WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA LOOK AT
AFTER THE URBAN FOLKS FIRST
WHICH?
SOUND OFF A LOT LIKE THE OPERATE
KIND LIKE LEGISLATURE FROM.
HERE.
URBAN COMMUNITIES FIRST -- THAT
ASIDE.
WHO'S LEAST WHICH RIVERS LEAST
PREPARED TO HANDLE THE SIZE OF
THE STONE OUT.
AT 10%.
YEAH I'D I'D I THINK IT IT'S
STILL KIND OF DEPENDS I DON'T
HAVE AN ANSWER FOR YOU ON THAT.
CAN I ASK A RELATED QUESTION.
WHICH COOLEY.
I MEAN AREN'T.
DON'T THESE SORTS OF ISSUES YOU
KNOW WE'RE NOW IN MAY IF WE HAD
A VERY SUSTAIN HOT PERIOD.
ISN'T THAT WHAT WE WORRY ABOUT.
IT'S YOU KNOW IN JANUARY IT'S
ALWAYS YOU WORRY ABOUT THAT WARM
RAIN STORM THAT IS ACTUALLY
MELTING THE SNOW MELT AS A FALLS
OUT OF THE SKIES.
NOW REGIS WE'RE SORT OF STUCK
WITH WE JUST HAVE A VERY SUSTAIN
PERIOD OF HIGH HEAT.
THE STAR CENTER WATER.
I ACTUALLY DO KEEP THE YOU KNOW
SOMEBODY -- HYDRAULIC HYDROLOGY
ON MY PHONE SO I WATCHED.
THE THE RIVER FLOW GOING UP AND
DOWN -- ON A DAILY BASIS SO NOW
I THINK WE'RE GETTING IN THE
WARM TIME HERE WE IF WE GET
INTENSE HEAT.
IT'S JUST ARE SENATE WATER
DOWNSTREAM AND THEN.
YOU CAN'T HAVE THE WATER
OVERTOPPING A SO YOU HAVE TO
HAVE RELEASES.
NO YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT IN ALL
BUT CALL YOUR ATTENTION TO HAND
OUT EIGHT AND THE PACKAGE THERE
AT THE BOTTOM OF THIS IS GETTING
A LITTLE IN OF THE THE DETAIL
WEEKS BUT THIS IS EXACTLY.
THE TYPES OF QUESTIONS THAT WE
RUN THROUGH IN THE COMING UP THE
OPERATIONAL SCENARIOS THAT ARE
THE BASIS FOR THE RESERVOIR FOR
NATIONS AND A HAND OUT EIGHT
WHEN YOU LOOK ON THE BOTTOM HALF.
YOU'LL SEE DOWN THERE IN -- THE
IT'S REALLY THE BOTTOM HALF SORT
OF THE UPPER RIGHT HAND CORNER
IT SAYS F. IN F. FORECAST
SELECTION HAVE TYPICAL WEATHER
PATTERNS WET AVERAGE WITH THOSE
ARE CHOOSE OUR BOXES.
AND YOU CAN GO THROUGH IF YOU'RE
REALLY RISK ADVERSE AND PUT IN A
VERY WET.
BUT WARM SCENARIO.
AND THAT WILL THEN ALLOW THE
TOOL TO GO THROUGH ND SHOW YOU
HEY HERE'S MORE WATER THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY COMING AS AN ACTUAL
SNOW MELT QUICKER.
AND THEN LOOK AT THE DASHBOARD
AT THE TOP AND SEE HOW THAT
SYSTEM IS RESPONDING TO THAT
PARTICULAR SCENARIO SO EACH
RESERVOIR OPERATOR HAS WITHIN
THEIR TOOL KIT.
THE ABILITY TO ASK THAT
INDIVIDUAL QUESTION AND THEN
THROUGH THE COORDINATION CALLS
THEY SHARE THEIR EXPERIENCES.
AND REALLY WHAT THE STATE'S ROLE
IS TO HELP FACILITATE OKAY WHO
CAN HOLD BACK.
SO THAT THIS AREA WHERE WE SEE
IT THIS PRESENT CONDITION A
GREATER RISK.
THEY CAN MOVE FIRST AND FORWARD
IN TIME AND THE OTHER THING THAT
WE DIDN'T HIGHLIGHT WE ARE
COUNTING FOR THAT ROUTING OR
THAT TIME TRAVEL OF THE WATER AS
IT MOVES THERE SO IF YOU'RE
FURTHER AWAY FROM A POINT OF
CONCERN.
THAT'S INCLUDED WITHIN THE TOOL.
TO AND YOU HAVE A MODEL THAT
COORDINATES.
THE DOWNSTREAM RIVER CHANNEL
WITH ALL THE OTHER FLOWS.
BE BECAUSE IT'S THE CUMULATIVE
AFFECT.
IT'S LIKE YOU KNOW THE MERCED
RIVER THE TO ALL OF ME.
THE SAN JOAQUIN IT'S THE WATER
THIS POINT TO ALL THOSE CHANNELS.
THAT EVENTUALLY START DROPPING
INTO THE INTO THE VALLEY FLOOR
AND HAVE TO WORK THEIR WAY NORTH.
INTO DELTA.
THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT AND ON THE
THE UPPER PANEL OF THAT SAME
HAND OUT EIGHT THOSE GREEN DOTS
WILL TURN OTHER COLORS WHEN WE
START ACTUALLY SEEING WHAT WE
CALL THE OBJECTIVE FUNCTIONS IS
THE TECHNICAL TERM BUT IT'S THE
CAPACITY OF THE CHANNELS.
AT THOSE LOCATIONS WILL CHANGED
OTHER COLORS.
IN A SIMILAR COLOR NAMAN GLACIER
TO WITH THE WEATHER SERVICE USES
FOR THEIR TO ON THE WEB SO WE WE
KIND OF KEPT WHERE PEOPLE ARE
CONDITIONAL LIES. TO GREEN
YELLOW RED AND ALL OF OUR TOOLS
AND DASHBOARDS.
ADVANCING TO SEE THIS WITH THE
TIME IT WOULD TAKE FROM THEIR
MAIN RESERVOIRS ON EACH OF THESE.
RIVERS SLASH TRIBUTARIES TO WHEN
THEY START ACTUALLY HITTING THE
SAN JOAQUIN.
JUST STANDARD WATER FLOW TIMES.
DO YOU GUYS HAVE MODELING WHERE
YOU COULD -- SHOW US WHAT.
THAT 10% PROBABILITY OF THE
LOOKS LIKE.
AS FAR AS FIGHTING AGAINST.
YEAH WE'VE GOT SOMETHING THAT WE
CAN THAT WE DO AS PART JUST A
PART OF OUR OPERATION IS IS
WORKING WITH THE RESTAURANT
WRITERS.
TO AND WE WE RUN SOME WORST CASE
SCENARIOS OURSELVES AS A
DEPARTMENT. TO TO KNOW WHERE --
NETWORK WHERE WE MIGHT BE AT
RISK OF SOME OF THOSE.
CHANNELS OF EXCEEDING OUR
OBJECTIVES I JUST SAT THERE
BRIEFINGS SERVE RISCO -- ON THE
MERCED WITH A THAT BIOLOGIST DID
SOME COMPUTER MODELING OF
DIFFERENT CFS.
NUMBERS AND WHAT THAT WOULD LOOK
LIKE -- TO THE RIVER IN THE
FLOOD PLAINS ROUNDED SOME SO FOR
THE SHOULD YOU HAVE THE SAME
CAPABILITY RIGHT.
YEAH.
THE QUESTION I'M STILL
STRUGGLING WITH IS.
AFTER SEVERAL DIFFERENT WAYS BUT
IT'S HARD FOR ME TO CENTRALIZE
AS A LAYPERSON HOW APPEAR THE
SACRAMENTO WHERE YOU'VE GOT FOUR
AND A HALF MILLION ACRE FEET OF
STORAGE.
AND WORST CASE SNOW MEL IS ONE
POINT SEVEN MILLION ACRE FEET.
THAT THE RISK.
IS IT FAR LESS THAN DOWN HERE ON
THE SAN JOAQUIN WHERE THE TOTAL
STORAGE -- IS MAYBE A HALF A
MILLION ACRE FEET.
AND THE WORST CASE SNOWMELT IS
THREE TIMES THAT.
SO I HAVE A HARD TO UNDERSTAND
HOW THAT RESERVOIR.
HAS THE SECOND YOU KNOW IS IT AT
GREATER RISK IN THAT REGION
ISN'T AT GREATER RISK FOR
FLOODING A WORST CASE SCENARIO
THAN THE SACRAMENTO.
AND UNDERSTAND THE DISTANCE
BETWEEN -- I MEAN THERE'S A LOT
OF FACTORS I GET THAT BUT IT
SEEMS VERY OBVIOUS RIGHT UP
FRONT THAT THAT WOULD BE THE
GREATEST RISK AND IT AM I MISS
INTERPRETING THE FACTS HERE.
WELL.
WHAT I?
I THINK IT'S A IT'S THE TERM THE
TERM REST WHAT RISK IS IS A
LIKELIHOOD OF FLOODING.
TIMES THE CONSEQUENCE OF
FLOODING.
SO ON THE ON THE LIKE YOU
MENTIONED ON THE SACRAMENTO
SYSTEM OF THE LIKELIHOOD OF
FLOODING THERE BASED ON THE
SENATE IS VERY SMALL.
BUT THERE'S A LOT OF OUR
POPULATIONS ARE SO THE
CONSEQUENCES ARE ENORMOUSLY HIGH.
ON THE SAN JOAQUIN SYSTEM AND
MAYBE THE OTHER PARTS ON THIS ON
THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER SYSTEM
THAT WE'RE YOU'RE DRAWING OUR
ATTENTION.
TO THE LIKELIHOOD OF FLOODING IS
HIGHER.
BUT THE CONSEQUENCES OF THE FAT
FLOODING WOULD BE LOWER AND SO
THAT'S WHY I STOPPED TAKING A
TOUGH ANSWER WHEN YOU WHEN YOU
WITH WHEN YOU USE THE TERM RISK
NO THAT'S VERY HELPFUL BECAUSE
NOW WE CAN.
WE CAN BY FOR KATE RESCUED TWO
CATEGORIES NOT A LIKELIHOOD SIDE.
THEN WE COULD SAY WITH SOME
CERTAINTY THAT SAM OUR KIDS IN
THE WORST.
POSITION.
THERE'S DEFINITELY A CONCERN
THERE -- I WANT TO THE LIMIT
LIVING DRILL DOWN A LITTLE
FURTHER FOR YOU -- IN ORDER TO
MITIGATE FOR THAT POTENTIAL
FLOODING WITH AFTER.
RELEASED A WHOLE LOT OF WATER
THROUGH THAT RESERVOIR RIGHT SO
WERE WE WARMING UP COMPLEMENT
WAS DISCUSSION ABOUT WATER
SUPPLYAND MISSED OPPORTUNITIES
FOR WATER SUPPLY AND SECURITY AS
WE LOOK AT EXTENDED DROUGHTS AND
WHICH IS ONE OF THE TOPICS --
REBECCA COR PORTION OF THE TOPIC
HERE TODAY.
IT SEEMS LIKE THAT'S A HUGE
MISSED OPPORTUNITY RIVER IN THE
SENSE THAT THAT'S A WHOLE LOT OF
WATER WOULD BE -- NOT STORING
FOR THE FUTURE IN THE CASE OF A
YOU KNOW HOT FEW HOT WEEKS OR
HOT MONTH SET FAIR TO SAY.
YES -- BUT I WANTED TO GO AND DO
A LITTLE COMPARISON HERE BETWEEN --
SHASTA WHICH IS THE LARGEST OF
OUR RESERVOIRS AND BACK -- TO
MILLER TENANTS AND CAN RIVER
THERE WHICH I THINK IS WHAT
WE'RE TALKING -- THIS THE
ORIGINAL SIZE IS DESIGNED BY
THOSE TO RESERVOIRS YOU CAN SEE
THAT THERE'S THE FOUR POINT FIVE
IT SHASTA THOUSAND ACRE FEET.
OR FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION ACRE
FEET SORRY AND THEN YOU HAVE A
BASICALLY EFFECTIVELY A HALF
MILLION ACRE FEET AS THE ACT OF
STORAGE BOWL WITH NORTON MIKE.
AND AT THE PARTY ORIGINAL DESIGN
FOR THOSE TWO WATER SHEDS WE
WERE ALWAYS.
KNOWING THAT WE WOULD BE
REFILLING A MILLER TEN AGAIN AND
AGAIN AND AGAIN AS THE SNOW MELT
BETWEEN APRIL AND JULY WOULD
SLOWLY UP HER OUT THERE.
SO THERE HISTORICALLY HAS BEEN A
METERING OF THAT SNOW PACK TO
FILL THAT -- IN I THINK THE THE
QUESTION AT HAND IS WINNER THE
RULES GONNA CHANGE AND WHEN WILL
WE SEE FASTER SNOW MELT INTO
THAT AREA ANY TO LOOK INTO THAT --
THE GOOD NEWS IS IT DOES TAKE
AWHILE FOR THAT TO OCCUR --
MEANING LIKE DECADES WHEN WE GET
INTO THAT DEGREE OF CLIMATE
CHANGE AND WHEN WE WENT AND DID
THE CENTER FIVE FOOT PROTECTION
PLAN WE DID DO CLIMATE CHANGE
ASSESSMENTS I TALKED ABOUT.
HOW PARADISE CUT WE SIZED SO WE
LOOK DOWNSTREAM WITHOUT WATER
WAS GOING ACTUALLY DESIGNED THE
CHANNEL TO BE BROAD ENOUGH TO
ACCOMMODATE SOME OF THAT WATER
AS IT MOVES THROUGH AN IMPROVED
SEVENTEEN RIVER SYSTEM -- BUT WE
HAD OTHER AREAS WHERE WE HAD
TRANSITORY STORAGE AREAS WHERE
WATER CAN GET INTO THESE MULTI
BENEFIT REFUGES ABOVE THAT AREA
AS WELL AND WE DID -- PLAY
AROUND WITH SOME RESERVOIR RE
OPERATIONS WHICH WOULD BE LIKE
REDEFINING THAT YELLOW SPACE IN
BLUE SPACE WITHIN MILLER TEN SO
THAT WE HAD SOME FLEXIBILITY IN
THERE.
AND WE WERE ABLE TO DO IT IN A
PLANNING CONSTRUCT AS THIS IS
TALKING ABOUT PLANNING FOR AN
AREA THE SIZE OF THE STATE OF
FLORIDA.
SO WE HAD TO MAKE SOME
ASSUMPTIONS AND THEN THE WAY
THAT WE WOULD THEN MOVE IT IS.
TEAR OFF OF THOSE PLANS TO GET
TO MORE REAL FEASIBILITY STUDIES
ABOUT IS IS SOMETHING THAT
REALLY WOULD WORK OR NOT.
KNOWING THAT SURVIVED THE
PROTECTION PLAN BY LAWS TO BE
UPDATED EVERY FIVE YEARS SO AS
WE DO OTHER ACTIONS AND HAVE
OTHER CONVERSATIONS WITH OTHERS.
THAT ADDITIONAL INFORMATION THEN
BECOMES THE NEW BASELINE WITHIN
OUR SYSTEM CONTEXT PLANNING
[inaudible]
THIS BIGELOW.
AS A CANDIDATE JUST TO LISTEN
AND BE ON THE BALCONY AND AND
JUST TRY TO LEARN A LITTLE BIT
MORE.
BECAUSE YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT YOU
KNOW.
AND YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU
DON'T KNOW -- FOR MISTER COOLEY
THERE IS A A GREAT DEAL
COORDINATION IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
RIVER.
AND ALONG THE THE WAY MOST OF
THESE RIVERS HAVE A COORDINATED
EFFORT SO THEY DON'T WIND UP
WITH THE OCCURRENCE THAT YOU
WERE.
SPEAKING TO WHICH IS.
I'M A CUMULATIVE IMPACT THAT
WOULD HIT THE RIVER THAT WOULD
CAUSE A MAJOR FLOOD TO THE
COMMUNITIES DOWN FLOW.
AND AS WE RECOGNIZE EACH OF
THESE HAVE EIGHT BY THE BY THE
GRAPH THAT WE SEE UP HERE ON
THIS CHART IN OUR CHARTS ON HER
DESK.
WE SEE THAT THERE'S MORE
CAPABILITY FOR TIME OF
DISPLACEMENT THE TERM IS NOT
REGULARLY USED OR HEARD BY THIS
BODY.
TIME A DISPLACEMENT IS A
CRITICAL COMPONENT FOR US TO
HAVE SUCCESS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
AND WATER STATE.
NOW WE JUST.
WE WERE JUST LISTENING.
TO WHAT YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT
YOU NEED DECADES. TO REALLY
STUDY.
TALK TO US ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
IN NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN AND THE
SUBSEQUENT YEARS UP.
TO TWO THOUSAND FIVE TELL US
ABOUT WHAT MAJOR CATASTROPHIC
EVENT OCCURRED.
ON THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER.
THAT WE KNOW CAN HAPPEN AND WILL
HAPPEN AGAIN AND AGAIN IF WE
DON'T CHANGE THE SKEW OF TIME A
DISPLACEMENT BY HAVING.
A QUANTITATIVE CHANGE IN STORAGE
CAPACITY.
SO THE NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN
FLOOD WAS A WIDESPREAD FLOOD OF
AND FOR BOTH SACRAMENTO SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY SISTER WHERE --
BUT THAT WAS AN EVENT THAT
OCCURRED BEFORE WE HAD THE
FORECAST WHEN IT OPERATIONS
PROGRAM THAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT HERE SO NOT TRUE.
THAT WAS BUILT INTO THE FEDERAL
REGULATION AND AND THEY MISTER
TONY WAS RUNNING THAT SO KEEP
GOING I'M GONNA I'M GONNA
CHALLENGE ON THIS ONE OKAY.
I WELCOME IS THERE YEAH I WAS
THE GUY THEY'RE HAVING TO MAKE
THE CALLS -- PRE BEING ABORTED
SUPERVISOR AS A LANDMARK.
I WASN'T AFFECTED PARTY --
MOVING INTO -- THE MORE RECENT
THOUGHT OF AS WE HAD SO THINKING
ABOUT THE WATER THAT HAPPEN IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THERE WERE
COORDINATION CALLS THE JOHNS
TEAM WAS WORKING WITH THE
RESERVOIR OPERATORS WITH THE
DOWNSTREAM COMMUNITIES. TO
LITERALLY GO THROUGH AND DO
EXACTLY DESCRIBED EARLIER WAS TO
ENSURE THAT BASICALLY WE COULD.
MEET HER OUT THE WATER ACCOUNT
FOR THE ATTENUATION TIME THIS
DISPLACEMENT TIME AS YOU CALL IT.
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE WOULD NOT
BE EXCEEDING THE DOWNSTREAM
CAPACITIES PARALLEL TO THAT --
THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES WERE GOING
THROUGH AND WHERE THEY NEEDED
WERE AN ACTING EMERGENCY
MEASURES ON THEIR LEVEES TO YOU
KNOW BASICALLY WHERE THERE'S
KNOWN LOW SPOTS ON THE LEVEES.
GO THROUGH PROVIDE BASICALLY
SOME ADDITIONAL BERMS OR
SANDBAGS TO ADDRESS AND STRENGTH
IN THAT SYSTEM IN THOSE WEAK
POINTS.
SO.
WHAT OCCURRED IN NINETY SEVEN
WAS ONE OF THE GREAT?
INJUSTICES.
BUT IT'S ALSO SOMETHING THAT
POINTS OUT OUR FAILURES -- TO
PREPARE.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING ON?
A PAGE FIVE YOU SPOKE TO ALL OF
THE IMPROVEMENTS AND THE FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS BUT IF WE TAKE A
LOOK VERY LITTLE MONEY IS
MISSING ON THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER
IT'S ALL BEEN SPENT.
IN THE SACRAMENTO REGIONAL AREA --
FOR IMPROVEMENTS THEIR
RECOGNIZING THAT THE CHURCHILL A
BY PASS HAS HOLES RIDDLED
THROUGH IT AND ANY MAJOR.
ADDITIONAL FLOOD THAT WOULD
OCCUR THERE IS GOING TO HAVE A
BLOW OUT THAT'S GOING TO WIPE
OUT TENS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
IF NOT MORE -- WITH IT WITHOUT
ANY HARDLY ANY NOTICE AT ALL.
LET'S RECOGNIZE MISSED COOLEY
JUST BECAUSE YOU'RE PART OF THIS
TRIVIA -- THAT FLOOD.
THAT OCCURRED HAD OVER SIXTY
SEVEN THOUSAND CUBIC FEET PER
SECOND THE DESIGN CAPACITY IS AT
TWENTY SIX ONLY TO GET TO THE
SACK DAM.
THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER TODAY CAN
ONLY HANDLE EIGHT THOUSAND CUBIC
FEET PER SECOND.
YOU CAN ONLY PUT A LITTLE OVER
NINE THOUSAND CUBIC FEET PER
SECOND AND THE BY PASS THOSE
DON'T EQUAL.
TWENTY SIX WHAT HAPPENS TO THE
DIFFERENCE IT GOES AND IT
SPREADS WILDLY
IF YOU LOOK AT THIS ROOM MOST OF
US HAVE DRIVEN ONE FIFTY TWO WE
KNOW ONE FIFTY TWO HAS THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER BECAUSE WE CROSS
IT.
HOW FAR DO WE SEE ACROSS TO
ABOUT THE WITH OF THIS ROOM?
IT'S ACTUALLY ELEVEN MILES WIDE.
BUT WE NEVER SEE IT FLOODED.
BECAUSE WE'VE DONE A GOOD JOB A
MASTERING IN HARNESSING THE
RESOURCE.
THAT EXIST.
BUT MR GRAY IS HEATING UP
FABULOUS POINT HERE.
THE LARGEST SNOW PACK.
THE GREATEST POTENTIAL FOR US TO
HAVE A GAME IS ON THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER FOR FLOOD
PROTECTION AND UTILIZATION.
YET WORK STUMBLING OVER
RECOGNIZING IT.
AND ADDRESSING IT.
WHY IS THAT NOT OCCURRING?
IN A MORE HASTILY WAY.
BECAUSE JUST AS WE WERE WORRIED
ABOUT WAR BILL.
WITH ITS FLOOD.
WHEN IT WAS OCCURRING?
WE WE DIDN'T THREATEN THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER WE NEED TO GET IT
TAKEN CARE OF NOW.
WE CAN'T WAIT ANY LONGER.
BECAUSE THOSE PEOPLE.
HAVE GROWN IN MASSES AND TO SAY
THAT ONE COMMUNITY.
AND ONE GROUP OF PEOPLE IS OF
MORE VALUE THAN ANOTHER.
KIND OF GETS TO THE SOMEONE'S
CROSS.
HOW CAN YOU RESPOND TO THAT?
OR DO YOU WANT TO KNOW HAVE
DON'T HAVE RESPONSE THAT I
DIDN'T THINK SO.
WE'LL KEEP GOING WE'LL HAVE MORE
QUESTIONS.
OR I CAN PICK ON HIM NOW. TO
HAVE -- DO WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS NUMBERS AT THIS
JUNCTURE.
SIGNAL TAKE OUR FIRST PANEL --
AND ALSO MENTION MEMBERS I HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY SEVERAL WEEKS
AGO TO GO OUT AND TOUR THE
FLIGHT OPERATIONS CENTER AND WAS --
VERY INTERESTING VERY INFORMED
EXPERIENCE I WOULD ENCOURAGE
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AND I'D BE HAPPY TO ARRANGE IT --
AND THANK YOU ALL -- BOTH FOR
THE INFORMATION BY THE TOUR AND
THE TESTIMONY.
HERE -- THIS AFTERNOON
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY MEMBERS AT THIS TIME WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE -- TO ITEM THREE
ON YOUR AGENDA -- FLOOD
MANAGEMENT NOW THAT WE'VE
COVERED THE OVERVIEW OF THE
CALIFORNIA FOR CONTROL SYSTEM A
WE'RE GONNA INVITE -- THE
CENTRAL VALLEY FOR PROTECTION
BOARD EXECUTIVE OFFICER LESLIE
GALLAGHER THE RECLAMATION
DISTRICT ONE AWAIT DEPUTY
MANAGER MEGAN MAGGIE AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA CENTRAL FLOOD CONTROL
ASSOCIATION MILITARY.
THANK YOU ALL FOR TAKING THE
TIME TO BE WITH HERE WITH US
TODAY AND GO AHEAD AND PROCEED
WITH YOUR PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AND MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS LESLIE GALLAGHER I IN
THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY FLOOD PROTECTION
BOARD.
I WAS APPOINTED BY THE BOARD IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN SO I'VE BEEN
DOING THIS FOR A LITTLE WHILE
NOW AT THE LAST TIME I WAS
BEFORE YOUR COMMITTEE THE WEST.
TWENTY FIFTEEN SO.
THANK YOU FOR INVITING US BACK.
I KNOW THAT TO A CATASTROPHIC
REVEREND FLOODING IS NOT THE
ONLY DISASTER THAT WE FACE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA SO I APPRECIATE
THAT THERE'S A FOCUS ON THIS.
AND I AM GOING TO TAKE THIS --
TO JUST A A BIT OF A DIFFERENT
LEVEL THAN WHAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT -- THAT DEPARTMENT
SHOWED YOU A LOT OF THEIR GREAT
TOOLS THAT THEY HAVE BOTH FOR
GATHERING DATA AND FOR
SUPPORTING DECISIONS I'M GONNA
TALK TO A LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW
WE ORGANIZE THE THE VENUES AND
HOW WE CREATE THE POLICY THAT
GOES ALONG WITH THAT.
THE STATE'S STRATEGIC VISION FOR
REDUCING FLOOD RISK IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY HAS A LOT OF AND
HAS HAD A LOT OF INPUT FROM THE
LOCALS WHICH WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE.
WE'VE BEEN AT THIS FOR FOR QUITE
AWHILE AND I KNOW WE TALK ABOUT
NINETEEN FIFTY AS KIND OF A
STARTING POINT AROUND THE
FIFTIES WHEN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT GOT INVOLVED.
BUT ACTUALLY THE CENTRAL VALLEY
FLOOD PROTECTION BOARD IN ITS --
PREVIOUS ITERATION AS THE
RECLAMATION BOARD WAS ASKED TO
STEP IN IN THE VERY EARLY
TWENTIETH CENTURY TO HELP
DEVELOP THE WHAT WE NOW KNOW AS
THE STATE PLAN OF FLOOD CONTROL.
SO WE'VE REALLY BEEN OUT THIS
FOR OVER A HUNDRED YEARS -- WE
DID HAVE A PLAN BACK THEN IN
NINETEEN ELEVEN WHICH WAS THE
JACKSON REPORT AND I THINK TO
UNDERSTAND REALLY WHERE WHY WE
HAVE SOME OF THE CHALLENGES WE
HAVE NOW IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND WHY THAT.
WHY THE SYSTEM CAME ABOUT THE
WAY THAT IT DID WE TOUCHED ON
THAT JUST A LITTLE BIT IN THE
FIRST PANEL -- WHEN THE BOARD
WITH ASKED TO STEP IN AND
DEVELOP A PLAN? TO TAKE OVER THE
LEADERSHIP OF THIS -- WHAT THE
OBJECTIVE WAS AT THAT POINT WAS
TO DEAL WITH -- THE SEASONAL
RIVER RAIN FLOODING THAT WE HAD
WHILE ALSO MAKING SURE THAT THE
RIVERS WERE FLOWING FAST AND
SWIFT TO GET RID OF THE MINING
TAILINGS AND ALLOW FOR COMMERCE
TO CONTINUE UP THE RIVERS.
SO THAT'S WHY THIS BYPASS SYSTEM
DEVELOPED AND THAT'S WHY WE HAVE
I CONTINUE TO HAVE THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE HERE
TODAY.
IF YOU JUST TURN AYE AYE HAS
SENT A PACKET IF YOU TURN TO A
KIND OF THE FIRST PAGE OF YOUR
POCKET -- I I TOOK THIS FROM THE
INVESTMENT STRATEGY HIGHLIGHTS
FROM THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN PLAN
BECAUSE IT REALLY HAS A GREAT
GRAPHIC TO SHOW WHAT HAS CHANGED
IN A HUNDRED YEARS YOU LOOK ON
THE LEFT SIDE OF THE GRAPHIC.
THAT'S WHERE WE WERE IN NINETEEN
SEVENTEEN YOU LOOK ON THE RIGHT
SIDE OF THE GRAPHIC AND THAT'S
WHERE WE WERE WHEN WE ADOPTED
THE MOST RECENT ITERATION OF THE
PLAN IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN IF YOU
JUST TAKE A FEW SECONDS IF YOU
HAVE A CHANCE TO PRE THROUGH
THAT IT.
WILL REALLY GIVE YOU A GOOD
SENSE OF WHERE WE ARE.
ALTHOUGH THESE THINGS ARE VERY
COMPLEX THE BOARD HAS RECOGNIZED
THAT THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
OPPORTUNITIES TO REALIZE THE
VISION FOR THE FUTURE OF THE
VALLEY AS TO NOTED IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY FLOOD PROTECTION
PLAN WHICH IS REALLY THE
BLUEPRINT THAT WE ALL FOLLOW.
AND I KNOW THAT CHAIR GARCIA WHO
JUST HAD TO STEP OUT FOR A
MOMENT IS -- EX OFFICIO ON OUR
BOARD AND THIS IS HIS SECOND
YEAR THAT HE'S BEEN DOING THAT
SO I I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
THERE'S THE LEGISLATIVE
INVOLVEMENT IN OUR BOARD -- THE
SEVEN VOTING MEMBERS APPOINTED
BY THE GOVERNOR AND CONFIRMED BY
THE SENATE AND TO FOUR YEAR
TERMS ARE REALLY THE ONES THAT
DRIVE THE POLICY FOR THE BOARD
AND SO.
HAVING THAT INPUT -- FROM AND
ABILITY FROM THE LEGISLATORS IN
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IS ALSO
VERY HELPFUL FOR THE BOARD --
THE PLAN THAT WE HAVE NOW WAS
DEVELOPED WITH EXTENSIVE
STAKEHOLDER INPUT AND I'VE GOT
SOME LOCALS HERE THAT HOPEFULLY
ARE GOING TO ATTACHED TO THAT
AND TELL YOU HOW AND HOW THAT.
MAKES THE PLANIMPLEMENTABLE IN
AND THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE WITH
SOME OF THE OTHER PLANNING
EFFORTS THAT YOU MAY HAVE SEEN
THROUGHOUT THE STATUS WE HAVE
BROAD SUPPORT FOR THIS PLAN
WHICH MEANS WE CAN ACTUALLY DO
SOMETHING WITH IT AND THAT'S AND
NOT SOMETHING THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO US THAT.
THE BOARD.
SO HOW ARE WE HANDLING THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT I MENTIONED
I'M GONNA BREAK THAT DOWN JUST
INTO THREE CATEGORIES WE HAVE --
REGULATORY AND OVERSIGHT.
WE HAVE OUR NON FEDERAL
SPONSORING ASSURANCES ROLE AND
THEN MUCH LIKE THIS COMMITTEE
HERE WE HAVE -- DRIVING THE
VISION IN PROVIDING THE VENUE
WHERE THOSE EXCHANGE OF IDEAS
CAN HAPPEN -- I THINK YOU'RE ALL
FAMILIAR WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT WAS ISSUED
LAST WEEK THAT REQUIRES THE
STATE AGENCIES TO I THINK
DIFFERENTLY AND ACT BOLDLY. TO
DEVELOP A RESILIENT WATER
PORTFOLIO IN THE FLOOD WORLD
THAT SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN DOING
BY NECESSITY FOR AT THE OVER A
DECADE NOW -- AND I WANT TO
SHARE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW
WE'VE BEEN DOING THAT.
THE BOARD UTILIZES ITS BROAD
REGULATORY AUTHORITY OVER THE
SYSTEM TO MANAGE AND OVERSEE
MORE THAN A HUNDRED LOCAL
ENTITIES WHICH INCLUDE
RECLAMATION AND LEVY DISTRICTS
COUNTIES AND EVEN OUR PARTNERS
AT THE STATE WHEN THEY'RE AND
MAINTAINING.
MAINTENANCE AREAS THAT SECOND
THIRD PAGE OF MY HAND OUT HAS
THAT A GRAPHIC SHOWING ALL THOSE
DIFFERENT RECLAMATION LEVY
DISTRICTS AND JUST KIND OF SHOWS
YOU I SPREAD OUT THROUGHOUT THE
VALLEY ON BOTH THE SACRAMENTO IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN.
WE OVERSEE AND MANAGE ALL OF
THOSE AND THEY IN TURN ARE
OVERSEEING AND MANAGING THE
ENTIRE SYSTEM.
WHEN WE ADOPTED THE LATEST
ITERATION OF THE PLAN IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN ARE PRESIDENT OF THE
BOARD BILL ANCHOR STATED THAT
THE BOARD'S FOCUS WAS GOING TO
BE ON TAKING CARE OF WHAT WE
HAVE NOW?
AND FINDING A WAY TO PAY FOR IT.
SO IN THE ROLE OF TAKING CARE OF
WHAT WE HAVE NOW SOME OF THE
DISCUSSIONS WE'VE HAD SINCE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WITH OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS HAVE BEEN THROUGH WHAT
WE HAVE THAT THEN YOU CALLED THE
COORDINATING COMMITTEE.
AND WE REALLY DRILL DOWN AND A
LOT OF DETAIL ABOUT WHAT
OPERATIONSAND MAINTENANCE
REALLY MEANS WHAT IS OPERATIONS
AND MAINTENANCE THAT THE LOCALS
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR SINCE THE
STATE TURN THAT OVER TO THEM.
AND THEN WHAT REALLY DO WE NEED
TO LOOK MORE HOLISTICALLY WITH
ALL OF US TOGETHER ON WHAT WOULD
BE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE OR WHAT
WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT WOULDN'T
BE CONSIDERED -- SORT OF YOUR
TYPICAL OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE AND REALLY TRYING TO
SOLVE SOME OF THOSE COMPLEX
PROBLEMS THAT SOMETHING WE
WORKED ON LAST YEAR WHICH
RESULTED IN THE ISSUANCE OF
BOARD RESOLUTION TWENTY EIGHTEEN
DASH OF SIX WHICH THAT STANDARDS
FOR THE OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT OUR
GOAL IS TO GET. TO YOU
COMPLIANCE WITH THE FEDERAL
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE
MANUALS THAT WE AS THE STATE
SAID BACK IN THE NINETEEN
FIFTIES THAT WE WERE GOING TO DO.
AND THEN FINDING A WAY THAT WE
COULD SANTA VISE AND ASSIST THE
LOCAL AGENCIES IN TWO GETTING
INTO COMPLIANCE WITH THE FEDERAL
PEEL EIGHTY FOUR NINETY NINE
PROGRAM.
AND THAT IS SOMETHING THAT IS OF
IMPORTANCE TO THE STATE BECAUSE
AS YOU'VE HEARD EARLIER -- THE
STATE DOES HAVE LIABILITY FOR
THE SYSTEM AND SO AS MUCH AS WE
TRY TO LEVERAGE ALL OF THE
AVAILABLE FUNDING TO HELP AND
ASSIST WHEN THERE ARE -- DAMAGE
TO THE SYSTEM THAT'S ONE WAY
THAT WE CAN DO THAT.
THE JUST TO BRIEFLY TELL YOU
ABOUT THE PL EIGHTY FOUR NINETY
NINE PROGRAM THAT WOULD PROVIDE
1100% FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
REPAIRS TO CATASTROPHIC FAILURES
TO STATE PLAN A FLOOD CONTROL
LEVEES AND SO.
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE THAT -- AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON WITH THE LOCALS TO
MAKE SURE THAT CAN HAPPEN AS
WELL AS REESTABLISHING OUR
COMMITMENT. TO DEALING WITH --
THOSE THINGS THAT ARE WITH ON
WITHIN SPECIFICALLY THE BOARD'S
JURISDICTION LIKE HANDLING
FIFTEEN THOUSAND ENCROACHMENTS
UPON THIS SYSTEM THAT STILL HAVE
TO BE DEALT WITH THAT HAVE.
CROPPED UP OVER A HUNDRED YEARS.
WITH ALSO REALLY BEEN OUT THERE
SHAKING THE TREES TRYING TO FIND
THE THE MONEY TO PAY FOR THIS --
THE AS YOU HEARD FROM RACHEL IN
THE LA YELLOW -- MANAGING THE
SYSTEM THROUGH BOND FUNDS AND
AND THE OCCASIONAL GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION DOES NOT PROVIDE A
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING. FOR ALL OF
THE WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE --
THANKS AND IN LARGE PART TO THE
ALLOCATION THAT WE RECEIVED IN
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET THE BOARD IS
COMMISSION DAY -- A STUDY TO SEE
IF WE COULD.
ARE RE UTILIZED AND REINVIGORATE
THE SACRAMENTO AND SAN JOAQUIN
DRAINAGE DISTRICT WHICH BACK IN
NINETEEN ELEVEN WAS SOMETHING
THAT THE BOARD USED TO RAISE
FUNDS.
TO BUILD THE ORIGINAL SYSTEM AND
TO MANAGE IT UP AND THREW UP
THROUGH THE NINETEEN TWENTIES OF
WE DID THAT SO -- WE APPRECIATED
THAT -- AUTHORIZATION AND WE ARE
WORKING ON THAT AND HOPEFULLY
WE'LL HAVE MORE ABOUT THAT IN
THE NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS.
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN CENTRAL
VALLEY FLOOD PROTECTION PLAN
NOTED THAT -- WE REALLY ARE ONLY
SPENDING AROUND THIRTY MILLION
ANNUALLY ON ACTUAL OPERATIONS
AND MAINTENANCE AND WE SHOULD BE
SPENDING CLOSER TO A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION SO WE'VE REALLY
BEEN WORKING TO TRYING CLOSE
THAT GAP.
IN OUR NON FEDERAL SPONSOR ROLE
THE BOARD HAS ALWAYS BEEN THE
NON FEDERAL SPONSOR WITH THE
ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS
PARTNERING ON THESE LARGE SCALE
SO SWITCHING OVER TO KIND OF THE
LARGE SCALE PROJECTS IN.
THE LAST DAM FOUR PAGES IN YOUR
PACKET THAT I PROVIDED THAT
THERE ARE THE FACT SHEETS.
FOR THE FOR PROJECTS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY ON GOING IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THAT ARE BEING
FUNDED BY THAT SPECIAL
ALLOCATION SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING
THAT WAS A PART OF THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGET -- FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SO THAT WAS
IN RESPONSE -- TO REQUEST BY IF
THEY ALREADY TEAMS THAT TELLING
THE ARMY CORPS THEY'VE GOT TO
MOVE DIRT TURNED OR GET THESE
THINGS BELT SO WITH THIS FUNDING
AND WITH THAT IMPETUS FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THE ARMY CORPS IS TRYING VERY
HARD TO SPEND ALL THIS MONEY ON
AMERICAN RIVER COMMON FEATURES
ON THE FOLSOM DAM REYES.
THERE'S TULE RIVER PROJECT AND
THEN ALSO IN THE U. BUT BASS AND
AND THAT'S WHERE THAT MONEY IS
BEING SPENT SO THE BOARD IS
PARTNERING ON THAT AND THOSE ARE
SOME VERY EXCITING LARGE SCALE
PROJECTS BUT IT'S ALSO REQUIRING
US AS THE GOVERNOR HAS SAID TO
SORT OF THINK.
DIFFERENTLY RATHER THAN GOING
THROUGH HOW WE'VE BEEN GOING
THROUGH WITH A HUNDRED MILLION A
YEAR ALLOCATED FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THEY GOT A GLASS ALL
AT ONCE AND THEN YOU HAD TO
REALLY RETHINK HOW YOU'RE DOING
IT.
DESIGNING BUILDING CONSTRUCTING
ALL AROUND ALL AT THE SAME TIME
SO -- ALL OF THE PARTNERS ARE
WORKING HARD TO MAKE SURE THAT
HAPPENS -- ON THE VENUE SIDE
OVER THE PAST DECADE WE'VE HAD
HUNDREDS OF MEETINGS AT THE
BOARD AND THIS IS WHERE.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE HAVING THE
LOCAL INTERESTS WE HAVE A A LOT
OF PARTNERS TO SHOW UP TO THAT
NOT JUST -- THE MAINTAINERS THAT
YOU SEE HERE TODAY BUT NGOS --
COME THE PART OF HOW THE
CONSERVATION STRATEGY WAS SO
SUCCESSFUL IN THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN ITERATION OF THE PLAN
IS BECAUSE WE HAD A GROUP OF OF
NGOS COME UP AND SAY WE REALLY
NEED TO DO THIS THIS IS YOU HAVE
TO DEVELOP THESE -- THE
ECOSYSTEM UP LIFT WE HAVE TO
HAVE SOMETHING WE CAN MEASURE
THAT AGAINST AND NOT SOMETHING
WE'RE STARTING TO WORK ON AND
YOU SHOULD BE SEEING THAT -- FOR
THE NEXT ITERATION OF THE PLAN
AS WELL.
I KNOW YOU WERE INTERESTED IN
CLIMATE CHANGE -- AND I TO TALK
ABOUT JUST A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
WHERE WHERE WE WERE IN THAT IN
THE PAST AND TO GIVE A LITTLE
SHOUT OUT TO ONE OF THE
PARTICULAR PROGRAMS THAT WE
MANAGE THAT I KNOW IS A IS NEAR
AND DEAR TO MELINDA TERRY'S
HEART -- FOR THE PAST FORTY
YEARS -- WE HAVE BEEN
ADMINISTERING THE DELTALEVY
SUBVENTION PROGRAM AND THAT IS
FOR BOTH PROJECT AND NON PROJECT
LEVEES.
AND THAT HAS BEEN BY A REALLY
ANY MEASURE AS SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM -- JUSTIN IN MANAGING
THAT THE REGULAR MAINTENANCE AND
KEEPING CATASTROPHIC VILLAGE
FROM HAPPENING MAYOR -- AND IT'S
REALLY BEEN A GOOD RETURN ON
INVESTMENT FOR THE STATE SO I
MEAN A LOT MELINDA TALK A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT WHAT THAT MEANS
FROM A LOCAL PERSPECTIVE --AND
JUST KIND OF LEAVE YOU WITH THIS
THOUGHT TWENTY EVENTEEN WAS A
VERY WET WINTER YOU HEARD A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT WE HAD
THAT YOU SAW THE VERY COLORFUL
ATMOSPHERIC RIVER GRAPH.
AND THAT DROVE A LOT OF WHAT
HAPPENED IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THOSE HIGH WATER EVENTS.
AND EVEN THOUGH -- THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS IS STEPPING INTO
THE P. LED FOR NINETY NINE
PROGRAM TO PAY ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OF THE
DAMAGE FROM THAT AND THAT IS
DAMAGE WITHOUT A CATASTROPHIC
FAILURE THOSE ARE JUST THE THE
SLIPPAGE IS IN THE EROSION AND
THE AND THE OTHER -- FLOOD
FIGHTING PROBLEMS THAT WE HAD.
THE STATE STILL I HAVE TO COME
UP WITH ANOTHER FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION OR SO RIGHT AND TWO
YEARS LATER WE ARE STILL TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW.
TO HOW TO MANAGE THAT HOW TO FIX
THAT HAD TO DEAL WITH THAT AND
THIS YEAR AGAIN WE HAVE HIGH
WATER ALTHOUGH NOT THE SAME KIND
OF HIGH WATER WE HAD TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AM AS YOU'VE ALREADY
DISCUSSED AT LENGTH WE HAVE VERY
HIGH SNOW PACK IN THE SIERRA
BOTH.
IN THE NORTH AND THE SOUTH.
AND THE FLOOD SEASON IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN RUNS THROUGH JULY
FIFTEENTH SO THAT'S SOMETHING WE
AT SPECIAL ATTENTION TO YOU KNOW
NEARLY ALL SUMMER IS HOW ARE WE
GETTING HOW IS THAT SNOW GOING
TO GET OUT OF THE MOUNTAINS AND
SAFELY THROUGH THE SYSTEM.
SO ENSURING RESILIENCY THROUGH
CLIMATE CHANGE IS SOMETHING WE
REALLY BEEN WORKING ON FOR QUITE
AWHILE OUT OF NECESSITY JUST
BECAUSE OF HOW THE SYSTEM CAME
CAME ABOUT AND HOW THIS IS HOW
WE'VE HAD TO MANAGE WE'VE DONE
THESE CAREFUL PLANNING --
EFFORTS AND WE'VE GOT TO
ITERATIONS OF THE FLOOD PLAN NOW
I CARRY MINE AROUND WITH ME AND
IT'S ALL DOGEARED AND AND HAS A
LOT OF POST ITS ON IT BECAUSE WE
WE ACTUALLY DO USE THAT -- A LOT
WITH OUR WITH OUR EFFORTS AND
HOW WE PRIORITIZE AND WE'RE
LOOKING AT GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE
THERE'S A LOT OF QUESTIONS THAT.
HAVE COME UP THAT THE BOARD IS
DEALING WITH AND THAT WE WILL BE
LOOKING OUT FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO PLAN AS WELL --
THERE'S SOME REALLY EXCITING
DISCUSSIONS GOING ON ALSO ABOUT
THE NEXUS BETWEEN FLOOD
MANAGEMENT AND THINGS LIKE
GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT
FLOODPLAIN MANAGEMENT
GROUNDWATER RECHARGE THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS -- YOU CAN LOOK FOR
SOME OF THAT COMING UP IN THE
FUTURE AS WELL.
SO I JUST WANT TO INVITE YOU TO
KIND OF LOOK AT OUR WEB PAGE IF
YOU GET A CHANCE WE HAVE A LOT
OF GOOD INFORMATION ON THERE WE
HAVE ALL THE BOARD MEETING
SCHEDULES WE ALTHOUGH.
ALSO BROADCAST THE BOARD
MEETINGS -- ANY OF THE AGENDA
ITEMS THAT ARE COMING UP THAT
ANYONE HAS A PARTICULAR INTEREST
AND WE'D BE.
HAPPY TO DISCUSS ANY OF THAT
WITH YOU.
AND I JUST WANT TO KIND OF LEAVE
YOU WITH -- KNOWING THAT THERE
IS A COLLABORATION OF LOCAL
FEDERAL AND STATE PARTNERS THAT
THIS IS ALSO ON THE MINDS OF THE
PEOPLE THAT YOU HAVE PUT IN
CHARGE OF THE SYSTEM AND THAT WE
REALLY ARE AND I'M THINKING VERY
BROADLY.
PLANNING VERY CAREFULLY AND
COLLABORATING WIDELY AND AND I
TAKE HEART IN THE FACT THAT
THAT'S HAPPENING -- SO I
APPRECIATE YOU HAVING ME HERE
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND COME BACK AND
REPORT.
WHEN WE FINISHED GREAT TO SWITCH
OVER TO ME TO QUESTION?
I'M GONNA GO AHEAD OF ME AGAIN --
HI MELINDA TERRY THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER VALLEY
FLOOD CONTROL ASSOCIATION --
WHICH WAS ESTABLISHED IN
NINETEEN TWENTY SIX AND LESLIE
HAD IN ONE OF HER PAGES ALL
THOSE RECLAMATION DISTRICTS AND
THE TWO SYSTEMS WE DO NOT
REPRESENT ALL THOSE BUT WE DO
HAVE -- OVER SEVENTY MEMBERS
THAT ARE FROM LIKE THE CHICO
MAYBE DOWN TO TRACY SO WE DON'T
COVER THE UPPER SAN JOAQUIN.
A PART OF THAT SYSTEM -- BUT
WITH A LARGE SO PACKED THIS YEAR
WE REALLY DO APPRECIATE BEING
INVITED IN THE FACT THAT YOU ALL
ARE THINKING ABOUT IT -- WHEN I
STARTED MY JOB ONE OF THE THINGS
I WENT DID WAS THE TOUR AT THE
FLIGHT OPERATIONS CENTER SO I
WAS GLAD TO HEAR THAT THE CHAIR
DID AND I DO ENCOURAGE THE STAFF
AND OTHER MEMBERS TO DO THAT --
IT IS VERY IMPRESSIVE AND IT'S
YOU KNOW SOMETHING THAT'S
HELPFUL AND TELL YOU LOOK THE
MATH AND APPRECIATE ALL THE
DISCUSSION BECAUSE THIS IS THE
LOGICAL COMMON SENSE WHEN YOU
LOOK AT SOME OF THAT IT'S SCARY
AND ALL THE TIME -- AND THAT'S
WHAT MY MEMBERS HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT EVERY SINGLE DAY.
BUT I YOUR INTRO COMMENTS WERE
JUST PERFECT IF I THINK SETTING
THE FOUNDATION FOR WHERE WE'RE
GOING TO HEAD ON OUR COMMENTS --
TO AND AS YOU HEARD THIS IS
REALLY AN X. EXTENSIVE -- SYSTEM --
AND THE STATE DOES HAVE
LIABILITY OUR MEMBERS ARE THE
LOCAL MAINTAINING AGENCIES
RECLAMATION DISTRICTS.
AND COLMAR DIS AND BUT THE STATE
ALTERNATELY STILL MAINTAINS THAT
LIABILITY THE PATERNAL LAWSUITS --
SOMEBODY TO ASK QUESTIONS
EARLIER IT WAS THE NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX THERE WAS A LEVEE
FAILURE OF OUR PROJECT WE CALL
PROJECT LEVEES OF THE STATE PLAN
A FLOOD CONTROL -- IT ENDED UP
IN COURT FOR MORE THAN TWENTY
YEARS SO IT WASN'T SETTLED UNTIL
ABOUT TWO THOUSAND FOUR AS I
RECALL.
IF YOU CAN REMEMBER OR CONNIE
DECLINED AT THAT POINT BECAUSE
CONSTRUCTION HOUSING AND
COLLAPSED -- IT WAS EIGHT
HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION DOLLAR
JUDGMENT -- WILLS INTERESTS THAT
HAD ACTUALLY CRUDE OVER THAT
TWENTY SMOKING HERE'S BUT THE
STATE'S TOTAL FOR FOREIGN FORTY
MILLION STATE AND HAVE THAT
MONEY WE WERE WE WERE IN HARD
ECONOMIC TIME BUDGET TIMES --
THEY PAID OUT OVER TEN YEARS SO
IT IT CAN GET YOU KNOW VERY
EXPENSIVE -- AND SO IT'S THAT
WHOLE PREVENTION OF THING IS IS
WHERE WE COME IN OF THE
MAINTENANCE TO HELP REALLY TRY
TO MAINTAIN IT.
GET OUT AHEAD OF IT YOU'RE NEVER
GOING TO A BE CAUGHT UP BECAUSE
IT'S LIKE YOUR LAUNDRY YEAH YOU
MAY HAVE DONE LAUNDRY YESTERDAY
BUT YOU'RE WEARING CLOTHES BEING
SOCIABLE FAMILY SO.
GUESS WHAT YOU GET TO DO YOU IN
A COUPLE DAYS SO IT'S JUST A
CONSTANT STATE AND IT'S ABOUT
ANTICIPATING WHAT'S COMING.
A HEARING LOVING.
THE OTHER LEFT -- BUT IT'S A
ANYWAY OUR OUR MEMBERS REALLY
DID -- SIGN THESE AGREEMENTS
WITH THE STATE AS WELL TO BE
THEIR LOCAL PARTNER IN THAT --
IN ADDITION LIABILITY THE STATE.
THERE ARE SOME PLACES WHERE
THERE ARE NOT RECLAMATION
DISTRICT SALUTE ALAMAIN.
AND SO THE STATE ACTUALLY DOES
MAINTAIN SOME OF THE LEVEES THEY
HAVE OPERATIONS THAT DO THAT I I
WANT TO SAY THERE'S NINE OR TEN
OF THEM -- THAT THEY DO HAVE TWO
MAIN AREAS THEY MAINTAIN
THEMSELVES THEY'RE ALSO
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE MAINTENANCE
OF THOSE BY PASSES.
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT YOLO AND
CENTER AND HIS BILL THESE SEVEN
BY PASSES THAT'S A RELIEF VALVE.
YOU CAN IMAGINE A REALLY BIG
WHAT EVENTS WHEN THEY PHILIP
YOU'VE GOT A LOT OF SENTIMENT
DEBRIS SO THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY
THAT I HOPE THE LEGISLATURE
THINKS ABOUT IN TERMS OF THE
RESPONSIBILITIES.
YOU KNOW ON THE STATE SIDE AND
FOR KEEPING THE CHANNELS BECAUSE
WE'VE GOT MAPS THAT SHOW THE
DESIGN CAPACITY FOR THE FLOOD
FLOWS.
BUT WHEN YOU GET SETTLEMENT
STUFF COMING IN EVERY YEAR
YOU'RE LOSING THAT CAPACITY
RIGHT SO THERE IS A LOT OF
MAINTENANCE JUST BE ON THOSE
LEVEES THAT I HOPE THE
LEGISLATURE -- WILL THINK ABOUT --
OUR MEMBERS A LOT OF OUR MEMBERS
ARE ALSO RESPONSIBLE FOR MAIN
SINCE OF NON PROJECT LEVEES IN
THE DELTA -- AS WELL BUT
ESSENTIALLY OF MY MEMBERS WORK
REVOLVES AROUND ONE PARADIGM --
AND THAT'S THE FACT THAT EVERY
WINTER -- ARE LEVEES ARE GONNA
EXPERIENCE WEAR AND TEAR.
EVERY SINGLE YEAR AND THEN SOME
YEARS ARE WORSE THAN OTHERS --
BUT EVERY YEAR THAT WILL HAPPEN
SOME THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT.
I THINK THE COMBINATION OF THE
INCREASE FUNDING THAT YOU HEARD
TALK TO BUY BY THE LA HELLO --
THIS AT NEW CENTRAL VALLEY FLOOD
PROTECTION PLAN THAT WE HAVE --
THEY REALLY PAID OFF -- WOULDN'T
HAVE LEVEE FAILURES IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND YOU KNOW KNOCK ON
WOOD WE'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE
SOME THIS YEAR DESPITE THE RISKS
YOU KNOW THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
AND FACING -- SO I MEAN TO ME
THAT IS A REALLY GOOD THING IT
WE SHOULDN'T EVER FORGET THAT
THAT RISK IS THERE BUT IT IS
STILL A VERY GOOD THING -- A
MAJOR REASON I THINK FOR THE
COMBINATION OF THIS FUNDING AND
THE PLANNING IN MY OPINION AS
HURRICANE KATRINA -- IT WAS A
DISASTER AND A NIGHTMARE FOR NEW
ORLEANS BUT IT REALLY ENDED UP --
BEING MOTIVATION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED LEGISLATION
REQUIRING THE ADOPTION OF THE
SOCIAL BALLOT FLOOD PROTECTION
THAT WE PLAN AND WE ARE NOW
IMPLEMENTING.
AND THE VOTERS APPROVED A FLOOD
ONLY BOND THAT YEAR OF THE FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS AND I THINK IT
WAS RATE YOUR QUESTION BECAUSE
REALLY.
AFTER THAT SUBSEQUENTLY WE SEEN
ADDITIONAL -- BOND FUNDING BUT
IT'S A SMALL PORTION OF WATER
BONDS THAT ARE BONDS ARE FOCUSED
ON WATER SUPPLY -- BUT AGAIN
BECAUSE WE'RE STATE WE HAVE
DROUGHTS AND FLOODS I MEAN THAT
THAT'S THE OUR REALITY THAT WE
LIVE IN.
BUT THERE'S SO THERE'S SMALLER
BOND FUNDS THAT GO TOWARDS THAT
THAT FLOOD RISK IN THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO BUILD MORE
STORAGE -- BUT AGAIN IT ENDED UP
KIND OF A GOOD CASE SUCH
SITUATION -- THE THING TO KEEP
IN MIND -- WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
THE FEDS TO PAY FOR SOME STUFF
BUT THE ONE THING THAT THEY
DON'T I DON'T CARE IF YOU'RE
FEMA OR THEIR ARMY CORPS THEY
DON'T PAY FOR MAINTENANCE?
THAT'S ALL ON US BETWEEN THE
STATE IN THE US -- THAT'S ALL ON
US THEY DON'T PAY FOR THAT AND
THAT'S REALLY WHAT WE TALK ABOUT
FUNDING WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO
LOOK FOR THAT MEAN INSTALLERS --
WE DID TALK ABOUT THE INCREASED
OF RECOGNITION THAT WHEN THE
BOND FUNDS AREN'T THERE WE DO
HAVE TO GO TO GENERAL FUND IT'S
NOT LIKE YOU CAN IGNORE.
THAT MAINTENANCEIN THOSE GIVEN
YEARS AND THIRTY MILLION IS NOT
ENOUGH THAT HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION IS REALLY WHERE
WE'RE HEADING TOWARDS -- BUT
THROUGH THE IMPLEMENTATION IN
THESE MONTHLY MEETINGS WHERE WE
REALLY DO TALK ABOUT THE HARD
STUFF THERE -- BUT AS WE CAME UP
WITH THE IDEAS OF CREATING DUE
TO THE DEPARTMENT ACTUALLY
CREATED TWO NEW FUNDING PROGRAMS
FOR MAINTENANCE.
AND SO NOW WE'VE GOT
OPPORTUNITIES OF WHERE THE
LEGISLATURE CAN ACTUALLY
DIRECTLY APPROPRIATE MONEY WHICH
THAT DELTA LEVY SUBVENTION
PROGRAM THAT SHE MENTIONED HAS
BEEN EXTREMELY SUCCESSFUL OVER
TOPPING OFF WAS VERY COMMON IN
THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES.
FEMA GOT VERY UPSET AT THE STATE --
AND WE HAVEN'T HAD OVERTOPPING
IN THE DOUBLE TO SENSE THAT
PROGRAM CAME AND THE MAINTENANCE
PROGRAM CAME INTO PLACE.
AND THE LEGISLATURE DOES
DIRECTLY APPROPRIATE FUNDING
TOWARDS THAT AND THAT'S ALWAYS A
GOOD WAY TO GO -- WE ARE
CHALLENGED WHEN WE'RE DOING OUR
COST YEARS WE DO HAVE TO DO PROP
TWO EIGHTEEN UNLIKE THE STATE
FOR THEIR MAINTENANCE AREAS --
SO WE DO HAVE TO GET LAND OVER
APPROVAL WHEN WE DO NEED TO
RAISE OUR ASSESSMENTS AND THAT
CAN BE A CHALLENGE PARTICULARLY
IN THE URBAN AREAS WHERE WE'VE
GOT MULTIPLE AGENCIES.
WE TYPICALLY HAVE -- WHERE I
LIVE WE HAVE LITTLE JUST A SAFE
CAR WAS SAFE BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT
A LARGER AGENCY THAT'S DOING BIG
CIVIL WORKS IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS
AND THEN YOU HAVE THE
RECLAMATION DISTRICT THAT ONCE
THOSE PROJECTS ARE DONE?
THEY TURN OVER FOR MAINTENANCE
OF THE RECLAMATION DISTRICTS BUT
YOU GET CHARGED TWICE IF YOU'RE
A LANDOWNER WITHIN THAT AREA
FROM TWO DIFFERENT ENTITIES AND
THEY'RE LIKE WELL I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY I'M GETTING
CHARGED.
FROM TWICE FOR THE SAME THING
FLOOD -- SO THEY HAVE TO
COORDINATE WHEN THEY'RE GOING TO
DO THERE BECAUSE EACH GONNA NEED
TO DO TO EIGHTEEN THERE'S A LOT
OF CHOREOGRAPHY THAT HAS TO GO
ON LOCALLY -- THE LEVEL OF
COOPERATION AT THE FLOOD BOARD
THOUGH IN OUR COORDINATING
COMMITTEE MEETINGS I HAVE TO
DEAL WITH A LOT OF STATE
AGENCIES IN MY ROLE. FOR THE
ASSOCIATION AND I WILL SAY THE
IT IS VERY NEEDS THE AMOUNT I
THINK OF INCLUSION THAT THEY
HAVE THAT THEY ACTUALLY INCLUDE
THIS AND WHEN WHERE THEY'RE
DEVELOPING THINGS -- AND THE
AMOUNT OF TRANSPARENCY SO YOU
KNOW WE DO GET A REALLY GOOD
PARTNERSHIP WHICH IS WHY WERE
ABLE TO THEN GET THAT LOCAL
SUPPORT THAT'S NEEDED FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION THAT LESLIE --
TALKED ABOUT.
SOME.
THE I DID PROVIDE A HAND OUTS --
WHICH JUST BECAUSE YOU HEAR US
TALK ABOUT DAMAGE TO LEVEES
EROSION SEEPAGE I JUST WANT TO
PROVIDE SOME PHOTOS I KNOW I'M
THAT TYPE OF PERSON IN ADDITION
A NEW.
TREND THE FLIGHT OPERATIONS I
WENT MY OUTLOOK TO LEVEES AND
LIKE I NEED TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
THAT'S THE KIND OF DAMAGE AND IT
WAS IN THE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS WE HAVE NOT FINISHED
DOING THOSE REPAIRS AND
UNDERSTAND AS THESE HIGH WATER.
THE WATER STAYS HIGH WE CANNOT
SEE THE DAMAGE BEING DONE THIS
YEAR BUT WE KNOW IT IS BEING
DONE -- LESLIE -- MEGAN'S GONNA
TALK INITIAL TALK ABOUT HOW
WATER LEVELS GO UP AND DOWN IT'S
THE EROSION IS OCCURRING.
BUT IF WE CAN'T SEE IT UNTIL
JULY WE HAVE A VERY SHORT WINDOW
TO DO THOSE REPAIRS.
SO IN ADDITION TO THINKING ABOUT
WHAT KIND OF MONEY THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO APPROPRIATE
FOR MAINTENANCE OF ITS SYSTEM
YOU NEED TO ANTICIPATE MAYBE
THIS YEAR.
ON PUTTING SOME MONEY TOWARDS
THE REPAIRS.
THAT WE NEED TO DO BETWEEN JULY
AND THE BEGINNING OF THAT
OCTOBER YOU KNOW FLOOD NOVEMBER
YOU KNOW FLOOD SEASON REALLY
STARTING -- AND I THINK BEING
ISN'T TALK ABOUT A LITTLE BIT
THAT ARE MEMBERS OF THE ONES
THAT.
ARE DOING THAT THAT -- THE DAILY
PATROL AND SO YOU HEARD ABOUT
THE C. DECK IN THE GAUGES THEY
DO GO ONLINE AND LOOK AT THOSE
DAILY.
AND THEY DO HAVE WITH RICK
USUALLY EACH DISTRICT WILL HAVE
OKAY WHEN LET'S SAY I STREET
BRIDGE GETS TO THIS LEVEL THAT'S
WHEN WE'RE GONNA START OR TWENTY
FOUR HOUR PATROLS RIGHT.
SO THEY THEY KNOW WHEN THEY'RE
GONNA START DOING THOSE THINGS
AND THEN THEY START MARKING AND
PAYING ATTENTION -- BUT THEY
THEY ACTUALLY DO THOSE AND OUR
FEAR OR THINGS LIKE HAVING THAT
LARGE SNOW PACK AND A PINEAPPLE
EXPRESS COME THROUGH -- THE
REALLY HOT DAYS THEY'RE JUST
GONNA -- MELTED SO FAST -- BUT
YOU DO HAVE TO BE CONCERNED YOU
KNOW WHETHER THIS IS OUR NEW
NORM OF HAVING TO DEAL WITH
THESE VERY SCARY NUMBERS WHEN
YOU LOOK AT A PIECE OF PAPER WHO
WOULDN'T BE AFRAID. TO DO LIKE
YOU SAID IT JUST TAKES
COMMONSENSE TALKED ABOUT IT IT
DOESN'T TAKE IN A CIVIL ENGINEER.
STAND YOU KNOW THAT IT'S THAT
IT'S A LITTLE SCARY OUT THERE --
OF I THINK I'VE HIT ON THAT -- I
WANT TO PUT IN A PLUG FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS OF
IS YOU KNOW NOT PART OF MY
MEMBERSHIP BUT WHETHER YOU'RE
THE LARGE RIVER SYSTEMS THEY'RE
ALREADY TRAINED THEY KNOW HOW TO
LATE OF THE SCREEN.
THEY KNOW HOW TO SAND BAG
PROPERLY HOW TO LAY IT PROPERLY
AND FAST AND THEN FOR THE CREEK
SYSTEMS THAT THE THE CURSE
SOMEONE OR SEE IT TALKED ABOUT.
THEY'RE ALSO REALLY CRITICAL IN
THOSE LOCAL AREAS FOR THAT
BECAUSE THEY ARE JUST SO FAST
AND I THINK THEY DON'T GET
ENOUGH CREDIT FOR REALLY HOW
IMPORTANT THEY ARE AND I DON'T
CARE RICH FLAVOR IT'S FIRE TO I
MEAN THEY'RE THEY'RE JUST
TRAINED ALREADY THEY'RE JUST A
GREAT -- ENTITY TO HAVE -- THE I
THINK WE TALKED ABOUT SO.
THOSE THINGS THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR THE NEW
PROGRAMS I'M GONNA LEAVE YOU
JUST WITH THREE WORDS TO THINK
ABOUT -- ONE IS VIGILANCE
THEY'RE JUST REALLY IS A CERTAIN
LEVEL OF MAINTENANCE THAT'S
NECESSARY -- TO REDUCE THE RISKS
TO QUALIFY FOR THAT FEDERAL
REPAIR FUNDING FROM BOTH
PROGRAMS ARE GOING TO WANT TO
KNOW THAT WE DID OUR MAINTENANCE.
AND ALSO TO RESPOND TO CLIMATE
CHANGE IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
THE SECOND WORD IS SYNERGY --
THE FLOOD BOARD LIKE I SAID IT
HAS A PLAN FOR THE STATE PLAN A
FLOOD CONTROL -- INCLUDING THE
EXPENDITURES THAT ARE REALLY
NEEDED -- FOR IMPLEMENTATION AND
WE HAVE SUCH REAL IMPRESSIVE
LEVEL OF COORDINATION AND
COOPERATION -- THAT YOU JUST
DON'T SEE ANY OTHER STATE
AGENCIES AT LEAST I DON'T AND
THIRD WORD IS CONSISTENCY.
IT'S AN AND THAT I REALLY JUST
MEAN IT'S ABOUT RELIABLE
APPROPRIATIONS -- BOND FUNDING
IS NOT THAT RELIABLE SO
HOPEFULLY THE LEGISLATURE CAN
GET USED TO SOME LEVEL OF
GENERAL FUND.
A YOU KNOW AS A BASELINE AND YOU
KNOW MAYBE WE LOOK AT HOW TO USE
THOSE BIGGER FUNDS WHEN THEY
COME IN.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M MEGAN NEED
GEE I'M THAT RECLAMATION
DISTRICT ONE AWAIT DEPUTY
GENERAL MANAGER FOR FLOOD
CONTROL.
I DO IN THE DISTRICT ABOUT TWO
YEARS AGO AFTER A TWENTY YEAR
CAREER AT THE ARMY CORPS OF
ENGINEERS -- WHERE I SERVED AS
THE EMERGENCY MANAGER FOR THE
SACRAMENTO DISTRICT AND LEADER
AS THE LEVY SAFETY PROGRAM
MANAGER OVER INSPECTIONS AND
PERMITTING?
SO -- HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
JOIN RT WHEN I WAIT AND JUMPED
ON THAT OPPORTUNITY TO TO REALLY
GET INTO BE THE BOOTS ON THE
GROUND -- WHICH IS REALLY FUN TO
BE HONEST IS TO TO BE THE
FRONTLINE -- THIRTY ONE AWAIT
WAS FORMED IN -- EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY JUST TWO YEARS AFTER THE
RECLAMATION DISTRICT LAW -- THEY
WERE FORMED TO BUILD LEVEES AND
RECLAIM LAND FROM OWNERS THAT
OVERFLOWED NEARBY RIVERS.
IN NINETEEN THIRTEEN TO NINETEEN
FIFTEEN THE LEGISLATURE CREATED
THE KNIGHTS LANDING RIDGE
DRAINAGE DISTRICT AND THE
SACRAMENTO RIVER WEST SIDE LEVY
DISTRICT -- LARGELY BECAUSE THEY
ARE YOU WANNA WAIT WAS REALIZING
THEIR BUILDING LEVEES THAT WERE
MOVING FAR BE BEYOND -- THEIR
DISTRICT BOUNDARIES.
AND SO.
THEY CREATED -- THESE TWO OTHER
DISTRICTS TO BETTER REPRESENT
THE LANDOWNERS THAT WERE BEING
PROTECTED -- WE CALL THOSE
SISTER DISTRICTS -- AND WE'VE
WORKED TOGETHER AS THREE
DISTRICTS -- SINCE THE INCEPTION --
WE WERE COST EFFECTIVELY AND
EFFICIENTLY TO OPERATE OVER
NINETY MILES OF LEVEES THAT SPAN
FROM COLUSA -- DOWN TO JUST
SOUTH OF KNIGHTS LANDING WHICH
FEEDS INTO THE YOLO BYPASS.
IT PROTECTS OVER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRES OF PRIME FARMLAND
AND SEVERAL SMALL COMMUNITIES.
IT'S LOCATED IN -- LOWER POLICE
COUNTY AND NORTHERN YOLO COUNTY.
WE MANAGEMENT STAFF OF FOUR AND
A TOTAL STAFF OF ABOUT -- TWENTY
FIVE AND I SERVED AS DEPUTY
MANAGER FOR ALL THREE OF THOSE
DISTRICTS THAT I MENTIONED -- SO
IN ADDITION TO FLOOD AND
DRAINAGE ON WE DO DRAINAGE AS
WELL AND ARE YOU WANT TO WAIT --
PARTY ONE WAY ALSO HAS A WATER
SUPPLY MISSION AND WE PROVIDE
WATER TO ABOUT FORTY EIGHT
THOUSAND ACRES OF FARMLAND IN
COLUSA AND YOLO COUNTIES.
SO LIKE MOST OTHER LOCAL
MAINTAINING AGENCIES WERE A LAND
OWNER RUN WORK -- AGENCY WE HAVE
A BOARD OF FIVE COMMISSIONERS
ARE TRUSTEES THAT ARE ELECTED BY
LANDOWNERS -- AND WE IMPLEMENT
THE DAILY OPERATION AND
MAINTENANCE OF THOSE NINETY LET --
NINETY MILES OF LEVEE.
SO IN THE SIMPLEST FORM MANY
ASSUME THAT -- LOCAL MAINTAINING
AGENCY SIMPLY GOES OUT AND
SPRAYS THE WEEDS AND MOST THE
GRASS AND KEEPS THE ROADS NICE
AND CLEAN AND AND DOES THE LEVEE
PATROLS WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
BUT IN REALITY WE DO WAY MORE.
THAN THOSE EVERYDAY ITEMS -- SO
WE WORK CLOSELY WITH THE CENTRAL
VALLEY FOR PRODUCTION BOARD --
AS WELL AS THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES -- AS YOU'VE
HEARD -- WE'VE ALSO WORKED
REALLY HARD TO FOSTER CLOSE
RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR COUNTIES
IN YELLOW AND COLUSA COUNTY --
WHICH HAS BEEN A HUGE HELP
DURING TIMES OF EMERGENCY --
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT FOR US TO
FOSTER RELATIONSHIPS ACROSS THE
RIVER WE'RE VERY CLOSE WITH OUR
NEIGHBORS IN ALREADY FIFTEEN
HUNDRED SEVENTY IN -- SIXTEEN
SIXTY WE NEED TO WORK TOGETHER
AS A TEAM -- WE ARE THE MIDDLE
OF OUR DISTRICT ON THE OPPOSITE
SIDE IS THE TUESDAY -- BY PASS
IF THAT IS THE BY PASS DOESN'T
FUNCTION GUESS WHAT THE WATER
GOES DOWN THROUGH MY LEVEES AND
PROVIDES GREATER RISK AND SO THE
DEPARTMENT MAINTAINS THE TISDALE.
BY PASS AND OUR NEIGHBORS ACROSS
THE STREET ARE KEENLY AWARE SO
WE ALL WORK TOGETHER IN THAT
REGARD -- WE ALSO WORK WITH JUST
OTHER ALL THE OTHER LOCAL
MAINTAINING AGENCIES IN THE
SACRAMENTO RIVER FLOOD CONTROL
PROJECT AND ESPECIALLY THOSE IN
WHAT WE CALL THE MID NUMBER
SACRAMENTO RIVER REGION -- SO
ARE YOU GOING TO WAIT STEPPED
FORWARD TO BE THE LEAD AGENCY --
FOR WHAT WE CALL THE MIDDEN
UPPER SACRAMENTO RIVER REGION --
AS PART OF REGIONAL FLOOD
MANAGEMENT PLANNINGTHAT STEMMED
OUT OF THE TWENTY TWELVE CENTRAL
VALLEY FLOOD PROTECTION PLAN.
WE ARE ONE OF SIX REGIONS -- AND
SO WE BRING TOGETHER A VARIETY
OF LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS TO HELP
THE STATE IN THE UPDATE OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY FLOOD PROTECTION
PLAN -- OR PARTICULAR REGION
COVERS A SEVEN COUNTY AREA OR
PRETTY BIG AREA -- AND I WOULD I
WOULD ARGUE THAT THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THOSE REGIONS AND THE
INVOLVEMENT OF THE LOCALS WAS
LARGELY THE GREAT SUCCESS OF THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN CENTRAL VALLEY
FLOOD PROTECTION PLAN HAVING
THAT LOCAL INPUT -- AND REALLY
BEING COLLABORATIVE IN THAT
UPDATE MADE THAT A SUCCESS -- SO
ONE OF THE OTHER ITEMS THAT
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO REGIONALLY
IS REGIONAL EMERGENCY RESPONSE
PLANNING -- JOHN'S PROGRAM HAS
PROVIDED GRANTS FOR MANY AREAS --
WE ESTABLISHED AS PART OF OUR
GRANT UNIFIED COMMANDS FOR
BROADER AREAS THAN JUST
OURSELVES SO WE'RE TALKING. TO
EACH OTHER AND WE SPENT TWO
COUNTIES AND LET ME TELL YOU IF
I COULD CHANGE THE COUNTY LINE
AND BE SO MUCH EASIER IT IS SO
COMPLICATED THAT TAKE. TO CROSS
THE COUNTY LINE IS A SPECIAL
DISTRICT JUST FROM FEMA FUNDING
FOR IT JUST EVERYTHING IS MAKES
IT MORE COMPLICATED SO IT'S
CRITICAL THAT WE'RE ALL TALKING.
I MEAN IF ONE OF OUR LEVEE
BREAKS IN COLUSA COUNTY IT IT'S
NOT GONNA STOP COUNTY LINE ROAD.
IT'S GOING TO CROSS IT AND GO
INTO YOLO COUNTY SO -- THAT
GRANT HAS BEEN HUGE IN HELPING
US WORK BETTER TOGETHER AND
BECOME CLOSER WITH OUR COUNTY --
YES OFFICES.
I'M PART OF THAT ESTABLISHED --
STOCKPILE MATERIALS WE BUILT
CONTAINERIZED FLOOD FIGHT
MATERIAL THAT WE USED IN --
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE WROTE
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS PLANS WHICH
YEAH UNFORTUNATELY FOR ME MY
FIRST DAY ON THE JOB WAS THE
FIRST DAY LEVY PATROL IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN SO I CAME IN.
YOU KNOW I DIDN'T KNOW ANY
LANDMARK I KNEW LEVEES I HAD
BEEN WORKING IN IT FOR A VERY
LONG TIME BUT I DIDN'T KNOW THE
LOCAL AREA AS WELL -- AND
WITHOUT THAT PLAN.
I WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
EXECUTE AS WELL SO THOSE
EMERGENCY RESPONSE GRANTS HAVE
BEEN PHENOMENAL -- SO.
WE ALL THE OTHER PART OF THE
GRANT WE CREATED ALL OF WHAT I'M
CALLING ON THE FLY FLOOD FIGHT
TRAINING -- SO WE CAN GO TRAIN
OUR FARMERS WHICH WE HAVE OUR
WE'VE GONE TO SOME OF THE LARGER
FARMS WE'VE TRAINED THEIR
FARMWORKERS WITH AN ONLINE VIDEO
IN FOUR HOURS TO BE ABLE TO HELP
US WITH OUR FLOOD FIGHT SO.
FOR IF WE CAN'T USE THE SEE SEE
SEE WE CAN GO TO OUR LOCAL
FARMERS AND SUPPLEMENT OUR STAFF
DURING TIMES OF EVENT -- AND
IT'S IT'S IT JUST MAKES A LOT
MORE SENSE TO INVEST IN THE
PLANNING NOW.
THAN IN THE CATASTROPHIC FAILURE
AFTERWARDS AND WE SEEN IT THE
MIDWEST THIS YEAR.
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE A LONG ROAD
AHEAD TO RECOVER FROM THAT
ECONOMIC DAMAGE AND SO IF
EVERYTHING WE CAN DO TO PLAN AND
PREVENT THAT IS CRITICAL.
SO PART OF THAT AND WE TALKED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE ARMY CORPS
OF ENGINEERS PROGRAMS FOR
REHABILITATION ASSISTANCE AND SO
MANY GIVE YOU SOME CONTEXT IN
NUMBERS.
SO WE JOINTLY WITH SEVERAL OTHER
RECLAMATION DISTRICTS JOINED TO
DEVELOP WHAT'S CALLED A SYSTEM
WIDE IMPROVEMENT FRAMEWORK.
IT'S BASICALLY A DOCUMENT THAT
YOU HAVE TO PROVIDE THE ARMY
CORPS OF ENGINEERS AS A GET WELL
PLAN.
THIS IS ALL THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE THAT YOU'VE
IDENTIFIED THAT WE NEED TO FIX
THIS IS OUR PLAN FOR FIXING IT
AND WE'RE GONNA DO IT AS A TEAM
THEY LOOK THEY DON'T LOOK AT
EACH RECLAMATION DISTRICT
SEPARATELY.
THEY LOOK AT PROTECTED AREAS SO
MY PARTICULAR AREA THAT ALREADY
ONE AWAY AND SACRAMENTO RIVER
WEST SIDE LEVY DISTRICT ARE PART
OF HAVE THREE OTHER LOCAL
MAINTAINING THE SYSTEM OF A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILES. TO
STAY ELIGIBLE THAT WHOLE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY MILES HAS TO BE GOOD.
SO WE HAVE TO WORK TO GET HER --
WE SPENT UP -- ABOUT TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS PUTTING
TOGETHER THE PLAN -- IT'S STILL
GOING THROUGH THE APPROVAL
PROCESS BUT WHILE IT GOES TO
THAT APPROVAL PROCESS YOU REMAIN
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS FEDERAL
FUNDING. TWENTY SEVENTEEN HEAD.
OUR BASIN WAS ELIGIBLE FOR FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
FUNDING.
I LOVE TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLAR INVESTMENT.
NOW WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
ADDRESS COMMENTS AND WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO REINVEST EVERY YEAR.
BUT IT'S REALLY CLEAR THAT'S A
GOOD INVESTMENT [inaudible]
SO.
WE WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE THAT PROGRAM AND THEN
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT
IT SO WHAT DOES THAT MEAN ALL
THAT DEFERRED MAINTENANCE THAT
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
ACTUALLY HAS TO GET TAKEN CARE
OF SO.
WE'VE THE BOARD HAS MELINDA SAID
IS BEEN PUTTING DOWN A
COORDINATING COMMITTEES AND AND
DIFFERENT COMMITTEES AND AND SO
ONE OF THE RECENT COMMITTEES.
AS THE INSPECTION COMPLIANCE
WORK GROUP HOW DO WE GET
TOGETHER. TO TO MAKE ALL OF OUR
JOINTLY WORK TOGETHER TO FIX ALL
THESE MAINTENANCE DEFICIENCIES
AND SO WE'RE STARTING ON THAT
AND I HAVE GREAT HOPE THAT WE'LL
BE ABLE TO WORK TOGETHER. TO
MINIMIZE COSTS FOR EVERYBODY
BECAUSE IF WE CAN WORK TOGETHER.
THEN WE CAN I'M NOT SPENDING
MONEY IN ANOTHER IDEAS IT'S BEEN
MANY ON THE SAME THING LETS YOU
KNOW POOL OUR RESOURCES -- TO A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THIS YEAR YOU
KNOW ITTHIS YEAR'S FLOOD EVENT
I THINK WAS REALLY DECEIVING --
DECEIVING BECAUSE THE SYSTEM
WORK WE HAVE A CATASTROPHIC
FAILURES RATE SO THAT'S A GOOD
THING.
BUT WE ALSO NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE ARE AWARE THERE'S
GOING TO BE DAMAGE AND IT VERY
WELL MIGHT BE SIGNIFICANT AND
IT'S STILL UNDER WATER IN MANY.
PLACES I KNOW IN THE SACRAMENTO
VALLEY ARE ARE RIVERS WILL COME
DOWN -- THE SAME JOAQUIN YOU
KNOW IT'LL STAY UP FOR AWHILE
AND SO WE WON'T REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT A REVISION --
DAMAGE THAT WE HAVE UNTIL THOSE
RIVERS RECEIPT -- AND I I WAS
COMPARING TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO
TWENTY NINETEEN A LITTLE BIT AND
NOTICED THAT THE FLUCTUATION AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE SEASON WAS
MUCH MORE DRAMATIC THAN IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHICHMEANS.
THE RIVERS GO UP AND DOWN A LOT
WE SEE MORE RUSSIAN WHEN THE
LIVER'S LIVE EAST IRWIN THE
REVERSE JUST STAY UP LIKE THEY
DID IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE SEE A
LOT MORE SEEPAGE.
WHICH YOU CAN SEE EASIER DURING
THE EVENT THE EROSION.
WE WE STILL DON'T KNOW WHAT WE
HAVE -- SO THAT'S GOING TO BE
IMPORTANT TO KEEP AN EYE ON WE
IT MOST PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE
THAT.
AT LEAST IN OUR AREA WE
PATROLLED FOR FIFTY DAYS THIS
YEAR LEVY PATROL WHEN WE GET
SEAT ACT AND WE HAVE A SPECIFIC
NUMBER WE GOT A LEVY PATROL WE
PATROLLED FOR FIFTY DAYS THAT'S
ONLY TWO DAYS LESS THAN IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE'VE EXCEEDED
OUR OUR EMERGENCY PATROL BUDGET
BY THREE TIMES -- AND SO FAR WE
DON'T HAVE AN A FEDERAL DISASTER
DECLARATION SO IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WE WERE ABLE TO RECOUP
A LOT OF THOSE CONTROL COSTS WE
DON'T HAVE A MECHANISM. TO
RECOUP THOSE COSTS SO THAT'S
JUST LESS MAINTENANCE THAT WE
CAN DO.
I'M THE CORE IS ALSO NOT OPENS
THE P. ONLY FOUR NINETY NINE
PROGRAM YET THIS YEAR WE DON'T
KNOW IF THEY WILL OR NOT -- BUT
ALL THOSE DAMAGES MAY NOT HAVE
FEDERAL ASSISTANCE THAT WE CAN
REACH INTO AND SO WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN THAT MORE FINANCIAL BURDEN
ON THE STATE AND LOCALS.
BECAUSE THE DAMAGE IS GOING TO
HAVE TO GET FIXED -- SO.
YOU KNOW I I CAN'T WE CAN'T LOSE
SIGHT OF THE FACT THAT THERE'S
GOING TO BE DAMAGE MORE DAMAGE
AND WE ALREADY HAVE A BACKLOG OF
DAMAGE FROM -- TWENTY SEVENTEEN
SO AS MELINDA STATED THAT YOUNG
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF INVESTMENT
IN THE URBAN AREAS.
WE'VE MADE GREAT PROGRESS THE
SYSTEMS HAS REALLY REALLY WORKED --
BUT WE NEED TO WORK TOGETHER TO
FIX THE OUTSTANDING STORM DAMAGE --
IF WE WAIT THEY JUST GET MORE
EXPENSIVE THEY DON'T GET THEIR
ON THEIR OWN IT JUST GETS MORE
EXPENSIVE.
AND WE ALSO NEED TO GET AHEAD OF
THE NEXT DISASTER AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WHAT'S NEXT --
PROTECTING OUR SMALL COMMUNITIES
AGRICULTURAL AREAS THE THAT
COMMUNITIES SUPPORT AGRICULTURE
IS KEY -- WE REALLY NEED TO
FOCUS ON THAT AS THE NEXT AREA --
SO WE CAN'T TAKE CARE OF THE
FLOOD INFRASTRUCTURE ALONE THE
ELEMENTS CAN ONLY DO SO MUCH AND
WE NEED TO WORK TOGETHER AS THE
STATE AND LOCALS AND THEN WE
NEED TO RELY ON EACH OTHER. TO
EFFECTIVELY MANAGE THE SYSTEM --
OUR INVOLVEMENT AT THE LANDOWNER
LEVEL BRINGS A FORM OF COST
EFFICIENCY.
TRUST IN ACCESS THE JUST THE
STATE AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
JUST CAN'T GET -- THE AMOUNT OF
TRUST THAT ARE LOCALS HAVE WITH
THE R. D. IS -- IS IT'S HUGE AND
AND SO WE CAN PROVIDE THAT.
AVENUE FOR THE LOCALS AND AND
EXPLAIN TO THEM THE STATE AND
FEDERAL PROGRAMS AND ALSO BE THE
VOICE BACK TO THE STATE AND
FEDERAL AGENCIES.
SO WE HAVE TO MOVE FORWARD IN
SYNC ALLOWING US TO BE MORE
SUCCESSFUL AND WERE ALWAYS -- WE
WE'VE DO WE'VE DONE A GREAT JOB
OF COLLABORATING MORE BUT YOU
CAN ALWAYS DO MORE SO WE CAN
ALWAYS DO BETTER AND KEEP MOVING
FORWARD AND TRYING.
TO ACT AS ONE RATHER THAN A
WHOLE BUNCH OF DIFFERENT
ENTITIES -- WE NEED TO CONTINUE
INVESTING IN EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS -- AS I SAID IT THE
PLANNING THAT WAS DONE IN OUR
REGION -- WAS PHENOMENAL -- BUT
IT IF YOU DON'T PRACTICE IF YOU
DON'T TRAIN IT GOES STALE SO WE
WILL HAVE ANOTHER ROUND OF
EMERGENCY RESPONSE GRANT WE WILL
KEEP THAT GOING IN OUR REGION
BUT THAT'S CRITICAL TO KEEP UP --
AND WE NEED TO CONVINCE CONTINUE
INVESTING IN OUR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND AS LESLIE SAID
TAKING CARE OF WHAT WE HAVE
WE'VE WE'VE GOT TO TAKE CARE OF
WHAT WE HAVE -- SUPPORTING THE
NEW PROGRAMS THAT HELP THE FLOOD
MAINTENANCE ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
IN THE FLOOD SYSTEM REPAIR
PROGRAM THOSE ARE TWO HUGE
PROGRAMS -- THAT THE STATE HAS
PUT TOGETHER THAT WILL ALLOW US
TO ADDRESS A LOT OF THAT
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE -- AND SO
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
WORKING TOWARDS THOSE PLANS AND
ULTIMATELY SO WE CAN REMAIN
ELIGIBLE FOR THAT FEDERAL
FUNDING.
IF WE DON'T CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORARD AND WE DON'T SHOW
PROGRESS.
GUESS WHAT WHAT WE BECOME AN
ELIGIBLE AGAIN NO MORE FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS RIGHT -- AND SO
INCREASINGLY IMPORTANT AS
CLIMATE CHANGE YOU KNOW IMPACTS
THE SAME IN THE FREQUENCY AND
THE INTENSITY OF THE STORMS
MIGHT CHANGE AND SERVICES EVER
MORE IMPORTANT -- AND AND WE
NEED TO INVEST IN OUR SMALL
COMMUNITIES YOU KNOW THE URBAN
INVESTMENTS HAVE BEEN A SUCCESS
AND IT'S TIME TO TO MOVE TO OUR
SMALL COMMUNITY IS THE NEXT BIG
LIABILITY FOR THE STATE --
BECAUSE THERE ARE ALSO
POPULATIONS THERE THAT -- ARE AT
RISK AND SO -- YOU KNOW ALL THE
PLANNING AND DATA COLLECTION AND
COORDINATING.
IT'LL ALL BE FOR NOT IF WE CAN'T
TAKE CARE OF WHAT WE HAVE A
MODERNIZE FOR THE FUTURE -- AND
SO EVERYTHING WE DO WORKS
TOWARDS -- REDUCING STATE
LIABILITY AS WELL AS REDUCING
RISK FOR OUR OUR LANDOWNER
ANYTIME WE REDUCE RISK IT IT
REDUCES THE STATE LIABILITY SO
WORKING TOGETHER SKI -- AND
ULTIMATELY WE ALL WANT TO
MAXIMIZE THAT FEDERAL INVESTMENT
IN TIMES OF EMERGENCY.
THAT'S ALL I HAVE.
OKAY THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY IT'S NICE TO HEAR THE
ENTHUSIASM IN YOUR VOICES -- FOR
FOR THE JOBS THAT YOU DO AND THE
HAVE APPRECIATION FOR
COLLABORATION THAT CERTAINLY
BEEN.
OUT FOR THE REGISTER HERE TODAY
I HAVE INTRODUCED LEGISLATION --
TO ASK D. W. R. TO LOOK AT THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE ON
BOTH -- YOU KNOW WATER SUPPLY
RELIABILITY SAFETY -- THE
GOVERNOR'S OPPOSITION EXECUTIVE
ORDER ALONG THE SAME LINES -- SO
A LOT OF ATTENTION.
ON THIS ISSUE AND FRANKLY.
I THINK WE ARE.
CAUGHT UP IN WHAT I LIKE TO CALL
THE STALE POLITICS OF THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES WHERE THIS
ENTIRE DISCUSSION -- HAS THE
ELEPHANT THE ROOM OF DAMS VERSES
NO DAMS.
AND THE CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
MOVEMENT VERSUS -- ALL THESE
OTHER KIND OF TECHNICAL ISSUES
IN THE WATER SIDE THE REALITIES
AT THE END OF THE DAY I'M A
BELIEVER THAT WE NEED -- ACROSS
THE BOARD COLLABORATION.
MORE COOPERATION BETWEEN REGIONS --
AND WE NEED TO MAKE MAJOR
INVESTMENTS IN INFRASTRUCTURE
AND IS TO BE KIND OF THE ANSWER
TO CALIFORNIA'S WATER QUESTION
TO BE ALL THE ABOUT RIGHT.
ENGAGE ALL THE NEW TECHNOLOGIES
ENGAGE CONSERVATION BUT ALSO
LEAVE ON THE TABLE THE
APPROPRIATE INVESTMENTS FOR BOTH
FLOOD MANAGEMENT LONG TERM WATER
SUPPLIES RELATES -- TO YOU KNOW
THE THE INCREASED -- I'M
RELIABLE -- CLIMATE CHANGE FACTS
RIGHT.
DOES THIS NEW DAMS CAN MAKE A
DIFFERENCE FULSOME IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX YOU KNOW WAS NEWER IT
MADE THE WHOLE DIFFERENCE THEY
ACTUALLY LET IT FILL UP HIGHER
THAN ITS DESIGN STANDARD AND
FRANKLY.
CROSS THEIR FINGERS BECAUSE
THERE ARE ALTERNATIVE WAS TO
EVACUATE FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE FROM SACRAMENTO BUT THANK
GOODNESS IT WAS THERE.
YOU KNOW THAT I GOT PLANNED FOR
AND IT WAS AVAILABLE.
BECAUSE MAYBE YOU KNOW I WELL I
HOPE IT'S BECAUSE PEOPLE WERE
PLANNING AND LIKE YOU SAID
THINKING AHEAD.
OR THINGS GONNA GET DIFFERENT
AND WE NEED TO PLAN FOR MORE.
TAKE CARE WHAT WE HAVE THE DO WE
NEED MORE THAT'S POSSIBLE.
EXACTLY.
JERRY GARCIA I HAVE A QUESTION
AND THAT IT HAS TO DO WITH.
HOW SOME OF OUR SMALLER
DISTRICTS ARE?
OF FAIRING WHEN IT COMES TO MAX
IS SEEN THE DOLLARS WERE EARLIER
WE TALKED ABOUT HOW MUCH.
MONEY HAS BEEN INVESTED OVER THE
LAST TWO DECADES.
P. M..
I DON'T THINK WOULD BE SURPRISED
IF WE NARROWED DOWN HOW MUCH HAS
GONE TO SOME OF THE SMALLER
DISTRICTS IN.
RURAL CALIFORNIA BUT I GUESS I'D
LIKE TO HEAR FROM YOU.
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT YOU'RE SAYING DIRECTLY --
SO THAT AS WE ARE ROLLING OUT
THESE DOLLARS AND CRITERIAS --
WERE MAKING SURE THEY WERE
KEEPING IN MIND -- THOSE --
SPECIFIC HER HURDLES RIGHT THAT
PRESENT THEMSELVES IN NOT SO
MUCH JUST THE WORLD THE BIGGER --
URBAN AREAS GET ALL THE MONEY
LET LET'S GET MORE SPECIFIC TO
SO WHAT ARE EXACTLY THOSE A
CHALLENGES THAT WERE SEEN IN
THAT PROCESS.
I WILL SAY THAT AGAIN AFTER
KATRINA AND THE LEGISLATURE DID
THE LEGISLATION REQUIRING THE
FLOOD PLAN -- THE OTHER THING IT
REQUIRED WAS FOR THE URBAN AREAS
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY SYSTEM
ANYWAY TO GET UP TO TO IT TO
ENTER YOUR LEVEL OF PROTECTION
BY.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND SO
THEY'VE ALL THAT'S PART OF THE
REASON WHY STATE FUNDING IN
PARTICULAR WAS GOING TO THE
TOWARDS THAT AREA BUT ALSO
BECAUSE THAT IS WHERE THE HIGHER.
RISK OF LOSS IS IF YOU WILL SO
IT BUT WAS WITH THE INTENTION
THAT YOU KNOW YOU YOU DO HAVE TO
THEN TAKE EVERY OTHER PARTS OF
THE SYSTEM -- THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOES A LITTLE BIT OF
THE SIMILAR THING WE'VE SEEN
THAT SOMETIMES OF THE NEWER
PROJECTS ARE WANTING TO DO.
ARE IN THE URBAN AREAS AND
TRYING TO GET TO THEIR COST
BENEFIT RATIO THAT THEY REQUIRE
FOR THESE RURAL AREAS IS IS
SOMETIMES A LITTLE BIT MORE
DIFFICULT.
BUT I'M ON ALL IT MEGAN HIT UPON
THAT I WILL SAY IN TERMS OF SOME
OF THE STATE FUNDING PROGRAMS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE IN THE DELTA.
AS I MENTIONED FOR FORTY YEARS
WE'VE HAD THE DELTA SUBVENTIONS
PROGRAM FOR MAINTENANCE AND WE
HAVE ONLY HAD TWO FAILURES IN
THE LAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS AND
NONE OF NEW FEELINGS FOR
OVERTOPPING SINCE IT'S BEEN.
IN PLACE -- AND AND WE DO HAVE
THESE TWO NEW PROGRAMS JUST
RECENTLY CREATED BY DEPARTMENT
OF WATER RESOURCES THAT REALLY
ARE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
RURAL AREAS -- TO START ACCESS
SCENE AND I AGAIN A LET ME AGAIN
MAYBE YOU'VE HAD ON HOW THEY USE
THAT BUT THAT'S THOSE ARE THE
USEFUL FUNDING TOOLS.
BUT THEY NEED TO BE FUNDED.
SO I THINK SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES -- AT MIL MELINDA
MENTION THE TWO EIGHTEEN
ELECTION PROCESS RATE THAT
CREATES A CHALLENGE -- IN.
IN BRINGING IN THE ASSESSMENTS
AND ESPECIALLY IN OVERLAPPING
DISTRICTS SO I MENTIONED THAT
I'M DEPUTY MANAGER FOR THREE
DISTRICTS WILL LOT OF THOSE
LANDOWNERS OF THE SAME.
SO THEY HAVE OVERLAPPING
ASSESSMENTS FOR LEVY MAINTENANCE --
ON TOP OF THAT YOU'VE -- WE'VE
ADDED THE CIGNA THE GROUND WATER.
ACT WHICH IS IT ANOTHER
ASSESSMENT THAT'S GOING TO BE
LAID UPON.
THE SAME LANDOWNERS AND THEN
WE'VE -- THIS IS A REALLY FUN
PROTECTION BOARD IS LOOKING AT
THE SACRAMENTO SEEM LOOKING
DRAINAGE DISTRICT WHICH IS
POTENTIALLY ANOTHER ASSESSMENT.
SO IS IS ALL OF THESE
ASSESSMENTS GET BUILT ON EACH
OTHER IT BECOMES LESS AND LESS --
IT WERE LESS ABLE TO GENERATE
LOCAL DOLLARS BECAUSE THEY THEY
JUST.
THERE SOME YOU MIGHT THEY CAN
VOTE NO.
RIGHT.
AND SO THAT'S THAT'S REALLY
DIFFICULT. TO TO BE ABLE TO GET
YOUR ASSESSMENT THROUGH AND IN
SOME AREAS -- REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS I MEAN REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS ARE SIGNIFICANT
COST AND SO FOR FOR A LOT OF THE
COSTS AND WITH REGULATORY --
ELEMENTS IS IS A DOLLAR LESS IN
IN MAINTENANCE AND WE'RE SEEING
IN SOME OF WE'RE YOU KNOW WE'RE
FOCUSING A LOT ON TIGHT.
REPLACEMENTS AND PIPE PICTURE A
BIG RESTORE LEVEES THEIR OLD
RIGHT NOW THE SYSTEM IS OLD --
THERE ARE SOME TYPES THAT YOU
THE ONLY WAY TO REMEDY IS TO
TAKE THEM OUT AND THE COST OF
DOING ALL OF THE PERMITTING.
EQUALS THE COST OF REPLACING THE
PIE.
AND SO IT IT THOSE CHALLENGES
JUST MAKE IT HARD FOR A LOCAL
DISTRICT TO EFFICIENTLY.
OPERATE AND MAINTAIN -- THEIR
SYSTEM.
SO AT SOME POINT WILL BE ASKED
TO CONSIDER ANOTHER WATER BOND
INFRASTRUCTURE RIGHT.
AT SOME POINT.
IF YOU WERE WRITING IT BUT WHAT
WOULD THOSE MAYBE TOP.
THREE CRITERIAS LOOK LIKE -- NOT
CONSIDERING THAT YOU PROBABLY
WOULD SAY I WANT TO DIRECT ON
OCCASION.
TO THESE DISTRICTS RIGHT BUT
WHAT WOULD BE KIND OF THE TO BE.
TOP CRITERIAS THAT YOU FEEL
WOULD ALLOW DISTRICTS LIKE YOURS
TO TO COMPETE WELL RIGHT TO FOR
OFF.
WELL IT WITHIN THE A DISTRICTS
OF SIMILAR YOU KNOW NATURE SO.
TO HEAR THAT YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THAT -- SO.
AT THE DISTRICTS HERE EVERY
DISTRICTS IN A LITTLE DIFFERENT
FINANCIAL SITUATION I THINK WE
NEED -- TO WE NEED TO POSITION
OURSELVES BETTER TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES
THAT COME -- YOU KNOW I'M WE
DON'T DO A LOT OF PREPARING WE
KNOW WHAT OUR DAMAGE STAR ARE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE SITE SORRY
WE KNOW WHAT'S OUT THERE.
AND IF WE HAD -- THE ABILITY TO
ACCESS STATE FUNDS NOW TO BE
ABLE TO PREPARE AND PERMIT AND
IN DESIGN A LOT OF THOSE THINGS
WHEN ALL OF THESE OPPORTUNITIES
COME UP.
YOU CAN JUMP ON IT -- THE FEMALE
HAS THE HAZARD MITIGATION GRANT
PROGRAM THAT YOU KNOW FOR EVERY
DOLLAR THEY ISSUE IN -- PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE THE STATE GETS A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF MONEY BACK
THAT WE CAN DO MITIGATION.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE APPLIED FOR ONE
OF THOSE ACTUALLY GOT IT WE WE
WERE TOLD WE WERE.
GOING TO BE ABLE TO GET IT WE WE
TRIED WE HAD TO DECLINE BECAUSE
WE ARE THE PROJECTS WE THINK
WE'RE GONNA GET IT -- BUT IT
SHOWED THAT WE CAN.
AS LONG AS WE'RE PREPARED.
AND SO IF WE CAN PREPARE IF WE
CAN POSITION OURSELVES AND BE
BETTER STRATEGICALLY PLACED TO
ACCESS ALL OF THOSE GRANTS WE
CAN BETTER LEVERAGE BOTH STATE
AND FEDERAL MONEY.
I'M I ANSWERED A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY SO WHAT.
MY MEMBERS WOULD SAY WE WERE
PRIDE GO BACK TO THE WORDING
THAT WAS IN THE FLOOD ONLY BOMB
THE PROP.
ONE EIGHTY BECAUSE IT HAD THE
TYPES OF CATEGORIES OF THE TYPES
OF THINGS THAT YOU WOULD WANT.
TO YOU KNOW SPEND THE MONEY ON
AND WHEN WE LOOK BACK YOU KNOW
WHAT WAS ACCOMPLISHED WITH THAT
ONE ANY YOU KNOW IT'S A LOT
THESE NEWER BONDS ARE.
HAVING DIFFERENT LANGUAGE AND
KIND OF GOT AWAY FROM SOME OF
THOSE CATEGORIES -- SO WE WOULD
RECOMMEND REALLY LOOKING BACK AT
THAT LANGUAGE.
YEAH I THINK A LOT OF THE NEWER
BONDS HAVE BEEN ALL MULTI
BENEFIT.
AND WHAT IN.
OUR DISTRICT IS MULTI BENEFIT
PROJECTS SO THOSE ARE GREAT BUT
NOT EVERYTHING CAN BE SOMETIMES
WE JUST HAVE FLOOD RISK
REDUCTION PROJECTS THAT NEED TO
BE DONE -- BUT AND THAT'S WHY I
SAY THERE IS CATEGORIES THAT
INCLUDED THE SYSTEM THAT THE
STATE NEEDS TO WORRY ABOUT THEIR
BY PASSES AND SUCH [inaudible]
RESPOND.
TO HERE IS H. U. EVALUATE --
FLOOD RISK AND MITIGATION.
ON FOOT PRESQUE. TWO CAN CIRCLE
BACK TO SOME OF THE COMMENTS I
GAVE YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
MY CONTINUE FRUSTRATION THERE
WATER POLICIES JUST TOTAL LACK
OF COLLABORATION AND A TOTAL --
LACK OF UNDERSTAND THAT.
YOU KNOW THE RIGHT HAND LEFT AND
NEED TO BE DOING THE TO BE
COORDINATED.
AND GIVEN EXAMPLE.
WE PASSED THE GROUND WATER
SUSTAINABILITY ACT.
LEGISLATURE DRESS THE THE CRISIS
FOLLOWING YOU KNOW EXTENDED
PERIOD DROUGHT THAT WE HAD
COLLAPSING AQUIFER'S THROUGHOUT
CENTER I THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND IN THAT VERY LEGISLATION WE
PROHIBITED -- RECHARGE OF GROUND
WATER AS A BENEFICIAL USE FOR
DISTRICTS ACTUALLY PUT WATER --
INTO THE GROUND OBVIOUSLY THAT
DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE -- NOW
THERE'S A LOT OF POLITICS BEHIND
THAT POLICIES ARE HAS TO DO WITH
URBAN AREAS WANT THEIR CAKE AND
EAT IT TOO AS FAR AS GETTING
THEIR WATER DOWN. TO THE URBAN
AREAS AND IF YOU GOT A BUNCH OF
RURAL.
DISTRICTS PUTTING WATER INTO THE
GROUND IT'S NOT MOVING -- SOUTH
SO THERE'S REASONS FOR THOSE
DECISIONS BUT THEY'RE OBVIOUSLY
SOMEWHAT HYPOCRITICAL
INCONSISTENT BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY TO ME FLOOD RISK AND
WATER SUPPLY ART.
DISCONNECTED RIGHT AND WHAT'S
INTERESTING BOTH IN THE PANEL
THAT WE HAD BEFORE THIS PANEL
AND IN DURING THIS PANEL IS.
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF THERE'S
TALK ABOUT COLLABORATION BUT I'M
NOT SURE WE'VE GOT SHARED GOALS.
IF THAT MAKES SENSE AND AND I
KIND OF WONDER HOW.
HOW COULD WE TAKE THOSE OTHER
CONSIDERATIONS INTO AFFECTS THE
WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT FLOOD
RISK AND I WAS LOOKING FOR
EXAMPLE TO LA OWES?
HAND OUT -- FROM EARLIER TALKS
ABOUT YOU KNOW FLOOD RISK IN A
IT BREAKS DOWN OR YOU KNOW
NUMBER OF RESIDENTS NUMBER OF
STRUCTURES CROP VALUE.
RIGHT.
WELL IF YOU TAKE THE SACRAMENTO
RIVER THE SAN JOAQUIN AND TULARE
LAKE JUST JUST THOSE.
THREE YOU'VE GOT A COLLECTIVE
CROP VALUE OF ALMOST SIX BILLION
DOLLARS.
THE ENTIRETY OF THE REST THE
STATE HAS A CROP VALUE OF ONE
POINT.
FIVE RIGHT -- SO WE'RE TALK
ABOUT CROP VALUE. EIGHT AND OF
COURSE FOOD SUPPLY AND WHAT THAT
MEANS LONG TERM -- AND THAT'S
ALSO A SAFETY AND SECURITY ISSUE --
THAT'S ARE WE TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION NECESSARILY IT
SOUNDS LIKE IT SO I GUESS HOW DO
WE WHAT CAN WE DO AS A
LEGISLATURE TO ASSIST.
YOU TO ASSIST YOU HAVE YOU ARE
TO ASSIST.
YOU KNOW THE WATER COMMISSION I
MEAN EVEN THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
A WATER BORDER WATER COMMISSION
D. W. R. FLOOD CONTROL AND
EVERYTHING'S IN A DIFFERENT
PLACE RIGHT SO.
FROM THE LAY PERSON'S
PERSPECTIVE THE LEGISLATIVE
PERSPECTIVE IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
TO SYSTEMS EVEN SET UP FOR A LOT
OF COLLABORATION SO IT SEEMS
LIKE THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO DO
I REALIZE THAT WAS ALL ALARM.
QUESTION WITH A LOT TO UNPACK
BUT I HAVE THE SAME THOUGHTS ALL
THE TIME AND THE REASON IS THE
OTHER HAT THAT I WEAR IS I'M
ALSO THE MANAGER OF THE NORTH.
DELTA WATER AGENCIES SO WE DEAL
WITH WATER SUPPLY ISSUES AND SO
I GO TO MEETINGS FOR ABOUT FIVE
MEANT WATER SUPPLY TAKE MEETINGS
AND MATT FLED.
AND AND I USED TO WORK RESOURCES
AGENCY AND I'M LIKE YOU I JUST
KEEP IN MY MIND I KEEP THINKING
WHY ARE WE MAKING THESE
SYNERGIZE TOGETHER BECAUSE THERE
CAN BE COMPLETELY COMPLEMENTARY.
AND IN SOME RESPECTS WE DO
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THE REST
RESERVOIRS PROVIDE BOTH FLOOD
CONTROL AND WATER SUPPLY BUT YOU
KNOW YOU LOOK AT DID OF YOU ARE
THEY DO HAVE TO THE DEPUTY
DIRECTORS YOU KNOW ONES WATER
SUPPLY AND YOU NO ONE'S GOT ALL
THE OTHER INTEGRATED MANAGEMENT
WHICH I THINK.
INCLUDES YOU KNOW FLOOD CONTROL --
AND SO I YOU KNOW I THINK.
I I THOUGHT BY WHERE STRUGGLE
WITH WHAT YOU BROUGHT UP IS I
AGREE WITH EVERYTHING HE SAID I
THINK ABOUT IT ALL THE TIME AND
I THINK THE DEPARTMENT WOULD AT
LEAST ACKNOWLEDGE.
YOU CAN ALWAYS IMPROVE YOUR
COORDINATION INTERNALLY YOU KNOW
AND FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO THESE I
THINK LIKE ANYONE WERE WE GET
CAUGHT UP AND WE GET STUCK ON
HAVING TO RESPOND. TO THE
EMERGENCIES OUR WATER SUPPLY
SIDE THE DROUGHTS COME IN NO
CENTERS OUT DROP CAM I GUARANTEE
YOU WHAT COMES RIGHT AFTERWARDS
AS THE FLOOD.
YOU KNOW AND SO AS A DEPARTMENT
WE SEE THAT THE INTERNALLY THEIR
STAFF.
THAT MIGHT EVEN WORKING FLOOD
OPERATIONS HAS TO GO WORK ON
SOME DROUGHT STUFF FOR A FEW
YEARS AND THE ONE THAT'S OVER
THE FLOOD DOES COME NOW PEOPLE
CHANGE.
AND SO WERE OFTEN REACTING AND
NOT HAVING I THINK AS MUCH TIME
AND ABILITY TO YOU KNOW FOCUS ON
THE OKAY NOW WE HAVE WHAT WE
HAVE HOW DO WE REALLY START
MAKING IT WORK TOGETHER.
I DO THINK THAT'S PART OF THEIR
INTEGRATED MANAGEMENT IF YOU
WILL IT IS ON THEIR MIND AS PART
OF THEIR WATER PLAN THEY THEY
CERTAINLY ACKNOWLEDGE IT
UNDERSTAND IT -- THEY THERE YET
NO I WOULD I WOULD WHAT I WISH I
HAD IS THAT WHERE YOU GOT AT THE
END WHICH IS WHAT WAS MY
RECOMMENDATION. TO ME TO YOU ON
WHAT DID WE ARE COULD OR SHOULD
DO.
THAT'S THE PART MAYBE I STRUGGLE
WITH A LITTLE BIT MAYBE MAYBE
LESS.
HAVE THE ANSWER.
YOU DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE THE
ANSWER BUT I CAN TELL YOU WHAT.
OUR BOARD PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
SAYING TO EVERYONE -- AND WHICH
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE IS THAT
BUILDING ON THE SUCCESSES THAT
YOU ALREADY HAVE SO WE HAVE THIS
MANDATE NOW TO DO THESE MORE
INTEGRATION AND MORE RATE ADDING
MORE RESILIENCE I'M LOOKING MORE
AT HABITAT THINGS THAT WE HADN'T
DONE IN THE PAST.
WELL WE'VE GOT TEN YEARS OF
PLANNING EXTENSIVE PLANNING LOTS
OF FUNDING THAT'S GONE INTO THIS
AND WE HAVE A REALLY GOOD PLAN
THAT ALREADY WORKS SO WORK FROM
THERE AND EXPAND THAT OUT.
WE CAN ADD IN THE FLOOD MAR WE
CAN ADD IN THE GROUND WATER
SUSTAINABILITY ACT TO WHAT WE
ALREADY HAVE AND SEE WHERE THE
GAPS ARE AND WORK ON FILLING IN
FROM THAT DIRECTION RATHER THAN
TRYING TO START ALL OVER AGAIN
WITH THE HOLISTIC PLAN AND WORK
DOWN SO -- THAT'S CERTAINLY A
STRATEGY THAT I THINKCAN WORK --
I WOULD HOPE THAT PEOPLE WOULD
CONSIDER THAT WHO HAVE THE
ABILITY AND AUTHORITY OUTSIDE OF
THE FLOOD WORLD SO.
THAT'S ONE OF OUR CONSTRAINTS IS
THAT WE HAVE A JURISDICTION IN A
MANDATE THAT INCLUDES -- THE
FLOOD WORLD SO IT'S IT'S NOT UP
TO THE BOARD TO GO OUT AND LOOK
AT GROUND WATER AND OTHER THINGS
EXCEPT WHERE THOSE NEXUS ARE SO.
SO -- THE POWERS THAT BE BEING
ABLE TO DO THAT AND PERHAPS YOU
HAVE SOME -- INFLUENCE AND IT'S
ALREADY IN THAT AREA I WOULD I
WOULD SAY THAT'S A GOOD PLACE TO
START.
I WOULD.
CHOOSE A LITTLE BIT TO SAY WHAT
WHAT WHY SEE THE BENEFIT OF NOT
REINVENTING THE WHEEL.
IN EXISTING.
DIRECTIONS AND PLANS.
YEAH WE TALK ABOUT CALIFORNIA
WATER PLAN HALF AND ASK PEOPLE
ACTUALLY READ IT.
AND TELL ME WHERE THE PLAN PART
IS.
BECAUSE IS GIVING SAMPLE I'M
FORTY ONE YEARS OLD AND IN MY
LIFETIME THE POPULATION
CALIFORNIA'S ALMOST DOUBLED.
OUR WATER SUPPLY HAS INCREASED
THE STATE AND FEDERAL INVESTMENT
WASH WAS INCREASED BY ABOUT 1%.
WHEN YOU DOUBLE THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE?
AND YOU INCREASE YOU WASH BY BY
1%.
IT SHOULDN'T BE REAL HARD TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT'S PROMISE RIGHT.
AND UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE WE
OPERATE IN SILOS FUND MANAGEMENT
VERSES WATER QUALITY VERSUS ACTS --
I THINK WE'RE MISSING OUT ON
OPPORTUNITIES UP TO SAY GO ABOVE
AND BEYOND EVEN JUST -- WATER
RIGHT -- THE CONTRIBUTIONS THAT
HYDRO MAKES TOWARDS REAL WINNER
SHE IN THE SERIOUS THREAT OF
CLIMATE CHANGE IS A MAJOR
SUBJECT -- THE GETS LOST IN THIS
IN THIS SAME WASH RIGHT SO WE
COULD BE SOLVING MULTIPLE
PROBLEMS -- BY MAKING SOME THESE
INVESTMENTS AND AND CREATED
GREATER COLLABORATION -- AND BY
ALLOWING PEOPLE TO OPERATE IN
SILOS IN VARIOUS AGENCIES AND
NOT NECESSARILY COLLABORATE
COMMUNICATE -- I THINK WE'RE
MISSING A WHOLE LOT OF REALLY
GREAT OPPORTUNITIES I THINK IT
IS HAPPENING LOCALLY A LITTLE
BIT YOU KNOW I THINK LESLIE
BROUGHT UP IN HER COMMENTS
EARLIER.
OF THE RECOGNITION NOW THAT THE
STORM WATER CAPTURE YOU KNOW AND
BECAUSE OF TECHNOLOGIES THAT WE
HAVE OF WE CAN RE USE THAT WATER
AND YOU KNOW THINGS ARE RECHARGE
AND SO I KNOW AT LEAST LOCALLY
THEY'RE STARTING TO DO THAT YOU
KNOW WHETHER WE'VE GOT A HANDLE
ON IT.
IN THE BIGGER SENSE LIKE YOU'RE
ASKING YOU KNOW THAT'S WERE
DEFINITELY I THINK IMPROVEMENT
COULD OCCUR.
THE GOOD NEWS IS WITH THE AS I
SAID EARLIER THE GOVERNOR'S
ISSUED EXECUTIVE ORDER -- SEEMS
TO BE PUSHING OUT LOOKING FOR
THE KIND OF COLLABORATION --
THAT I'M SPEAKING OF SO I'VE GOT
ONE FEELING AT THE MOMENT
SOMEWHAT OPTIMISTIC ABOUT.
THE TEAM UP HERE IN SACRAMENTO
AND THE INTEREST IN AT LEAST --
IDENTIFYING YOU KNOW THESE
PATHWAYS TO COLLABORATE
OCCURRING AND REALLY HAVE A A
STRONG WATER PLAN FOR THE NEXT
FIFTY YEARS.
I AM HOPEFUL.
TO AT THINK -- TO THE THE
REASONS THAT I MENTIONED THE THE
FLOOD MANAGEMENT REGION'S AT
LEAST UP IN OUR AREA YOU KNOW
THOSE DO THE STAKEHOLDERS THAT
ARE INVOLVED IN THAT -- WHILE
THE FOCUS MAY BE FLOOD ARE ALSO
WATER SUPPLY FOLKS MAY NOT WE
HAVE A WATER SUPPLY MISSION IN
OUR DISTRICT -- AND THE THE
COUNTIES IN OTHER FOLKS THAT ARE
INVOLVED IN THAT SO WILD WHILE
IT MIGHT NOT BE DIRECT.
THERE IS ALWAYS A WATER SUPPLY
THOUGHT IN THE BACK OF MOST OF
THOSE FOLKS MIND AS WE AS WE
PLAN AND SO I YOU KNOW I'M I'M
LESS AWARE OF SOME OF THE OTHER
REGIONS AND AND IF THE
STAKEHOLDERS ARE -- IS MIX OF I
THINK I WERE ONLY ONE OF FOR
RECLAMATION DISTRICTS THAT HAS
WATER SUPPLY MISSION SO MOST
RECLAMATIONS ACTUALLY DON'T.
HAVE A WATER SUPPLY MISSION --
BUT WE'RE LUCKY IN THAT WE DO
AND IT DOES IT IT DOESN'T ALLOW
US TO KIND OF THINK A LITTLE BIT
MORE BROADLY ABOUT ALL.
GROUNDWATER AND SURFACE WATER
AND FLOOD IN AND ALL OF THOSE
COMBINED.
OKAY REALLY DIGITAL QUESTIONS
ARE FOR THE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS PRECIADO YOUR
PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S HEARING.
AT THIS TIME MEMBERS WERE GONNA
MOVE TO OUR FINAL PANEL
[inaudible]
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS.
AND WE HAVE -- THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF PLANNING PATTERSON
PREVENTION CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES AS
WELL AS THE CHIEF OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES -- OFFICER FROM
SACRAMENTO COUNTY SO WELCOME --
PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELVES AND
PROCEED WITH YOUR TESTIMONY.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRS MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE HI MY NAME IS TINA
CURRY AND ONE OF THE DEPUTY
DIRECTORS AT CALLOW YES AND I
OVERSEE PLANNING AND
PREPAREDNESS -- IT'S A PLEASURE
TO BE HERE AT TO TALK TO YOU A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS -- ANGLE OF THIS OF
THIS TOPIC AND TO BE HERE WITH --
ONE OF OUR COUNTIES -- WHICH IS
A BIG ROLE IN THE STATE I'LL
START WITH IN IN A MERCY
PREPAREDNESS IS TO SUPPORT.
THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA AND BY EXTENSION THE
COMMUNITIES WITHIN THAT IN ALL
ASPECTS OF EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS IN ALL THE HAZARDS
THAT WE FACE -- FLOOD IS
DEFINITELY -- ONE THAT
HISTORICALLY -- AS WE'VE HEARD
THROUGHOUT THE DAY HAS BEEN ONE
OF THE MOST FREQUENT IT'S
AFFECTED EVERY COUNTY IN SOME
WAY -- OVER HISTORY AND IS
RESULTED IN A LOT OF LOSSES AND
CERTAINLY -- A LOT OF STE --
MERGES YOU DECLARATIONS AND AND
RESPONSES I'M SO IT'S IT'S
CRITICAL FOR US TO BE READY FOR
THAT.
AND I'LL JUST SPEAK VERY BRIEFLY
ABOUT SORT OF HOW WE FRAMERS HE
PREFERS A CALIFORNIANS SPECIFIC
TO FLAT AND CERTAINLY WANT TO
GET TO YOUR QUESTIONS FIRST AND
FOREMOST AS WELL AS MY CO
PANELIST HERE.
SO PLAN PREPAREDNESS FOR AS FAR
AS WE LOOK AT THAT AND EMERGENCY
SERVICES SPANS A LOT OF THINGS
PART OF THAT IS PLANNING.
ON HAVING EMERGENCY PLANS SO
THAT WERE READY AND UNDERSTAND --
WHAT ROLES RESPONSIBILITIES ARE
AND WHAT TYPE OF RESPONSE WE
MIGHT NEED TO UNDERTAKE TO SAVE
LIVES AND PROTECT PROPERTY BUT
ALSO INCLUDES THINGS LIKE
TRAINING AND EXERCISES?
INCLUDES RISK REDUCTION IT'S ALL
THOSE THINGS TO GET READY FOR
EMERGENCIES SO THEY ARE LESS
IMPACTFUL -- FOR ON THE PLANNING
SIDE WE HAVE A STATE EMERGENCY
PLAN THAT ARTICULATES OUR SYSTEM
RESPONSE THINGS LIKE MUTUAL AID
HOW RESOURCES MOVE AROUND THE
STATE TO DEAL WITH MULTIPLE
HAZARDS.
AND WE'VE ALSO -- DONE A NUMBER
OF WHAT WE CALL CATASTROPHIC
SCENARIO PLANS FOR EARTHQUAKE --
AND ALSO FOR FLOOD HAZARDS HOW
WOULD A VERY AND LARGE FLOOD
EMERGENCY.
THAT AFFECTS A LARGE SWATH OF
THE STATE HOW THE STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT COME TOGETHER
TO RESPOND TO THAT AT TO
SUPPORTER COUNTY SO IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO EXAMINE THE
SCENARIOS.
SO THE CAN REALLY LOOK AT
SOMETHING THAT EITHER WE HAVEN'T
FACED IN A LONG TIME OR THAT WE
HAVEN'T FACED AT ALL.
UNDERSTAND HOW WE MIGHT HAVE --
TO COME TOGETHER TO RESPOND TO
THAT EFFECTIVELY -- IN TERMS OF
PLANNING WE ALSO HAVE A NEW ROLE
AT CALLAWAY YES THE RESULT OF
THE OROVILLE EVENT AND THAT IS
TO OVERSEE THE EMERGENCY ACTION
PLANS BY ALL THE REGULATED.
DAM OWNERS IN CALIFORNIA SO
THAT'S A VERY DIRECT -- ROLE
THAT SOUNDS THAT WERE WORKING
WITH THOSE OWNERS AND BY
EXTENSION THE COMMUNITIES WHERE
THOSE DAM -- INUNDATIONS MIGHT
IMPACT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU KNOW WHERE
WE'RE AT DAM ISSUE IF THERE WERE
TO BE A PROBLEM OR FAILURE HOW
THAT WOULD AFFECT THE
COMMUNITIES DOWNSTREAM.
HOW THEY WOULD NOTIFY -- PEOPLE
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY WHAT'S
OUR SYSTEM OF OF EVALUATING DAMS
CONSTANTLY TO UNDERSTAND -- THAT
WHAT YOU KNOW WHETHER THEY'RE
SAFER WHETHER THERE'S A PROBLEM
EMERGING AND THEN TAKING THOSE
PLANS AND WORKING WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ARE THEN PART OF THE FABRIC
OF THEIR EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
PLAN AND THE PUBLIC UNDERSTANDS --
DAM SAFETY SO THAT'S A LITTLE
BIT NEWER TO AS I WANTED TO
MENTION THAT. FOR TRAINING AND
EXERCISES WE HAVE A A PROGRAM TO
HELP EMERGENCY PERSONNEL --
ACROSS THE STATE THOSE DOES
CHANGE SOMETIMES SO WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
FRESHEN UNDERSTAND HOW EMERGENCY
RESPONSE WORKS IT'S A LITTLE BIT
OF A SPECIALTY AREA SO THERE'S
DIFFERENT POSITIONS THAT --
THERE ARE INVOLVED IN AND THEY
NEED TO BE READY -- AGAIN WE AT
THE STATE ARE PREPARED TO
SUPPORT COMMUNITIES INTO SEARCH
THEIR CAPACITY MOVE RESOURCES
AROUND THE STATE TO HELP ANOTHER
THAT'S HAPPENED A LOT IN THE
FIRES -- RECENTLY AND IT'S
HAPPENED A LOT AND OTHER HAZARDS
WE'VE HAD.
CAN FINALLY I MENTION ANOTHER
PLAN THAT WE HAVE IT'S IMPORTANT
IT'S CALLED THE STATE MITIGATION
PLAN -- THAT IS ONE THAT
ARTICULATES THE STATE'S
COMMITMENT TO RISK REDUCTION AND
INCORPORATES ALL THE STUFF WE
TALKED ABOUT AND FLOOD
MANAGEMENT BUT ALSO FIRE.
EARTHQUAKE AND THE DIFFERENT
HAZARDS WE FACE AS WELL AS WHAT
WE'RE DOING TOWARDS BUYING DOWN
AT RISK AND LAYERED ON TOP OF
THAT HOW CALIFORNIA'S CHANGING.
CLIMATE INCREASED POPULATION ALL
THE DIFFERENT THINGS THAT HAVE
BEEN MENTIONED TODAY NEED TO BE
KIND OF RE RE -- LOOKED AT BY
CALLAWAY YES OVER TIME SO THE
UNDERSTAND THE RISK IS CHANGING
ALL THE TIME IT'S NOT --
NECESSARY TOOK IN OUR HISTORY
FOR THE TYPE TO HAVE THREE PHASE
BUT THEN L<c.cyan>G THAT OVER HOW</c>
CALIFORNIA ITSELF IS CHANGING
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
CONSTANTLY RESETTING -- WHAT
THAT COMMITMENT TO RISK
REDUCTION IS -- SO THAT WAS JUST
A VERY BRIEF INTRODUCTION TO
SOME OF THE SOME OF THE PROGRAMS
THAT WE HAVE -- I KNOW THAT YOU
PROBABLY HAVE QUESTIONS FOR ME
ON ON SOME SPECIFICS OF HOW WE
UNDERTAKE RECEIVER FAIRNESS BUT
I WANT.
TO GIVE A CHANCE FOR THE OTHER
PANELISTS -- AND THEN TAKE YOUR
QUESTIONS -- AS YOU WISH OR
RIGHT NOW HOWEVER YOU PREFER.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME HERE
TODAY TO SPEAK AT THIS HEARING --
MY NAME IS STEVE TELL ME I AM
THE CHIEF OF THE SECOND COUNTY
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES --
PRIOR TO COMING TO WORK IN
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT I SPENT
TWENTY YEARS IN THE FIRE SERVICE
RETIRING AS ASSISTANT CHIEF.
AND I SPENT ABOUT THE LAST NINE
YEARS WORKING FOR YOU SEE
MEASURE FOR EITHER -- YOLO
COUNTY SECOND OF COUNTY OR CITY
SACRAMENTO -- WELL SITTING IN
THE IN THE AUDIENCE HERE LISTEN
TO THE PANEL TO THE COMMITTEE I
WAS THINKING TO MYSELF.
YOU KNOW IT'S UNUSUAL FOR ME TO
BE SITTING IN A ROOM FULL OF A
LOT OF PEOPLE THAT ARE KIND OF
LIKE MINDED -- IT'S REALLY FOR A
REFRESHING TO KNOW THAT THERE
ARE SO MANY PEOPLE THAT ARE
SHOULD FLOOD PROTECTION -- AND I
WANT TO THINK THIS IS THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE INTERESTS AND
THE SUPPORT THEY'VE GIVEN TO
TRYING TO IMPROVE -- FLOOD
PROTECTION -- NOT JUST IN SECOND
COUNTY BUT THROUGHOUT THIS --
THE SEGMENT ON THE SAN JOAQUIN
OUR REGION -- MOST OF THE PANEL
MEMBERS -- HAVE ALREADY SPOKEN A
LOT ABOUT -- FLOOD MANAGEMENT
AND THE THE CONCERNS THAT THEY
HAVE IN THE THINGS THAT THEY
WOULD LIKE TO SEE TO IMPROVE --
FLOOD MANAGEMENT HERE -- I'M
KIND OF COMING FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF THE LOCAL --
EMERGENCY MANAGER SO I SHARE A
LOT OF THOSE CONCERNS AND I
SHARE THE THAN AND EMBRACED IN
SUPPORT A LOT OF THE THINGS THAT
THEY TALKED ABOUT HERE TODAY --
FROM A LOCAL MANAGERS
PERSPECTIVE THOUGH I WOULD SAY
THAT -- IN. TO TO KIND OF
RESPONSE SOME OF THE THINGS I'VE
HEARD TODAY -- I'VE BEEN DOING
THIS FOR ABOUT THIRTY YEARS
INVOLVED IN -- EMERGENCY TYPE OF
WORK AND I HAVE BEEN INVOLVED
SINCE EIGHTY SIX INTO THE IN THE
FLOOD SO FOR ME SIX ALL THE WAY
TILL TODAY.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THERE'S BEEN
A HUGE -- IMPROVEMENT IN TERMS
OF COOPERATION COORDINATION THAT
GOES ON IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT
STATE AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT --
IS STILL HAS A LONG WAY TO GO
DON'T YOU KNOW IT'S GOVERNMENT
SO IT DOESN'T NOTHING HAPPENS
QUICKLY -- BUT I WILL TELL YOU
IS IS GOOD IS A VAST IMPROVEMENT
THERE WAS WHEN I STARTED IN
MARIN CITY MANAGEMENT.
AND FAR SERVICE -- WITH THE
LOCAL LEVEL WE HAVE TO
COORDINATE AND COLLABORATE WITH
PARTNERS.
AND TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE --
ADEQUATE PROTECTION FOR THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE SERVE -- WE
WORK CLOSELY WITH OUR LOCAL --
GOVERNMENTS FROM THE RECLAMATION
DISTRICTS OF THE CITY IS --
SPECIAL DISTRICTS -- AND THEN WE
WORK.
IT IN PARTICULAR WITH THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITHCALLAWAY US AND
CALIFORNIA D. W. R. -- IS THERE
SUPPORT THAT HELPS US MAKE --
WHAT WE DO SO SUCCESSFUL?
THE THE COUNTIES AND I'M
SPECIFIC TIME A SECOND ROUND OF
THE OTHER COUNTIES AS WELL HAVE --
HUGE RESPONSIBILITIES TO PRY
PROTECTION -- TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND WITHOUT.
THE WORK OF THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
THE WORK OF THE PARTNERS THAT WE
WORK WITH AS WELL AS THE STATE
AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE COULD
NOT DO WHAT WE DO TODAY --
HAVING SAID THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
JUST KIND OF BRIEFLY TALK ABOUT
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT WERE
BROUGHT UP TODAY AND HOW WE
WOULD -- OUR SUPPORT OF IT WE DO
COLLABORATE WORK CLOSELY WITH
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT -- IN THE
STATE -- THE STATE PROVIDES A
LOT OF THE TECHNICAL SPECIALISTS
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE AN ARMORED
SEE OPERATION CENTERS WHENEVER
WE HAVE A DISASTER OR ARE LARGE
INCIDENT -- STATE E. W. R. HAS
PROVIDED US WITH A LOT OF
FUNDING -- TO HELP US TO
MITIGATE SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
WE HAVEN'T PREPARE OUR
COMMUNITIES -- FOR FACING A
FLOOD EVENT -- I KNOW JOHN PASHA
EARLIER AND MENTION THE FACT
THAT -- HE HE COR COOPERATION
COORDINATES WITH THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT HE IS -- HIS OFFICE AND IN
DOING RECENTLY IS WORKING WITH
US TO PROVIDE A LOT OF THE FLOOD
PROTECTION EQUIPMENT AND
SUPPLIES THAT ARE NEEDED DURING
AN EVENT WE'RE TAKING THESE
THINGS -- PURCHASING IT THROUGH
GRANT FUNDING AND WE'RE TAKING
THESE THINGS AND WERE
STRATEGICALLY LOCATING THEM
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY ESPECIALLY
IN THE IN THE DELTA AREA.
AND MAKE IT AVAILABLE TO ALL THE
GOVERNMENT SO THEY CAN -- USE
THAT EQUIPMENT AND THE SUPPLIES
IN THE FLOOD -- EMERGENCY SO --
THAT'S JUST ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE WORK CLOSELY WITH --
COUNTY HAVE YOU ARE ON WE ALSO
WORK WITH ANOTHER THINGS LIKE --
SUFFER PROGRAMS -- TELLS MODEL
EVENTS -- WE WORK WITH THEM ON
ONE SOFTWARE MET A MOLLY THAT
THEY'LL HELP US US IF WE FIND --
AREAS WITHIN OUR OUR LEVEES THAT
NEED TO BE -- ADDRESS WE CAN
SIMULATE A FAILURE AT THAT LEVEL
IT WITH LEVY AND WE CAN ACTUALLY
MODEL WHERE THE WATER WILL GO AT
THE RATE OF THE SPEED OF THE
SPREAD.
THE DEPTH OF WHAT CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IS IS IN THIS WAY
SO THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THAT --
WE DO IN PARTING WITH THE STATE
TO HELP US AND LOCAL LEVEL THE
SAME PROGRAMS OBVIOUSLY HELP THE
STATE AT AT THEIR LEVEL.
SO -- WE'RE ALWAYS LOOKING FOR
OPPORTUNITIES TO PARTNER WITH
THEM -- CALLOW YES -- ANYTIME WE
HAVE AN EVENT WE RELY HEAVILY ON
THEIR FOR ME TOO LATE -- THEY
ALSO PROVIDE US WITH THOSE
TECHNICAL SPECIALIST TO ADDRESS
SPECIFIC NEEDS THAT ARE WITHIN
OUR COUNTY AND A RELATED TO
THOSE DOES THAT ESTHER'S.
SO -- YEAH I I JUST LIKE TO
BEFORE I CLOSE OUT JUST SAY THAT
I DO.
THINK THAT THE SUPPORT FOR THE
RECLAMATION DISTRICT IN THE
FUNDING FOR SOME OF THESE
PROGRAMS IS IS VERY IMPORTANT --
AS YOU KNOW THE THERE IS A HUGE
AMOUNT LEVEES -- THAT ARE
IMPACTED SO I CAN THE SECOND
AREA AND THESE ARE ALL OLD
LEVEES AND THEIR FRAGILE AND THE
WHILE THE RECLAMATION DISTRICTS
IN THE ONLY A IS -- DO A LOT OF
WORK IN TRYING TO MAINTAIN THOSE
THINGS IT TAKES A LOT OF MONEY
AND A LOT OF EFFORT A LOT OF
RESOURCES TO DO THAT SO --
OBVIOUSLY IF THEY IF THEY
MAINTAIN THEIR LEVEES AND THOSE
LIKE IS A STRENGTH AND THEN THAT
HELPS ME IN DOING MY JOB SO I'M
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THAT -- AND
I'M ALSO SUPPORT OF OF SOME OF
pTHE FUNDING THAT THEY'VE TALKED
ABOUT LIKE PROP -- EIGHTY FOUR
ONE WHEN THE THOSE THINGS ARE
ALL VERY IMPORTANT -- TO
CONTRIBUTING TO THE RESILIENCY
AND THE PREPAREDNESS FOR A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
SO WITH THAT I DON'T TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE.
FOR QUESTIONS -- OUTSIDE OF A
CATASTROPHIC.
A RESPONSE PLAN HOW MANY OTHER
TYPES OF CATASTROPHIC.
PLANS DO WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA
WE'VE SO FAR WE'VE COMPLETED --
PLANS FOR THE THE HIGH HAZARD
EARTHQUAKE AREAS OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BAY AREA AS WELL AS
THE CASCADIA SUBDUCTION ZONE UP
IN EXTREME NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
IN ADDITION TO THE FLOOD PLAN.
AND THAT'S NOT TO SAY THERE ARE
TO OTHER TYPES OF EVENTS OF
COURSE THAT COULD BE
CATASTROPHIC IN CALIFORNIA.
I'M SORRY.
YEAH RIGHT YES EARTHQUAKES YEAH
AND THEN THE SAID NOR THE IT'S A
CASCADIA UP IN -- DONOR HUMBLE
AREA -- BUT THOSE THOSE GIVE US
A A FRAMEWORK OF WHAT'S
SOMETHING -- WE'RE REALLY KIND
OF A MAXIMUM THE MAXIMUM TYPE OF
EVENT SO IT ALLOWS US TO GET
EVERYBODY TOGETHER TALK ABOUT
ROLES AND RESPONSIBILITIES SOME
OF THE REALITIES OF THE TIMING
ON RESOURCES THAT MIGHT BECOMING
A FAR TO HELP US DEAL WITH
SOMETHING.
REALLY -- REALLY IMPACTFUL IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THE EFFECT OF
THOSE PLANS HAVE REALLY HELPED
US WITH OTHER EVENTS AND I'LL
GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE THE IN THAT
ORVILLE -- DAM EMERGENCY WE
ACTUALLY ACTIVATED FOR THE FIRST
TIME THAT HAVE KIND OF A UNIFIED
COMMAND AT THE AT THE YES LEVEL
WITH THE FEDERAL WITH OUR FELLOW
PARTNERS AND STATE AGENCIES THAT
WE HAD CONTEMPLATED NEEDING FOR
A CATASTROPHIC EARTHQUAKE AND
SOME OF THE OTHER PLANS.
AND THAT INTERNET THAT COMMANDED
CONTROL ENDED UP BEING VERY
USEFUL AND WE'RE ABLE TO TEST
THAT CONCEPT OF HOW WE JOINTLY
PRIORITIZE -- OF RESPONSE AND
RESOURCES REQUEST WITH OUR
FEDERAL PARTNERS SO SO REALLY
THE IDEA IS WE LOOK AT THESE --
MAXIMUM SCENARIOS BUT THE
BENEFITS OF THOSE PLANS HELP US --
WITH EITHER DISASTERS THAT ARE
LESS IMPACTFUL OR OTHER TYPES OF
EVENTS THAT -- IT KIND OF KEEPS
AS PRACTICED IN THAT THAT
DIALOGUE OF HOW WE WOULD
APPROACH.
A BIG EMERGENCY.
THANK YOU MY QUESTION WOULD BE --
AROUND THE ISSUE AND WE TALK A
LOT ABOUT AGENCIES WORKING IN
THEIR OWN.
SILOS.
YOU HAVE TO COORDINATE WITH A
LOT OF PEOPLE AS WELL IN FACT.
IN OF ALL THE WAY DOWN TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT -- TO THE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
WHAT IS YOU KNOW MAYBE THE LAST --
EMERGENCY SITUATION THAT YOU
RESPONDED.
WHAT WHAT IS THAT PROCESS LOOK
LIKE WHAT IS THAT COMMUNICATION
I THINK THE PUBLIC -- SHOULD GET
A BETTER SENSE OF THAT -- LEVEL
OF COMMUNICATION THAT'S
HAPPENING ON REAL TIME AND
REALLY YOU KNOW TO THE POINT
THAT YOUR SCENE THE RESPONSE ON
THE GROUND.
SO MAYBE YOU CAN CONSTRUCT AS TO
WHAT THANK YOU FOR ABSOLUTE SO.
I'M SORRY. TO OFFSET THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS A LOCAL STANDARD
SYSTEM FOR RESPONSE IT WAS A
LESSON WE LEARNED ON BACK IN THE
NINETIES AFTER THE OAKLAND HILLS
FIRE AND THEN SUBSEQUENTLY WAS
TESTED IN.
SOME OF THE EVENTS AND THAT
REALLY -- ORGANIZES EMERGENCY
SERVICES THE SAME WAY AT EVERY
LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT SO --
WHETHER IT'S LOCAL FIELD
RESPONDERS ON THE SCENE AND THEM
PORTENTS OF THAT IS BECAUSE YOU
NEVER KNOW WHO'S GOING TO NEED
TO COME TOGETHER IN AN EVENT AND
SO THEY NEED TO BE.
APPROACHING THE MANAGEMENT OR
MERCY IN A IN A SYSTEMATIC AND
CONSISTENT WAY AND THEN EVERY
LAYER THAT'S RESPONDING NEEDS TO
BE ABLE TO QUICKLY AND
EFFECTIVELY RESPOND TO THOSE WHO
ARE HELPING THEM -- SO IT MAKES
A LOT OF SENSE TO TO KEEP TO
STAND RIGHT AND THAT'S TESTED
ITSELF OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND
AND IN ADVANCE IN FACT THE
NATIONAL GOVERNMENT ADOPTED IT
IN THE MID TWO THOUSANDS -- SO
THAT IS WHAT THAT SERVICE TWO
THINGS PRIMARILY THAT IS AND HOW
TO MOVE RESOURCES SO IF YOU NEED
SOMETHING HAVE YOU ASKED FOR IT
WHO DO YOU ASK.
AND HOW DO WE GET IT BACK DOWN
AND ALSO SERVES AS A WAY TO
PROVIDE SUITABLE BECAUSE
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS SO HOW DO
WE COMMUNICATE -- LOCAL
GOVERNMENT UP TO THE NEXT TO THE
COUNTY UP TO THE STATE BECAUSE
OF THE STATE OR HAVE A VANTAGE
POINT OF MAYBE MULTIPLE COUNTIES
AFFECTED.
IN SO HOWEVER WE SORT OF TAKING
THAT ALL IN AND BEING A FISSION
AND HOW WE PROVIDE INFORMATION
AND RESOURCES BACK OUT.
IT ALSO REQUIRES THAT WE ASK
WHETHER IT'S STATE -- YES SIR
AND COUNTY -- YES HAS TO HAVE
GOOD RELATIONSHIPS WITH
DIFFERENT ENTITIES WITH
DIFFERENT SUB EXPERTISE THAT
MIGHT LEND A HAND IN THAT EVENT
THAT CANNOT COME TOGETHER.
IN YOU KNOW WHEN SOMETHING IS
HAPPEN YOU HAVE TO CULTIVATE
THAT AHEAD OF TIME FOR EXAMPLE
OF AT THE STATE LEVEL WE RELY ON
ALL THE STATE AGENCIES -- TO
HAVE SOME ROLE IN EITHER GETTING
READY FOR EMERGENCY RESPONDING
TO IT -- OVERSEAS DON'T
TYPICALLY PRESENT THEMSELVES
WITH SORT OF ONE TYPE OF FACT
AND WILL DO TO BE YOU ARE IN A
FLOOD EVENT WOULD BE PRIMARY --
FOR FLOOD FIGHT UNDERSTAND THE
WATER SYSTEM WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
SOCIAL IMPACTS -- PEOPLE THAT
NEED SHELTER WE'RE GONNA HAVE
HEALTH IMPACTS AND SO IT'S UP TO
US TO IN LIST AND THE EXPERTISE
OF OUR STATE AGENCIES THAT
OVERSEE THOSE THINGS
TRANSPORTATION -- SECURITY WITH
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT AND BE ABLE
TO DRAW THAT IN.
AND SO THE WAY THAT WE MAINTAIN
THAT IS FIRST OF ALL WE'VE
DEFINED ROLES OF STATE AGENCIES
IN OUR STATE EMERGENCY PLAN SO
WE KNOW WHO IS CAPABLE OF DOING
WHAT AND HOW THAT MIGHT GET
EMPLOYED IN THE DIFFERENT TYPES
OF DISASTERS WE COULD HAVE --
AND THEN WE HAVE TO PRACTICE
THAT WITH THEM SO THAT WE CAN
UNDERSTAND THINGS CHANGE YOU
KNOW HOW HOW ARE WE LOOKING AT
AREABLE TO EMPLOY THAT IN THE
FUTURE.
AS WELL AND THEN -- FINALLY AN
ACTUAL EVENTS THEY COME AND THEY
SAID IN OUR OFFICE AND WE HAVE A
AS STATE EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
CENTER IT'S GOT A SEAT FOR ALL
THAT.
NOT TO STATE PARTNERS BUT THE
BUT THE FEDERAL PARTNERS AS WELL
SO THE WORKING TOGETHER TO SOLVE
PROBLEMS THAT ARE GOING TO HAVE
YOU KNOW ASYMMETRIC EFFECTS AND
KIND OF REQUIRE MULTIPLE
SOLUTIONS.
AND THE SAME TIME WE'RE
CONSTANTLY IN CONTACT WITH OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WHO SIMILAR
HASN'T UC -- IT TO KIND OF LET
US KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING ON THE
GROUND WITH THE SITUATION HOUSE
A CHANGING WHAT DO YOU NEED SO
WE'RE KEEPING THAT REAL TIME.
COMMUNICATION WITH -- WITH OUR
COUNTIES AND BY EXTENSION THE
COMMUNITIES THAT AND KEEPING THE
COMMUNICATION UP TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO COME HELP US
AND THEN ACROSS TO THE STATE
EMERGENCY SO.
IT DOESN'T JUST COME TOGETHER IN
IN A DISASTER WHEN WE ACTIVATE
THE EOC THAT HAS TO BE
RELATIONSHIPS WE ESTABLISH AHEAD
OF TIME SO THEY'RE READY.
FOR THAT RESPONSE SO THAT WE CAN
BE EFFECTIVE.
IF YOU WANT TO COMMENT ON THAT
YEAH I WOULD LIKE TO SAY I I'D
LIKE TO REITERATE WHAT YOU JUST
SAID IT IN THAT -- AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL WE DO THE VERY SAME THING --
FROM OUR OUR PARTNERS THAT ARE
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL THE THE
RECLAMATION DISTRICT THE CITY'S --
AS WELL CITY AND THE STATE AND
THE FEDS -- SO WE'RE COSTLY WORK
WITH INVOLVING THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS WHEN SOMEBODY FROM
OUR OFFICE GOES IN TO MEET WITH
THEM WE TYPICALLY KNOW EACH
OTHER THE SAME VICE VERSA THE
SAME THING THEY COME IN. TO OUR
OFFICE WE TYPICALLY KNOW WHO'S
COMING IN AND WE HAVE A SEAT AT
OUR TABLE ARE YOU'LL SEE -- FOR
A LOT OF PARTNERS -- FROM --
PROBABLY AROUND IT'S A SMALLER --
EOC OBVIOUSLY BUT WE PROBABLY
HAVE ROOM FOR ABOUT A HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE PEOPLE TO COME INTO
OURS OF WHICH PROBABLY AT LEAST
THIRTY OF THEM ARE -- LIAISONS
FROM OTHER AGENCIES.
OKAY THE ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
FROM THE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE THANK OUR PANELISTS
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
TODAY'S HERE.
AND WE'LL LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
YOU AGAIN SO THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME -- MEMBERS WERE GOING TO
OPEN IT UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENT --
THERE'S A MICROPHONE -- IN THE
BACK FOR ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WISH TO MAKE A
STATEMENT OR COMMENT ON TODAY'S
AGENDA.
SEEING NO PUBLIC COMMENT
[inaudible]
THAT CONCLUDES.
TODAY'S INFORMATION HERE I'D
LIKE TO AGAIN EXPRESS MY
GRATITUDE THANK YOU TWO GERMAN
GARCIA.
AND THE WATER PARKS WHILE LIKE
READY FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION IN
THE STORE HEARING -- A VERY
IMPORTANT TOPIC I THINK WE'VE
LEARNED A LOT TODAY AND THERE'S
SO MUCH TO FOLLOW UP ON RICHARD